WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE MEETING
FOR NATURAL RESOURCES -- I JUST
SAW MISTER MAYNES.
WHO IS NOT READY TO HAVE ANOTHER
AUTHOR ASSIGNED AN AUTHOR READY?
OKAY SOON AS WE HAVE AN AUTHOR
WILL BEGIN THE HEARING IF THERE
ANY AUTHORS WHO ARE WATCHING ANY
MEMBERS WHO ARE WATCHING THE
COMMITTEE.
WHO HAVE SIGNED IN AND HAVE A
BILL THIS IS YOUR CHANCE
?
ANY AUTHORS WHO HAVE A BILL IN
NATURAL RESOURCES PLEASE COME
AND PRESENT YOUR BILL
.
MR BERMAN WELCOME WE ARE -- DO
NOT OF A QUORUM YET WE'RE GONNA
BE BEGINNING AS A SUB COMMITTEE --
BUT YOU'RE WELCOME 2%.
AND TODAY YOU WILL BE PRESENTING
[inaudible]
ON ON
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO I
REALIZE THAT EASY WAYS OF TRACKS
IN THE NATION.
THE PROPOSED EXEMPTION UNDER
THIS BILL SHOULD NOT.
BECAUSE THE EXISTING SIMPLE
GUIDELINES ALREADY PROVIDED
SIMILAR.
I BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE REASONS
WHY THESE THINGS.
ARE REALLY -- PERSON SIMILAR
ACQUISITION OF LANDS ABOUT
EXHAUSTION OF USE.
WOULD NOT AND COULD NOT HAVE AN
EXACT SECOND REQUIRED
[inaudible] FOR RESULT. ONE IS.
RESOURCES.
THIRD.
OVER.
THE TO ACQUIRE LAND FROM A
WILLING LANDOWNER TO PROTECTED
IN PERPETUITY FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS DOES NOT STAY OPEN
VERY LONG.
THE EXEMPTION IS NEEDED BECAUSE
RECENT LAWSUITS HAVE CREATED
UNCERTAINTY.
YOU CAN GO
.
THANK YOU AND I I EIGHT I THINK
THAT YOUR MICROPHONE IS OFF FOR
THE ROOM I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S ON
FOR COULD YOU HEAR HIM IN THE
BACK.
NO THE MICRA SO IF IF WE CAN TRY
TO WORK ON THE TECHNICAL ISSUES
SO THAT.
TRY SPEAKING AGAIN TESTING
TESTING THEIR AGO OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY WE GOT IT.
OKAY NO I DO THAT ALL OVER AGAIN
NO NO.
IT WAS GREAT BY THE WAY -- DO WE
NEED TO HAVE HIM DO IT AGAIN FOR
ANY LEGAL REASONS.
IT WAS IT WAS IT ON THE TO ON
THE TELEVISION.
WAS IT PICKED UP BY THE TO HELP.
THEY DO HAVE IT.
DAVID NOW.
DO THEY HAVE IT WHEN HE WAS
SPEAKING.
IN THE OPENING STATEMENT.
I YEAH I WAS JUST TOLD THAT FROM
THE OPENING STATEMENT AND IT
DOES NOT NEED TO TO BE I'M
PRESENTING AB SEVENTY TWO IT'S A
GREAT BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I THINK IT WOULD THAT WILL
GO TO YOUR WITNESS.
EACH WITNESS WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ANNE
DEISTER AND I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF LAND TRUSTS ALSO
KNOWN AS C. CLT.
AND WE ARE THE PROUD SPONSOR OF
AB.
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO SEE SEE ALTES
MISSION IS TO CONSERVE
CALIFORNIA'S EXTRAORDINARY LAND
AND WATER RESOURCES THROUGH A
STRONG NETWORK OF LAND TRUST
WITH ONE COHESIVE BOYS ACROSS
URBAN AND RURAL COMMUNITIES.
WE SERVE A UNIFIED VOICE FOR
MORE THAN A HUNDRED FIFTY LAND
TRUST WORKING THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
WE SEE A FUTURE WHERE ALL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT SHARE A
COMMON CONSERVATION ETHIC.
AND BENEFIT FROM HAVING ACCESS
TO CLEAN WATER HEALTHY FOOD
PARKS AND OTHER NATURAL LANDS
WHERE THEY LIVE.
AB SEVEN EIGHTY TWO IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO THIS
MISSION.
AS YOU JUST HEARD FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN THERE HAVE
BEEN RECENT SEE QUIRK LAWSUITS
THAT HAVE CREATED UNCERTAINTY
FOR STATE AGENCIES SEEKING TO
PROTECT LAND IN PERPETUITY FOR
CONSERVATION PURPOSES.
AND THIS HAS THE POTENTIAL OF
SETTING A VERY TROUBLING
PRECEDENT -- FOR PROTECTING
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS FOR
WATER SUPPLY ENDANGERED SPECIES
AND AGRICULTURAL USES AND TO
ACHIEVE CLIMATE GOALS.
COURTS IN SOME OF THESE CASES OF
HOW THE PUBLIC AGENCIES VIOLATED
SEE QUIRK SIMPLY BY AGREEING TO
PURCHASE THE LAND WITHOUT ANY
ANALYSIS.
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF
POTENTIAL RESTORATION OR
PRESERVATION ACTIVITIES.
AB SEVEN EIGHTY TWO WOULD END
THIS UNCERTAINTY BY CLARIFYING
THAT PUBLIC AGENCIES MAY ACQUIRE
LAND FOR CONSERVATION PURPOSES
INCLUDING THE CRITICAL PROCESS
OF OBTAINING GRANT FUNDING FOR
THE ACQUISITION.
WITHOUT FIRST CONDUCTING
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW BUT ONLY SO
LONG AS THE PUBLIC AGENCY HAS
COMMITTED TO FULLY COMPLY WITH
SYKORA PRIOR TO COMMENCING ANY
PHYSICAL CHANGE TO THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THIS BILL WOULD THAT'S RESTORE
THE COMMON PRACTICE PRIOR TO THE
MORE RECENT LINE OF CASES.
AND WOULD PROVIDE A BRIGHT LINE
RULE FOR COURTS LAND TRUSTS
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND THE PUBLIC
TO FOLLOW.
AB SEVEN EIGHTY TWO WOULD NOT
CREATE A NEW SIBLING SEPARATE
EXEMPTION OR EXPAND AN EXISTING
EXEMPTION.
RATHER IT WOULD SIMPLY CODIFIED
THE REGULATORY GUIDANCE ALREADY
PROVIDED IN SEQUEL GUIDELINES.
C. CLT WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR CURING
THIS LEGISLATION.
IN OUR VIEW THIS ABSOLUTELY OF
STATEWIDE INTEREST TO OUR STATE
AGENCIES TO ACQUIRE VALUABLE
RESOURCE PLANS WHEN THOSE
LIMITED OPPORTUNITIES BECOME
AVAILABLE AND AB SEVENTY TWO
WOULD PROVIDE THE CLARITY AND
THE LAW. FOR SIMPLE ACQUISITION
OF RESOURCE PLANS TO BE EXEMPT
FROM SICKLE REVIEW WHILE ALSO
CRITICALLY ENSURING THAT FULL
SEQUEL COMPLIANCE MUST OCCUR.
PRIOR TO THE AGENCY MAKING ANY
PHYSICAL CHANGES TO THE PROPERTY
FOR ALL THESE REASONS WE URGENT
HI VOTE THANK YOU BEFORE WE
CONTINUE WITH THE HEARING I'M
GOING TO TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HERE.
FRIEDMAN HERE FLORA.
CHAU CHOW HERE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE GARCIA.
THE MOON.
THE MOON HERE MATHIS THEIR
MATHIS HERE MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ LENDERS HERE ROUTE TO
CHEAT.
MURATSUCHI HERE STONE.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
RECALL MUSTARD AN AUTO WITH THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND HIS STAFF AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOUR STAFF WHO MADE
THEMSELVES AVAILABLE TO US ON A
NUMBER OF TIME OCCASIONS TO WORK
THROUGH THE LANGUAGE AND
AMENDMENTS THAT.
WE'VE ACCEPTED ON A AND
COMMITTEE TODAY.
THE ONLY THING I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT HAD MAYBE A OR PUT A
POINT.
TO IS THE STATE HAS A LOT OF
AGGRESSIVE CONSERVATION GOALS WE
HAVE A A NUMBER OF GUIDING
DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE COME OUT IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS AROUND
CLIMATE AROUND.
WATER ACTION PLAN WILDLIFE
ACTION PLAN SAFEGUARDING
CALIFORNIA.
AIR BE JUST PUT OUT A NATURAL
WORKING LANCE CLIMATE --
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN THEY ALL
HAVE -- AS A KEY COMPONENT TO
THOSE PLANS THE ABILITY TO
CONSERVE.
OCCUR BY ACQUISITION OR BY
EASEMENT ON HIGH VALUE RESOURCE
LAND.
AND AGENCIES HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
BE NIMBLE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
AND THE HIGH A PASTE REAL ESTATE
MARKET AND THAT'S WHAT THE SPOT
AB SEVENTY TWO AS A ALLOWING
FOREIGN PROVIDING.
FOR SO I JUST OR DRIVE VOTE AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
PEARL PROMOTER FROM CHIU MOLLY
WEINBERGER AND I I'VE WORKED
WITH THE AUTHORED OFFICE IN THE
SPONSORS TELL CRAFTED IN.
IN JUST HERE IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT TAKING ALL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU WITHOUT WILL ASK
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE -- TO
A SUPPORT.
GROUP THREE DATA.
CHAIR MEMBERS READ OUT US WITH
SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE FRIENDS
OF LOS ANGELES RIVER IN MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT HERE IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JUST MILAN
FOR THE COMMUTER LINES WITH
FAMILY FARMERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MARK
FENSTER AKER FOR THE PENINSULA
OPEN SPACE TRUST IN STRONG
SUPPORT WE'RE DRIVE OUT THANK
YOU.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MARK SMITH ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GET AFTERNOON JAMIE GO ON BEHALF
OF AUDUBON CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA RELIEF AND SUPPORT.
GET AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MATTHEW BAKER
PLANNING CONSERVATION THE
INSTRUCTOR POOR THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS LOOK AT FACTS ON BEHALF
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND ALSO
THE PACIFIC FORCE TRUST AND IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON VANESSA GONZALEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND LISA VERO
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CURABLE RODRIGUEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA OPEN
SPACE COUNCIL IN THE CAL AND THE
BUSINESS COUNCIL OR JUNIOR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRED AND ALSO
SIERRA CLUB IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MOVE THE BILL.
THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY WE HAVE A A MOTION A SECOND
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
THE AUTHOR WERE ANY OF THE
WITNESSES.
FACING THEN WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE.
IF YOU WANT TO BUY THE CLOTHES
OUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE NOT
AT ALL RESPECT OTHER I'VE ONLY
[inaudible]
GOOD CLOSELY.
OKAY ITEM NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA.
CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA LIMON.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ LENDERS I WROTE TO
CHEAT.
RED TO GI STONE. SEVEN ZERO
THANK YOU YOUR BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAILY.
WITH AB.
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT THE MANAGER
MEMBERS.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE WORK --
WITH ME AND I'M WILLING TO TAKE
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS LABORS
ANY AB ONE SEVEN EIGHT THAT WILL
CREATE A NARROW EXEMPTION. FOR
THE MANDATORY SOLAMENTE FOR
PEOPLE HAVE LOST THEIR HOMES DUE
TO CATASTROPHIC EVENT.
WHEN A STATE OF EMERGENCY HAS
BEEN DECLARED BY THE GOVERNOR?
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCE SEVERAL
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
THE IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
WHICH IS TO ABOUT ONE POINT SIX
MILLION ACRES OF LAND AND
THOUSANDS OF HOME.
SEVERAL OF THESE HOMES WERE
UNDER INSURED AND WITH ALL THE
INCREASED COST OF THIRTY WITH
REBUILDING DUE TO THE NEW
BUILDING STANDARDS.
AND MAKING IT DIFFICULT FOR SOME
TO REBUILD THE COST OF A SOLAR
SYSTEM ALONE CAN ADD UP TO
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND TO
THE COST OF REBUILDING.
AB ONE SEVENTY EIGHT WILL GIVE A
NARROW EXEMPTION FROM THIS
MANDATE TO THOSE WHO MEET.
A CERTAIN CRITERIA THIS WILL
GIVE THEM THE NECESSARY LEAVE
FOR SOME OF THESE PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO REBUILD THEIR HOME AND
START PUTTING THEIR LIVES BACK
TOGETHER OF COURSE.
IF THEY CHOOSE TO INSTALL SOLAR
THEY CAN.
LETS BUT THESE PEOPLE.
LET'S HELP THESE PEOPLE GET BACK
IN THEIR HOMES AND REPAIR THEIR
LIVES I RESPECT THE ASPEN ABOUT.
YES WITH THE THANK YOU YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I WAS THERE ANYBODY WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL
MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND.
HI JOHN KENNEDY WITH RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THE BILL
WE THINK IT'S A GOOD WAY TO
PROVIDE LIMITED RELIEF TO
HOMEOWNERS WHO HAVE LOST
EVERYTHING -- IN AN ERA WHERE
MANY PEOPLE ARE UNDER INSURED
AND OTHERS ARE UNINSURED MANY BY.
WITHOUT THEIR OWN CHOICE WE
THINK THIS HELPS TO MAKE IT A
LITTLE MORE AFFORDABLE TO
REBUILD PEOPLE'S LIVES.
THANK YOU -- ADAM WRIGLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE -- DEFTLY ECHO -- MY
COUNTERPARTS WE SUPPORT THE BILL
WE THINK IT'S COMMONSENSE VERY
NARROW -- RELIEF FOR SOME OF THE
MOST -- DEVASTATED CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON YOU LIKE EVER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS WERE NOT REFLECTED
IN THE ANALYSIS BUT WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M VICTORIA ROME WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL REGRETFULLY IN
OPPOSITION AND WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SIT DOWN WITH
MISTER DALI WE APPRECIATE HIS
TIME AND MEETING WITH US.
BUT WE JUST DISAGREE THAT --
COMPLYING WITH THE SOLAR MANDATE
IS A COST OR BURDEN --
SYMPATHIZE WITH VICTIMS OF WILD
FIRE CERTAINLY BUT WE THINK THAT
ADDING SOLAR -- AND THERE ARE
FLEXIBLE WAYS TO COMPLY WITH THE
REGULATION -- IS ACTUALLY
BENEFIT TO THE HOMEOWNER OVER
THE LIFE OF THEIR OCCUPANCY OF
THAT HOME THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WANTING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
LAUREN COLUMN WITH SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA.
CIRCLE CALIFORNIA MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT THIS BILL IS A
STEP BACKWARDS FROM CALIFORNIA'S
ENERGY EFFICIENCY GOALS AND
POLICIES.
THE CDC CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY
COMMISSION HAS ADOPTED BUILDING
STANDARDS THAT WILL HELP REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UP HOLD THESE
BUILDING ENERGY EFFICIENT C.
STANDARDS BECAUSE THOSE
STANDARDS ARE PREPARING
CALIFORNIANS. TO MAKE THE
NECESSARY CHANGES TO FIGHT
CLIMATE CHANGE.
CALIFORNIA IS FEELING THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE IN
MANY WAYS INCLUDING AN
INCREASING AVERAGE AIR
TEMPERATURES AS WELL AS AN
INCREASE IN WILD FIRES AND
DROUGHTS HE'S EXTREME WEATHER
EVENTS PROMPTED THE ADOPTION OF
THESE BUILDING STANDARDS
INCLUDING THE VOTE OF A TAKE
REQUIREMENTS.
ALL THESE UPDATES ARE CRITICAL
TO CALIFORNIA'S OBLIGATION TO
RAPIDLY DE CARBONIZED IT'S HOMES
AND BUILDINGS IN RESPONSE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE.
WE ARE SYMPATHETIC WITH THE
VICTIMS OF RECENT WILDFIRES AND
RECOGNIZE THE FINANCIAL BURDEN
OF REBUILDING.
THE CAMPFIRE THE DEADLIEST AND
MOST DESTRUCTIVE FIRE IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY ALL BUT
OBLITERATED THE TOWN OF PARADISE.
ON FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND
PARADISE HELD ITS FIRST IN A
SERIES OF PLANNING WORKSHOPS ON
REBUILDING THE INFRASTRUCTURE
LOST IN THE FIRE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
WERE IN ATTENDANCE.
THE RESIDENTS EXPRESSED
ENTHUSIASM FOR REBUILDING THE
TOWN EMPHASIZING THE IMPORTANCE
OF IT HEARING TO CURRENT
BUILDING CODES AS OF MANY OF THE
NEWER DEVELOPMENTS.
SURVIVE THE FIRE.
THE RESIDENTS ALSO VOICED THEIR
INTEREST IN EXPANDING RENEWABLE
ENERGY IN THEIR TOWN IN AN
EFFORT TO CREATE MORE ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE AND LESS RELIANCE
ON LARGE SCALE ENERGY UTILITY
COMPANIES.
THE RESIDENTS OF THE TOWN OF
PARADISE WANT TO REBUILD.
BETTER THAN BEFORE CREATING A
MORE RESILIENT SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY WAS SAFE HOMES THAT
WILL STAND THE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WANTING TO SPEAK AGAINST THE
BILL.
OKAY WITH THAT I WILL NOW TURN
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGS.
THANK YOU BUT IN THANK YOU
MISTER DALI AND WHILE I
APPRECIATE THE OPPONENTS --
POSITION I ALSO HAVE VISITED
THAT AREA QUITE A FEW TIMES AND
SO MANY OTHER PLACES WHERE WE'VE
SEEN THE DESTRUCTION OF THE
WILDFIRES.
AND CERTAINLY WE WANT PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO GET BACK IN HOMES AND
IDEALLY THEY'VE WITH SOLAR ON
THE ROOFTOP OF SOMETIMES
INSURANCES DON'T QUITE.
PENCIL OUT AND THAT KIND OF WAY.
AND SO MASS WAS HIGHER HE WOULD
SAY THAT WE PUT SOME OF OUR
HIGHER ASPIRATIONAL GOALS ON THE
VERY TOP ONLY KEEP THEM THERE
BUT THAT WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
SURE.
THAT PEOPLE HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO
LIVE ALSO SO -- IS ALREADY BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED BUT I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY AND
AND THANK YOU FOR FINDING A WAY
TO SPREAD THAT NEEDLE TO MAKE
SURE WE KEEP OUR CLIMATE GOALS
IN MIND.
BUT THAT WE ALSO MAKE ALLOWANCES
FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO GET
BACK IN THEIR HOMES THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU SOME EVER
SEARCHING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITH THE THE CHAIRS INDULGENCE I
WANTED TO SEE -- IF WE CAN GET
THE REPRESENT FROM THE NATIONAL
RESEARCH RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL BACK UP HERE
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SOME IS WRONG MY I APPRECIATE.
TO YOUR POINT THAT TO OVER THE
LIFE OF THE HOME.
THE THE ARGUMENT IS THAT.
THE ARE GOING SOLAR WOULD -- BE
A COST SAVINGS BUT WE WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
MEDIA READ REBUILDING HERE --
WHAT WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE?
TO YOU KNOW THE TEN THOUSAND
ESTIMATED -- IMMEDIATE COSTS OF
REBUILDING.
IS IT OKAY IF I HAVE MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER DEL FORGE SPEAK
TO THAT [inaudible]
SURE OF THERE ARE MANY WAYS.
TO YEAH.
THIS IS YOU INTRODUCE YOURSELF
THE OTHER FOR THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL.
THERE ARE SEVERAL WAYS IN THE
BUILDING CODE TO MEET THE SOLAR
REQUIREMENTS ONE OF IT IS ONE OF
THOSE WAYS IS LEASING.
WHERE -- THE PANELS CAN --
BECAUSE ZERO MONEY UP FRONT WAS
STILL SAVING OVER THE LIFE OF
THE BUILDING -- SO AT THIS
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW TO ACHIEVE
THAT AND IT DOESN'T THIRTY OUT
COST TO THE FIRST CLOSE TO THE
BUILDING.
OKAY AND DO A MASCOT -- MISTER
DAHLE IF YOU CAN RESPOND TO THAT.
BUT I'D LOVE TO SO FIRST OFF
NUMBER ONE I'M NOT -- THIS BILL
IS IS ONLY REDUCING THE SOLAR
MANDATE NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO WE
ARE WE WANT THEM TO REBUILD A
HOME THERE'S GONNA BE FIRE
RESILIENT.
AND SAFE THAT'S WITH THE NEW
STANDARDS WE HAVE THAT.
SO -- THERE ARE THERE ARE
PROGRAMS -- FOR FOLKS TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF BUT IT'S AT
THE COST THE TAXPAYER AND ALSO I
WANT TO JUST MENTION ONE THING
THAT I THINK IS.
THE ELEPHANT ROOM IS THAT.
WE HAVE WHAT WE CALL THE DOT
KIRBY MANY OF YOUR FAVORITE FROM
HERE THAT THAT WERE PRODUCING
MORE SOLID THAN WE ACTUALLY NEED
AND WE HAVE THE VALLEY IF THEY
WERE IF THERE WAS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BE ABLE.
TO FILL IN THAT GAP AT THE
BOTTOM I THINK IT WOULD BE
TOTALLY PROBATE BUT AT BUT YOU
REALLY NEED TO UNDERSTAND IS
THAT.
INSURANCE COMPANIES DON'T COVER
IT THESE PEOPLE ARE STRAPPED TO
TRY TO GET BACK INTO THEIR HOMES
WITH THE NEW ALREADY ADDED
BUILDING CENTERS THAT WE SHOULD.
ENFORCE THAT MAKE THEIR HOME
SAFER TO FIRE SOLAR DOES NOT DO
THAT IT SIMPLY.
HAD TO COST OF THEM IF THEY
CHOOSE TO WANT.
TO APPLY TO ONE OF THESE
PROGRAMS IT AND IT FITS FOR THEM
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO THAT WE ARE
NOT LIMITING IT TO THAT THEY
CAN'T TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A
PROGRAM THAT THEY MAY WANT.
TO BUT WE DON'T WANT TO FORCE
THEM TO HAVE TO TAKE SOLAR WHERE
IT MAY IMPACT THE COST UP FRONT
FOR THEM ON THEIR HOMES OR
SIMPLY JUST TRYING.
TO GIVE THEM THE ABILITY.
TO EITHER USED EXEMPTION OR NOT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- MISTER
DALI DO YOU TO YOUR KNOWLEDGE DO
SOLAR PANELS INSTALLED ON A
ROOFTOP.
MAKE THE HOUSE FIRE RESISTANT.
NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE.
THANK YOU SO THEN THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAVE BEEN
HEARING SO FAR OR ABOUT --
ENERGY DEPENDENCE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS THAT WE HAVE HOLD THE ENERGY
STANDARDS THAT CALIFORNIA IS
ALREADY SET -- I DON'T QUITE
UNDERSTAND [inaudible]
HOW?
PEOPLE CAN COME IN HERE AND
DISCUSS THIS WITH A STRAIGHT
FACE AND NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE NOW
OUT OF THE HOME.
YOU DON'T HAVE AN EXTRA TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS LYING AROUND OR
A NICE SUIT TO WEAR TO COME IN
AND TESTIFY IN A COMMITTEE TO
TALK ABOUT HOW YOU CAN FINANCE
SOLAR PANELS.
I THINK WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT IS
THAT WE GET PEOPLE BACK IN THEIR
HOMES.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY ASPECT OF THIS ONCE
PEOPLE ACTUALLY GET THEIR LIVES
BACK THIS IS A VERY SMALL ASK
YOU HAVE ACCEPTED COMMITTEE A
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
WHICH I I WOULD JUST SAY THAT.
THESE ARE DISAPPOINTING. TO SAY
THE LEAST BUT YOU HAVE TO DO
WHAT YOU HAVE TO DEAL KNOW
EVERYBODY HAS TO WORK TOGETHER.
SO I'M GLAD YOU'RE ABLE TO DO
THAT BUT WHAT IS MOST IMPORTANT
RIGHT NOW IS TO GET THESE PEOPLE
BACK IN THEIR HOMES.
AND NOT -- NOT FOCUSED ON ENERGY
REGULATIONS AND EFFICIENCIES
BECAUSE FRANKLY THAT IS --
MONUMENTALLY INCONSIDERATE TO
THOSE WHO HAVE LOST THEIR HOMES
I'LL BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL THANK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OKAY WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SPENT
LAST FOREVER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM THREE AB ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THIS AMENDED.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I LIVE ALONE.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MULLIN DESIGN
MURATSUCHI.
REAL TWO G. AYE STONE. EIGHT
ZERO THANK YOUR BILL IS OUT HERE
WE'RE GONNA NOW TURN -- TO I'D
LIKE A MOTION FROM SOMEONE
PLEASE ON THE COMMITTEE RULES ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE -- AND
AND SO WILL FIRST TAKE THE CAN
THE COMMITTEE RULES.
THE MOTION IS SECOND TO THE
COMMITTEE RULES.
MADAM CHAIRMAN FOR WE TAKE A A
VOTE I JUST WANT TO SPEAK I
THINK I SPEAK FOR SOME WOMEN
MATHIS AS WELL WE'VE DONE THIS
AND OTHER COMMITTEES.
SINCE THE ASSEMBLY HAS TAKEN --
DEVOTED TO TO GIVE CHAIR MEMBERS.
THE ABILITY TO HEAR OR NOT HERE
A BILL I'M WITH IS NOT ISRAEL
WITH WHICH WE DISAGREE -- I WILL
BE VOTING NO ON THE RULES AS
THEY ARE RIGHT NOW JUST SO YOU
KNOW OKAY.
OKAY OKAY THE MOTION IS TO ADOPT
THE NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
RULES FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY LEGISLATIVE
SESSION MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA I LIVE
ALONE.
MATHIS NO MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MULLIN HAS NO MERIT TO
CHOOSE.
RIGHT TO G. AYE STONE
[inaudible] SEVEN TWO THANK YOU
IN WITH THAT -- IF THEY'RE A
MOTION FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEC WITH MOTION THE SECOND WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
HI GARCIA GARCIA I THE MON.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ.
LENDERS IRA TO TREAT.
RIGHT TO GI STONE. EIGHT ZERO
OKAY THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
NOW WE WILL MOVE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING.
WITH AB.
ONE SIXTY ONE HE SEEMS TO HAVE A
VERY LARGE RECEIPT WITH HIM.
WELCOME THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
PROUD TO THE AUTHOR AB ONE SIXTY
ONE ARE SKIPPED THE SLIP BILL
WHICH WILL REQUIRE STARTING IN
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THAT THIS IS A
LIFE CUSTOMERS HE RECEIVED BY
DEFAULT IN PAPER RECEIPTS UPON.
REQUEST OUT WE ARE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TO CARVE
OUT HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS IN THE
FINE INVOICE AND PREFER
PURCHASED SO.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
MADAM CHAIR AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF TIME.
WE ALSO WORKED ON AMENDMENTS TO
FIRST DO A NUMBER OF THINGS ONE
IS.
TO CARVE OUT CASH ONLY
BUSINESSES AS WELL AS SMALL
BUSINESSES WITH GROSS RECEIPTS
UNDER A MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT'S VERY SIMILAR TO A
DEFINITION THAT WE USED IN SAN
FRANCISCO TO TO FIND SMALL
BUSINESSES I'M IN THE SONG
BEVERLY CREDIT CARD ACT TO ALLOW
CUSTOMERS TO SHERIDAN FINALLY AT
THE IDENTIFIABLE.
INFORMATION OR TO GET THE
RECEIPT ALSO ALLOW CUSTOMERS TO
RECEIVE A PAPER RECEIPT WITH
FEDERAL OR STATE LAW SUPPLY.
IT SHOWS THAT THE BILL DOESN'T
CHANGE THE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
UNDER THE SCOPE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT --
ALSO THE ECOLOGIST GENERALLY
SUPPORT LAST TO THE FACT THAT
93% OF RECEIPT PAPERS ARE COATED
WITH BPA OR P. P. S..
A AND WALLPAPER MANUFACTURES
THEY ARGUE THAT THERE ARE NO
LONGER USING B. P. HEY -- B. P.
S. IS SEEN AS A SIMILAR.
REPLACEMENT WHICH IS -- BEEN
DEEMED ASKED SIMILARLY TOXIC BY
WASHINGTON STATE UNIVERSITY
GENETICIST.
ADDITIONALLY GREEN AMERICA
COMMISSION TO STUDY WHICH FOUND
THAT.
OVER THREE MILLION TREES AND
NINE BILLION GALLONS OF WATER IN
THE U. S. IS TO CREATE.
PAPER RECEIPTS -- SO THESE ARE --
TOTALLY UNNECESSARY AND IF YOU
TALK TO RECYCLERS MANY RECYCLERS.
HAVE DIFFICULTY RECYCLING THE
PAPER RECEIPTS BECAUSE THEY ARE
VERY SMALL AND THEIR SYSTEMS
HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME CATCHING
THEM.
ALSO FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
THROWING THE RECEIPT IN THE
COMPOST -- THESE RECEIPTS ARE
NOT COMPOSTABLE BECAUSE OF THE
PPA AND THE PPS CHEMICALS
THROUGH ARE ACTUALLY REAL
WINNING YOUR COMPOST ON THE
OPPOSITION WILL ALSO TALK ABOUT
HOW THE RECEIPTS ARE RENEWABLE
BECAUSE TREES ARE RENEWABLE.
AND BY RENEWABLE THEY MEAN BY
WHAT YOU CUT THE TREES YOU CAN
REPLANT THEM AND THAT'S THEIR
DEFINITION OF RENEWABLE WHICH I
I DISAGREE WITH SO.
WITH THAT WE HAVE TO WITNESSES.
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB.
ONE SIXTY ONE THANK YOU AND THE
WITNESSES AND PAPER HAVE. TWO
MINUTES APIECE.
I GOT TEN O'CLOCK THIS OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT FOR A
COUPLE SIMPLE REASONS.
CALIFORNIA'S RECYCLING SYSTEM IS
REALLY AT A CROSSROADS FOR THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS WE RELY ON
OVERSEAS MARKETS TO TAKE ALL OF
OUR RECYCLABLES.
AS CHINA AND OTHER COUNTRIES
HAVE SAID THAT THEY NO LONGER
WANT TO TAKE THAT THAT
CONTAMINANTS THAT WE SEND ALONG
WITH OUR RECYCLABLES.
MANY CITIES ARE FORCED TO
RETHINK ABOUT -- RETHINK WHAT
THEY ARE COLLECTING IN THEIR
SYSTEMS.
AND IT REALLY IS FORCING US TO
THE STATE TO RETHINK OUR WHOLE
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE.
PART OF THAT IS FOCUSING ON THE
FIRST ARE IN THE THREE R'S AND
THAT'S REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF
WASTE WE GENERATE.
IF FOR LOOKING AT REDUCING WASTE
PROBABLY THE EASIEST THING WE
CAN DO IS GET RID OF THE THE
MATERIALS THAT SOMEBODY HANDS TO
US THAT WE DON'T WANT.
THAT WE HOLD ON TO UNTIL WE GET
TO NEXT TRASH CAN AND THROW AWAY --
THIS BILL DOES NOT PANDER SEATS
IT JUST SAYS THE RECEIPTS MUST
BE PROVIDED ONLY TO THOSE WHO
ACTUALLY WANT THEM WHICH IS A
VERY COMMON SENSE MOVE.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I'M BILL
ALLEY -- WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP -- THIS BILL
THERE'S A HEALTH ISSUE HERE AND
IT'S BEEN DOUBLE REFER BUT NOT
TO HEALTH COMMITTEE AND I THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE TO QUICKLY
ADDRESS THAT HERE -- THESE
RECEIPTS HAVE BISCAYNE ALL A OR
BISCAYNE ALL ELSE IN THEM IT FOR
A WHILE WE WERE SAYING BPA FREE
RECEIPTS IT TURNS OUT THAT BE PS.
MUCH LIKE DRINKING WATER BOTTLES
NOW SAY BPA FREE MOST OF THEM
HAVE BE PS ARE BISCAYNE ALL ELSE.
BUT SCIENCE IS SHOWING US THAT
BPA HAS REALLY NEGATIVE EFFECTS
ON PREGNANT FOR PREGNANT WOMEN
FETUSES AND ADULTS -- AND
SOMETHING LIKE 90% OF AMERICANS
THAT BP AND THEIR URINE WE WERE
ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE TO
LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY ELEVEN THE
THE DAMAGING IMPACTS OF THE PA
AND THEY'VE VOTED TO BAN PPA IN
BABY BOTTLES.
THAT WAS SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR --
BE PS MAY BE JUST AS BAD IT MAY
BE HOLDING YOUR BODY LAST TIME
THAT A STRONGER ESTROGENIC
EFFECTS.
ON OVER 80% OF AMERICANS THAT BP
ASSN THEIR URINE AND SO THERE
ARE HORMONAL EFFECTS OF SUSHI
WITH THIS WE THINK IT'S A GOOD
IDEA TO NOT HAVE PEOPLE TOUCHING.
THEM ESPECIALLY CASHIERS UP ALL
DAY A CONTACT WITH THESE
RECEIPTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
OF THE DID RECEIVE COALITION.
INCLUDING COMPANIES OF CALM CASH
AND RECEIVE ME IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JAMIE GO ON
BEHALF OF A SOUL IN SUPPORT.
THERESA BROKERAGE ON BEHALF OF
SAVE OUR SHORES AND SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE EVAN ON BEHALF OF
SEVEN GENERATION ADVISERS IN
PLASTIC POLLUTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
READ A MONSTER DO NOT A WITH THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND IN SUPPORT.
FOR CALLING THE SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
AND ONLY SERVER -- DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
READ OUT AS WITH BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES HERE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION.
AND AGAIN THREE WITNESSES WITH
TWO MINUTES APIECE.
OR FOR WITNESSES WITH SIX
MINUTES BETWEEN YOU.
OTHER FOR WITNESSES ARE. THREE
THREE OKAY -- THREE HI MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MET CERTAIN
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL -- WE BELIEVE THAT
PROPOSING A MANDATORY ELECTRONIC
OR SEEN AS THE DEFAULT
TRANSACTION AS A RECORD BETWEEN
THE CONSUMER IN THE BUSINESS IT
COMES WITH UNIQUE IMPACTS FOR
THE RESTAURANT COMMUNITY.
IT MAY SEEM THAT THESE
ELECTRONIC RECEIPTS ARE SUPER
COMMON PLACE AND THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT SOME RESTAURANTS
USE THEM IN SOME BUSINESSES USE
THEM.
BUT THEY ARE NOT WIDESPREAD AND
IT DOESN'T CHANGE WITH THE FLIP
OF A SWITCH THERE'S A LOT THAT
GOES ON THE BACK AND IT'S QUITE
COSTLY.
SO I JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY WALK
YOU THROUGH THAT.
A LITTLE BIT IS CERTAINLY A LOT
OF THE GOAL TO GO -- AND ADDRESS
PAPER WASTE BUT THIS COMES WITH
A LOT OF FINANCIAL COST
LOGISTICAL HURDLES -- AND SOME
CONSUMER PRIVACY IMPACTS THAT WE
WANTED TO ADDRESS HERE TODAY --
MOST BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ARE USING SOME SORT OF
POINT OF SALE SYSTEM.
NOT ALL POINT OF SALE SYSTEMS
ARE EQUIPPED NOW TO DEAL WITH
ELECTRONIC RECEIPTS AND SO WHAT
IT OFTEN REQUIRES IS A SOFTWARE
UPGRADE OR A FULL CHANGEOVER OF
A POINT OF SALE SYSTEM AND THE
NUMBERS THAT WE KEEP HEARING.
FROM INDEPENDENT RESTAURANTS OR
SOMEWHERE IN BETWEEN THE THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND AND FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR LEVEL TO EITHER DO THE
SOFT GRADE OR MORE EXPENSIVELY
TO SWAP OUT THE POINT OF SALE
SYSTEM.
SO THE BOTTOM LINE IS THE WAY
THIS BILL IS STRUCTURED I KNOW
IT'S BEEN SAID IT MANY TIMES
THAT IT'S IT'S IT'S AN OPTION.
OUT OF THE GATE IT'S A MANDATE
THAT YOU HAVE TO PROVIDE AN
AVENUE FOR THE ELECTRONIC
RECEIPT THAT'S WHERE THE COST
IMPLICATIONS COMMON RESTAURANTS.
AT THE SAME TIME YOU CONTINUE TO
OFFER THE SAME LANE THAT YOU
HAVE NOW WHICH IS THE
TRADITIONAL PAPER RECEIPT SO IT
IS A MANDATE TO GO DOWN THAT
ROAD OF UPGRADING YOUR SOFTWARE
IN YOUR LACK CONICS WHICH AGAIN
COMES AT GREAT COST.
IT COMES AT GREAT COST TO
INDEPENDENT RESTAURANTS AND EVEN
IF YOU'RE IN A FRANCHISE MODEL
THAT FRANCHISE IS TREATED AS AN
INDIVIDUAL BUSINESS BY THE
CORPORATION IN MANY CASES SO
THOSE COSTS ARE BORNE.
BY THE INDIVIDUAL FRANCHISEE OR
FRANCHISE OR LOGISTICS IF YOU
IMAGINE A FAST PACE RESTAURANT
ENVIRONMENT WITH A FAST CASUAL
OR A QUICK SERVICE TYPE
RESTAURANT.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO ASK THAT EACH
TRANSIT ACTS EACH TRANSACTION
TAKE MORE TIME BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO BE ASKING -- FOR EMAIL
OR CELL PHONE INFORMATION OR
SOME PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION TO GET SOMEONE
ELECTRONIC RECEIPT.
THAT'S GOT LOGISTICAL AND
OPERATIONAL PROBLEMS FOR FOR US
ON OUR END AND CERTAINLY
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS THE GUEST
EXPERIENCE.
THE ISSUE APPEARS TO BE DRIVEN
BY PAPER WASTES AND THE STAFF
ANALYSIS ALSO SUGGESTS.
THAT PAPER WASTE FROM THIS FRONT
IS NOT.
DETECTABLE IN CALIFORNIA NOT NOT
QUANTIFIABLE AS IT RELATES TO
PAPER RECEIPTS THE OTHER ISSUE
THAT CONTINUES TO COME UP IS
CHEMICALS.
AND SO I GUESS WE'RE LEFT ASKING
IN RESTAURANTS ON THE GROUND --
LEFT ASKING WHY CAN'T WE USE
TRADITIONAL RECEIPTS AS AN
OPTION THAT DON'T HAVE THE
CHEMICALS IN QUESTION.
THAT'S A FAIR QUESTION.
OTHERWISE WE THINK THAT THIS
MANDATE IMPOSES COSTS ON US --
CREATE SOME PRIVACY CONCERNS FOR
OUR CUSTOMERS AND ALSO
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS THE GUEST
EXPERIENCE IN CERTAIN SITUATIONS
SO WITH THAT WE ARE OPPOSE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CATHOLICS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN FOREST AND
PAPER ASSOCIATION HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
REPRESENTING THE U. S.
MANUFACTURERS AND IMPORTERS OF
RECEIPT PAPER -- WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT SOME OF THE
MISLEADING AND I'M SUBSTANTIATED
STATEMENTS ABOUT PAPER RECEIPTS
PAPER RECEIPTS ARE MADE FROM
FIBER SOURCE FROM SUSTAINABLY
MANAGED FORESTS AND ARE
RECYCLABLE.
RESPONSIBLE SOURCING OF TREE
FIBER THREE SUSTAINABLE FOREST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICE CONTRIBUTES
TO MITIGATING CLIMATE CHANGE.
THROUGH CARBON SEQUESTRATION OF
PROMOTE SPORES BIODIVERSITY.
SHOULD MARKETS FOR PAPER DRY UP
THERE'S A VERY STRONG LIKELIHOOD
THAT THE FOREST LAND WOULD BE
CONVERTED INTO URBAN DEVELOPMENT.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT OF
PAPER SEAT USAGE WRITTEN AND AB
ONE SIXTY ONE TAKE TAKEN
DIRECTLY FROM A REPORT BY GREEN
AMERICA DEMONSTRABLY FLAWED.
THEIR ASSERTIONS ARE SPECULATIVE.
THEIR CLAIMS ARE BASED ON DATA
FROM OUTSIDE NORTH AMERICA AND
THE METHODOLOGY FOR CALCULATING
WATER USE WASTE AND GREENHOUSE
GAS IS NOT PEER REVIEWED.
OR ACCEPTED BY THE LIFE CYCLE
ASSESSMENT COMMUNITY AND SHOULD
NOT BE IN STRIDE AND TO
CALIFORNIA ON RECEIPTS CONTRARY
TO SPEECH IS A CLAIMS ARE FULLY
RECYCLABLE.
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE U. S.
COLLECTIVE RECEIPT PAPER FOR
RECYCLING WE'VE SURVEYED ALL OF
OUR MILLS REGARDING THIS.
NEW YORK CITY FOR EXAMPLE
RECYCLES ON ALL THEIR PAPER
RECEIPTS THEY CAN BE RECYCLED
THE SAME AS MAGAZINE CATALOGS
MAILING OFFICE PAPER.
THE HEALTH CONCERNS ABOUT
EXPOSURE TO PAPER RECEIPTS IS
UNFOUNDED.
US PRODUCERS DO NOT USE BPA IN
THE MANUFACTURING OF RECEIPT
PAPER AND THE MAJOR IMPORTERS DO
NOT IMPORT PAPERS THAT USE BPA
COATINGS.
SCIENTIFIC LITERATURE SUPPORTS
THAT EXPOSURE TO BE PA THROUGH
RECEIPTS IS WITHIN THE PROP
SIXTY FIVE SAFE HARBOR THRESHOLD.
CHEMICAL EXPOSURE AND SAFETY
REQUIRE VERY FACTUALLY INTENSIVE
IN SCIENCE BASED QUESTIONS WHICH
IS WHY WE HAVE THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM AND PROP.
SIXTY FIVE IN CLOSING -- FROM
YOU HEARD FROM THE RESTAURANTS
THE PAPER RECEIPTS -- SHOULD BE
LEFT OPTIONAL AND A CHOICE
BETWEEN RETAILERS AND CONSUMERS.
AND AS MISTER SUTTON --
MENTIONED THAT THE ANALYSIS DOES
POINT OUT THAT YOU DO NOT HAVE
CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC DATA I WOULD
JUST OFFER.
THAT THE PAPER INDUSTRY IN ITS
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN DATA ON A
PAPER RECOVERY U. S. WIDE WAS
AROUND 66%.
PAPERS ONE OF THE MATERIALS THAT
REALLY IS WALKING THE WALK IN
TERMS OF RECOVERING ITS MATERIAL
YOUR TIME TO STAND AND WE WOULD
JUST ARGUE THAT IF YOU WERE
COVERED ALL THE RECEIPT PAPER
YOU'D BE RECOVERING ZERO POINT
3% THANK YOU.
THINK THANK YOU LAST WITNESS.
I AM RENTAL BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA GROWERS ASSOCIATION.
TAKE A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT --
POSITION WE ARE OPPOSE WAS
AMENDED -- PERFORMING A THANK AS
A MEMBER TING AND HIS STAFF --
FOR SUGGESTION THE AMENDMENT
ABOUT THE FEDERAL REGULATIONS
BECAUSE WE HAVE CUSTOMERS WHO --
EXCEPT PUBLIC BENEFITS THAT WE
CAN'T THAT WE HAVE PROVIDED
PAPER SEE -- FOR WE WOODS --
HUMBLY ASKED THAT -- GROCERS BE
EXEMPT FROM THE BILL AND THE
REASON IS THIS -- AS YOUR CALL
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO -- WE CHOSE --
TO PART WITH LEGISLATURE.
TO ELIMINATE THESE OF SINGLE USE
PLASTIC BAGS -- DID A GREAT JOB
THE RHYME A GETTING WASTE OUT OF
THE OUT OF THE WASTE STREAM BUT
WHAT THAT HAS DONE IS BASICALLY --
MADE IT HARDER FOR US TO DISCERN
WHO HAS OR HASN'T BOUGHT -- GOOD
AT OUR STORES -- YOU GO TO A A
REGULAR RETAIL STORE MACY'S ARE
AT NORDSTROM YOU GET A BAG WHEN
YOU GO OUT SO IF YOU HAVE A A
PAPERLESS RECEIPT IT'S EASY TO
SAY.
WHO'S BOUGHT SOMETHING WHO
HASN'T HAD A RESTORE HOWEVER
BECAUSE AT PEOPLE EITHER BRING
YOUR OWN BAG MAYBE THEY WALK OUT
WITH A WITH US -- CART CARRIED
OUT OF THEM ON THEIR OWN -- WE
NEED THAT RECEIPT TO BE ABLE TO
CHECK TO SEE WHO HAS OR HASN'T
BOUGHT SOMETHING -- AND WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THAT CAN BE
DONE WITH A ELECTRONIC RECEIPT.
THE ONLY -- THING WITH THAT IS
THAT THERE MAY BE IN SAYS WERE
SOMEONE DOESN'T HAVE A CELL
PHONE WITH THEM.
THEY MAY BE SITUATION WHERE THE
RECEIPT DOESN'T ARRIVE IN A
TIMELY MANNER SO EVEN IF
SOMEBODY -- WENT AND SECURITY
SAID HEY CAN AS YOUR RECEIPT
THAT MAY NOT HAPPEN WITH THEM IN
A TIMELY MANNER WHICH LEADS TO
DELAYS -- SO AGAIN WE THINK THE
PAPER SEAT AT LEAST FOR GROCERY
STORES BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
BAGS THAT ARE EASILY
IDENTIFIABLE WE JUST WOULD
HUMBLY ASKED THAT -- BECAUSE OF
THAT THAT WE WERE TAKEN OUT OF
THE BILL -- HOPE TO WORK WITH
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO STAFF ON
ON THAT POSSIBLY BUT JUST FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE -- THAT'S OUR
POSITION AND AGAIN WE'RE OPPOSE
US MANY BECAUSE I KNOW THE AND
HOUSES AS A POST SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WHAT'S THE NO WAY OUT.
ORDER GLAD SHE ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE OPPOSED TO DO I THINK THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF ARE WORKING
WITH US ON RECOGNIZING THE
CONFLICT WITH SONG BEVERLY AND
ADDRESSING THAT WE STILL HAVE
SOME ADDITIONAL ISSUES WHICH
PROBABLY MORE APPROPRIATE TO BE
DISCUSSED IN THE PRIVACY
COMMITTEE SWEAR. FOR TO HAVING
THAT DISCUSSION.
IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL CANDLE
KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARING HOUSE.
AND THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION TO ECHO THE
STATEMENT THAT MISS CLASS DEAN --
JUST STATED WE THANK THE AUTHOR
AND HIS STAFF VERY MUCH FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD.
OUR A POSITION IS UNOFFICIALLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED WE'VE
SPOKEN SEVERAL TIMES WITH THE
STAFF IN THE OFFICE VERY QUICK
IT JUST JUST YES ORGANIZATION
YOUR POSITION.
EXACTLY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON
THIS -- IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ADAM WRIGLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
OKAY AARON GIRL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRACTION AND PARKS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
SEAN LEWIS THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION INDEPENDENT BUSINESS
REPRESENTING SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ALSO POST.
AND A SECOND THOUGHTS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION BE PM PM AND THE
FAMILY WHEN MAKERS OF CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION.
MICROBES IN ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF THEATER
OWNERS CALIFORNIA NEVADA IN
OPPOSITION.
ATTENTION STICK UP IN HALF OF
THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
DON CAP GIMMICK YOU CAPTAIN
ASSOCIATES ON HALF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO POST.
SILVIO FOR OUR BEHALF ICONIX IN
OPPOSITION.
KELLY JENSEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FUELS AND CONVENIENCE
ALLIANCE.
SACROILIAC OUT POINTED DOWN THE
SAYS ASIAN WE JUST WANT TO NOTE
ARE APPRECIATION FOR THE AUTHOR
TAKING THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
RELATE TO HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITHOUT WILL TURN OUT
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ANY MEMBERS WITH COMMENTS
QUESTIONS.
SOMEONE NUMBER GARCIA -- I HAVE
A MORE A MORE OF A COMMENT ABOUT
THE ONE MILLION DOLLAR AS THE
DEFINITION FOR SMALL BUSINESS.
AND I KNOW IT IS IN SAN
FRANCISCO WE DON'T REALLY HAVE A
CLEAR DEFINITION HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE'VE SEEN LOTS OF
DIFFERENT THINGS OUT THERE.
I'M NOT SURE.
IF IT'S THE BEST DEFINITION I'M
STILL GOING TO BE VOTING FOR THE
BILL BUT I DO THINK WE NEED TO
REVISIT THAT I WAS SEEING A
LITTLE BIT OF QUICK MATH --
BEFORE I CAME IN AND I THINK
ABOUT COMMUNITIES LIKE SOUTH LA
WHERE THEY HAVE LITTLE MARKETS.
AND I LOOK AT GROSS RECEIPTS
THEY MIGHT BE HITTING CLOSE TO
THAT ONE MILLION DOLLAR ON DOWN
PROBABLY DON'T HAVE THE WIFI IN
THERE AND SO FORTH AND SO.
I JUST WANT US.
TO CONTINUE TO PLAY WITH THE
COMMISSION.
ALONG THE WAY AND SITS WANTED TO
MAKE THAT STATEMENT.
THANK YOU WILL.
A DID YOU WANT TO RESPOND WELL I
JUST THAT JUST TO STATE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE COMMENT --
THAT WAS THE BEST TECHNICIAN WE
HAD BEEN HAPPY TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSION TO SEE IF THERE IS A
A BETTER.
ONE THANK YOU SOME MEMBER AG.
BUT I THINK YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS FOR SHOOTING WE BOTH TO A
LOT OF WORK IN THE SPACE -- AND
I APPRECIATE THE MOMENT TO TAKE
IN ALL PUBLIC SUPPORT THIS TODAY
I'LL.
AND I AND IN OUR CONVERSATION I
SAID I LIKE BY SAID NOPE NO
THANK YOU NO THANK YOU TO THAT
RECEIPTS BUT I'M ALSO IN A LOT
OF STORES IN MY DISTRICT THAT.
DON'T SOMETIMES DON'T THE
INTERNET'S DOWN THEY DON'T HAVE
IT AND AS MS GARCIA SAID.
THEY COULD BE DOING A MILLION
DOLLARS BECAUSE ARE CASHING
PAYCHECK TO DOING ALL KINDS OF
THINGS OUT THERE.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO IN THE
FUTURE AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS OF GET GETTING CLOSER BUT I
APPRECIATE WORK ON IT.
BUT WILL PEOPLE SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYOR CITY
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHANG I APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR GOAL WITH THIS BILL -- I WE
DO WANT TO ASK YOU IF YOU CAN
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED FIRST BY THE THE GROCERS
ASSOCIATION AND I'M THINKING.
WHENEVER I SHOP AT COSTCO I'M
ALWAYS WALKING OUT THE DOOR WITH
THAT MY OF MY RECEIPTS.
COULD COULD YOU RESPOND.
TO THE ADMINISTRATION OF THEIR
BUSINESSES YEAH I HAVE HAPPY TO
I THINK -- AGAIN IT'S THE
RECEIPTS AS THE DEFAULT WITH
PAPER SEATS AS A AS AN OPTION.
WHAT WE WILL BE BELIEVE IS THAT
IF YOU DO WALK OUT?
WITH YOUR PHONE MOST OF US HAVE
OURPHONE WITH US YOU GET THE
RECEIPT ON YOUR PHONE THE
RECEIPTS JUST THERE TO VERIFY
PURCHASE LIKE MISTER MARINO
TALKED ABOUT.
SO WE THINK IT'S EASILY DONE ON
THE PHONE AS WELL AS WITH THE
PAPER SEE.
OKAY AND THEN -- AYE AYE AYE.
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
IMPACT ON THE VERY SMALL BIZ
BUSINESS.
YOU KNOW I I KNOW THAT WERE.
COMFORTABLE LUG ON GOING ACROSS
THE STREET TO CHICORY AND AND
AND YOU KNOW HOW THEY THEY THEY
SEEM TO HAVE THAT DEVICE READILY
AVAILABLE WERE -- YOU KNOW YOU
YOU CAN ASK FOR THE RECEIPT
HEARD OR OR NOT BUT I MEAN.
HOW EXPENSIVE OR INEXPENSIVE IS
THAT TECHNOLOGY THAT THE YOU CAN
SEE MANY SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE
ALREADY MOVED TO THIS TECHNOLOGY
BECAUSE PROBABLY IN THE LONG RUN?
CHEAPER ON THEIR BOTTOM LINE --
MUCH OF THE NEWER TECHNOLOGIES
ACTUALLY COME IN LESS EXPENSIVE
THAN SOME OF THE OLDER OR LEGACY
TECHNOLOGY THAT MANY SYSTEMS
HAVE BEEN IN PLACE WHICH IS WHY
YOU FRANKLY I'VE SEEN.
SO MANY SMALL BUSINESSES I DO
WITH IT TO GET THE TRADITIONAL
QUITE A CREDIT CARD SWIPE OR
MACHINES FROM THE BANKS WAS YOU
KNOW QUITE QUITE COSTLY SAID.
THESE THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY
HAPPENS TO BE LESS EXPENSIVE IN
MY OPINION NOW.
HAVING SAID THAT -- MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT JUST THEY HAVE A
CERTAIN HABIT OF DOING BUSINESS
A CERTAIN WAY SO WHAT WE'VE
TRIED TO DO IS FIND A DEFINITION
SOME NOT TO BE A BURDEN -- TO
SMALL BUSINESS BUT AS YOU CAN
SEE MANY SMALL BUSINESSES EVEN
WITHIN WALKING DISTANCE FROM THE
COUPLE HAVE ALREADY MOVED IN
THIS DIRECTION I THINK.
A LOT OF IT IS REALLY JUST BASED
ON COMFORT WITH TECHNOLOGY ONCE
THEY MOVE IN THIS DIRECTION THEY
FIND OUT IT'S ACTUALLY
INCREDIBLY EASY TO USE SO THEY
ACTUALLY -- HAVE MAY HAVE A
BREAST [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A SOME EVER MATHIS.
THANK YOU MANAGER.
MISTER CHANG.
LOOK AT YOU YOU KNOW I'M A RURAL
GUY.
AND THEN TELL WE GET ROLE
BROADBAND GO AND I'M IN A LOT OF
MY SMALLER BUSINESSES -- SOMEONE
MURDER FEED STORES SO I HAVE THE
SAME CONCERNS -- MISS GARCIA HAS
WITH -- YOU KNOW TECH TALKING
ABOUT THE THE GROSS INCOME OF A
MILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE IF YOU
EVER BOND HEY IT GOES A LOT MORE
THAN THAT REALLY QUICK --
ESPECIALLY IN CELLS IN THESE
PLACES BUT A LOT OF THESE GUYS I
MEAN.
THEY'RE USING DIAL UP INTERNET.
DID JUST TO DO THE CREDIT CARDS
FLIPPER MACHINE.
AND WHEN THAT GOES OUT IN IN
THEIR DOING OTHER THINGS I MEAN.
THIS MIGHT WORK GRAY IN.
THE BAY AREA OR IN LA OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT IF
YOU'RE ON THE COUNTRY LIKE ME.
IT'S NOT AN OPTION BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE ROLE BROADBAND
YET -- WE DON'T HAVE THE FIVE G.
YET WE WE DON'T HAVE THOSE
THINGS WOULD BE NICE.
WE DON'T HAVE AND IT'S THE REST
OF THE STAGE JUST NOT THERE --
MAY AND I UNDERSTAND I
APPRECIATE THE CALL IN AN OPTION.
BUT A I THINK YOU KNOW SOMETIMES
THE THINGS THAT WERE GOOD AND
ARE YOU KNOW BIGGER CITIES DON'T
NECESSARILY WORK.
IN THE COUNTRYSIDE OF A LOT OF
CONCERNS THERE -- THERE ONE
OTHER CONCERN THAT.
THEIR RAISED -- A BROW FOR ME --
TALKING ABOUT WITH WITH THE
CHEMICALS WITH THIS -- BPA B. P.
S. MIGHT MIGHT THE THOUGHT THE
POP IN MY HEAD IS IS THAT IN ALL
THOSE NEW PAPER STRAWS THAT WE
ALL HAVE NOW.
NO NO NO I DON'T I TO
MANUFACTURE I'M JUST YOU KNOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PAVE
RECEIVES PAPER STRAWS SO.
THIS RAISES THE QUESTION.
ANYWAY IN IN INTEL I CAN LOOK AT
THIS IS BEING A VIABLE OPTION
FOR RURAL DISTRICTS AYE I CAN'T
SUPPORT.
NO PRESSURE YOUR COMMENTS AND
WE'D BE HAPPY -- TO AGAIN IT CAN
TO WORK WITH YOU AND FIGURE OUT
HOW.
HOW THIS COULD -- COULD WORK IN
YOUR IN YOUR PART OF THE
DISTRICT.
THANK YOU SOME MEMORABLE ONE
DOES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MISTER
TING -- CAN I JUST ASK.
YOUR GOAL OBVIOUSLY IS TO REDUCE
WASTE WHICH IS IT THAT'S A GOOD
THING BUT GIVEN THE OPPOSITION
IN THE COMMENTS THAT YOU'VE
HEARD TODAY WHICH I'M SURE
YOU'VE HEARD THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS.
MAY I ASK WHAT YOUR OPPOSITION
IS TO ALLOWING -- THE MARKETS TO
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT THEY WANT
TO GO PAPERLESS WHICH AS YOU
STATED MANY STORES HAVE DONE
ALREADY I'M JUST CURIOUS.
WHY YOU THINK THE STATE SHOULD
MANDATE RATHER THAN ALLOWING --
BUSINESSES TO IMPLEMENT THAT
THEMSELVES -- I THINK IT'S A
FAIR POINT.
WHILE WE'VE SEEN INTERESTING
ENOUGH ADOPTION AND A MORE LOCAL
SMALL BUSINESS LEVEL YOU REALLY
HAVEN'T SEEN ADOPTION.
OF MUCH BROADER LEVEL SO -- IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT THE THE
COMPANIES OR THE ENTITIES WITH
FRANKLY THE MOST MEANS IN THE
**** AND THE FACTS ABILITY TO
THIS.
NEW THEORY WITH THE MOST
SOPHISTICATED TECHNOLOGY --
REALLY HAVEN'T DONE IN MY
OPINION THEIR PART TO REALLY
MOVE IN THIS DIRECTION.
OKAY THAT THAT'S A FAIR ENOUGH
POINT -- I WILL JUST SAY THAT.
FOR ME AS A CONSUMER I WANT -- I
JUST WOULD PREFER THAT WE ALLOW
BUSINESSES TO MAKE THIS DECISION
WHETHER THAT'S GOOD FOR THEIR
COMPANY'S BOTTOM LINE OR THAT
SOMETHING THAT THEIR CUSTOMERS
ARE CALLING FOR I THINK WE
SHOULD LET THEM MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS.
I DON'T DISAGREE WITH.
YOU ON THE FACT THAT YOU KNOW
SIX FOOT LONG RECEIPT IS KIND OF
RIDICULOUS BUT BUT I KNOW THAT
THIS BILL IS ALSO GOING TO THE
PRIVACY COMMITTEE WHICH IS
PROBABLY WERE MORE OF MY
CONCERNS ARE.
JUST IN THAT I'M THINKING OF
CERTAIN FAMILY MEMBERS OF MINE
WHO WOULD HAVE GREAT DIFFICULTY.
IN -- GETTING A RECEIPT LIKE
THIS ELECTRONICALLY OR EVEN
BEING ABLE TO FIND IT NOT TO
MENTION THOSE WHO ARE
CATEGORIZING THE RECEIPTS FOR
TAX PURPOSES -- I MEAN THERE'S
PLENTY OF APPS AND AND SOFTWARE
NOW TO DO THAT FOR US BUT NOT
EVERYONE IS.
IS LIKE US YOU KNOW WITH THE YOU
CAN YOU CAN MOVE THROUGH OUR
FUNDS AT OUR COMPUTERS VERY
QUICKLY SO -- SO FOR THAT REASON
THOUGH I'M WITH YA ON THAT YOU
KNOW LESS LESS PAPER THOUGH
TREES ARE IT IS YOUR PAPERS
RENEWABLE SOURCE -- WE WANT TO
DE YOU KNOW REFOREST -- SO
THAT'S A GOOD THING BUT I'M WITH
YOU ON GETTING ON THE WAYS BUT
I'M FORCE I CAN'T BE WITH YOU IN
THE BILL TODAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
IT AGAIN FOR FOR YOUR FAMILY
MEMBERS FRIENDS WHO WANT
RECEIPTS FOR TAX PURPOSES OF
SPECIFIC REASONS.
OBVIOUSLY DOT THAT'S WHAT'S
ABSOLUTELY ALLOWABLE.
WHAT WE DON'T WANT IS YOUR IN
THE COFFEE SHOP IN THE RECEIPT
GETS PRINTED YOU YOU HAVE NO NO
NEED FOR THAT?
THE RECEIPT IN THE COFFEE SHOP
COULD NOT RETURN THE COFFEE --
SO AGAIN IN THOSE KINDS OF
CIRCUMSTANCES WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT OKAY DO WE CAN WE CAN
WE REALLY -- NOT HAVE THAT PAPER
WASTE YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN I'VE
BEEN IN SITUATIONS WHERE AS MY
COLLEGES DOCTORS THAT YOU SAY NO
RECEIPTS BUT WHAT THEY DO IS
THEY PUT THE RECEIPT OUT NO
RECEIPT OKAY THEY TAKE IN THE
THIRD WAY.
SO AGAIN -- WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE MUCH
MORE MONEY.
SAYS AND I'M.
MY CONCERN IS THAT I NOW IT'S
OPTIONAL.
IN MAYBE IN A COUPLE OF YEARS
IT'S NOT OPTIONAL ANYMORE THAN
WE SEE THE BILL THAT SAYS OKAY
NOW IT'S MANDATORY AND THAT.
IS CAN WHEN WE SEE THAT HAPPEN
ALL THE TIME IN THE LEGISLATURE
WE START OFF WITH THE GOOD IDEA
WITH GREAT INTENTIONS AND THEN
WE SEE IT MORPH INTO SOMETHING
ELSE DOWN THE ROAD NOT SAYING
THAT THAT YOUR INTENTION -- BUT
THAT GIVES ME PAUSE BUT BUT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU I'LL JUST MAKE A
COMMENT THAT I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR WORKING SO HARD I'M TRYING
TO GET THE POLICY OF THIS RIGHT
I THINK IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
GOAL.
AND I'M CERTAINLY GONNA SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY AND I DO HOPE
THAT YOU CONTINUE TO WORK ON
SOME OF THESE ISSUES AND
ESPECIALLY THE PRIVACY ISSUE
WHICH I THINK -- YOU KNOW GIVEN
THE CHANGING LANDSCAPE OF
PRIVACY IT'S A IT'S IT'S IT'S
ALMOST UNFAIR TO ASK YOU TO
RESPOND TO A BILL THAT HASN'T
BEEN IMPLEMENTED YET.
BUT I DO HEAR SOME LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS SO WITH THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE COMMENTS FOR ALL ALL YOUR
WORK AT THE COMMITTEES WORK ON
THIS BILL AGAIN.
THIS IS THIS BILL THERE -- FIRST
COMMITTEE BILL WE REALLY VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS --
FROM BOTH THE OPPOSITION AS WELL
AS ALL THE ALL THE MEMBERS HE
WIPES THE BE TAKEN THAT FEEDBACK
ON THE TO THE NEXT.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT -- TO HAVE A MOTION SO.
WITH A SECOND AGAIN THE MOTION A
SECOND WE HAVE A ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
ITEM TO AB ONE SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIANG.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO REFER TO PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO CHILD [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NOT VOTING.
GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE LIMóN
[inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MULLIN HAS NO RIGHT TO
TREAT HIGH MURATSUCHI AYE STONE.
THREE THREE OKAY WILL HOLD THE
BILL OPEN -- FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU I'M GONNA HAVE -- TO
TAKE A BRIEF -- I'M HAVE TO
ESCAPE FOR A FEW MINUTES TO GO
TO OTHER COMMITTEE NOW LIVE FOR
INTEREST.
SOMEONE OBERNOLTE.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN BILL NUMBER.
THREE NINETY FOUR MOVE THE BILL
[inaudible]
SECOND.
THANKS FOR BEING [inaudible]
JOHN.
STRUGGLING WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
THANKING.
CHAIRMAN FRIEDMAN FOR HER.
WORK ON THE BILL ALSO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF HAS BEEN
ABSOLUTELY GREAT.
I IT WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PREFERRED AND THERE'S BEEN
LOCKED UP THIS MORNING I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO TO
REVIEW THEM -- I'VE REVIEWED
THEM THEY'RE ACCEPTABLE AND THAT
THEY MAKE THE BILL BETTER.
AB THREE NINETY FOUR IS A
RESPONSE TO THE DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES HAVE BEEN OCCURRING IN
CALIFORNIA RECENTLY AND I'M SURE
EVERY MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE IS
AWARE OF THE SEVERITY OF THE
CAMPFIRE LAST YEAR THAT WAS THE
MOST DESTRUCTIVE IN THE
DEADLIEST FIRE IN CALIFORNIA
STATE HISTORY WAS ALSO.
THE COSTLIEST NATURAL DISASTER
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD LAST YEAR
COST OVER SIXTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS OF LIABILITY AND THAT'S
STILL GOING TO CONTINUE INCREASE
OVER EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
STRUCTURES LOST BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY EIGHTY SIX LIVES
WERE LOST IN THAT FIRE.
THE DEADLIEST FIRE IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY.
I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY LAST MONTH
TO VISIT THE DEVASTATED TOWN OF
PARADISE I'M I KNOW A NUMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE ALONG
ON THAT LEGISLATIVE TRIP AND
I'LL TELL YOU IT WAS SO.
EMOTIONALLY AFFECTING TO SEE THE
DEVASTATION OF THAT COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE PRESENTATIONS FROM A LOT
OF THE FIRST RESPONDERS THAT
WERE PARTICULARLY POIGNANT
BECAUSE THESE WERE FIRST
RESPONDERS THAT ALSO LIVED IN
THE COMMUNITIES THEY WERE HAVING
RESPOND TO A DISASTER THAT.
INCLUDED THEIR OWN HOUSE HOMES
IN TOWN BEING DESTROYED. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WAS AMAZING
ABOUT THAT FIRE IS THAT THE
BEHAVIOR OF THE FIRE WAS NOTHING
LIKE.
WE HAVE EVER SEEN IN CALIFORNIA
IF YOU READ SOME OF THE CAL FIRE
REPORTS THEY COMPARE THE SPREAD
OF THAT FIRE. TO THE FIRE
BOMBING OF HAMBURG IN WORLD WAR
TWO IT WAS NOT LIKE A WILDFIRE.
IN IN BEHAVIOR AT ALL IN FACT
THE MAJORITY OF THE STRUCTURES
THE BURNED.
WERE BURNED BEFORE IT WITHIN
FOUR HOURS OF THE ADDITION OF
THAT FIRE.
SO THAT REALLY BRINGS UP.
A REALLY A A VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC FOR US FROM A POLICY
STANDPOINT WHICH IS THE TOPIC OF
THE IF EGRESS FROM THESE FIRES
BECAUSE WHEN THE FIRE SPREAD SO
QUICKLY AND SO DESTRUCTIVELY --
IT'S IT'S IMPOSSIBLE WITH A
CONVENTIONAL STRATEGIES TO GET
PEOPLE OUT OF THE PATH OF THE
FIRE.
SO LAST YEAR.
CHAIRWOMAN FRIEDMAN HAD A BILL
THAT ASKED THE BOARD OF FORESTRY
TO IDENTIFY COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA WITH INSUFFICIENT
EGRESS THIS BILL IS KIND OF A
FOLLOW UP TO THAT BILL IT
CREATES A VERY NARROWLY CRAFTED.
CRAFTED SEQUEL EXEMPTION FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE PROJECTS
THAT WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
BOARD IN THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKING TODAY EVEN FURTHER
NARROW THE SCOPE.
OF THAT BILL SO WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
ARE JOHN KENNEDY FROM THE RURAL
COUNTIES REPRESENT IT'S OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO DON TRAP THE
CHIEF OF THE SAN MATTEO COUNTY
FIRE DEPARTMENT.
ARE YOUR FIRST WITNESS JUST A
REMINDER TO MISS PER WITNESS
PLEASE SIX MINS TOTAL.
GET A GOOD AFTERNOON ON BEHALF
OF SEMINAL COUNTY.
THE CALIFORNIA THIRTIES
ASSOCIATION AND FIRE DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA PLEASE TO
TESTIFY THIS AFTERNOON IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY FOUR THE
LEGISLATION FOR YOU WOULD EXEMPT
FROM C. QUIT URGENT SAFETY
PROJECTS IN FIRE PRONE
SUBDIVISIONS WITHIN SUFFICIENT
ESCAPE ROUTES.
THE SALMON IN A COUNTY FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICT PROTECTS THE
COUNTY THE POPULATION OF OVER
TWO MILLION RESIDENTS.
WE PROTECT NINETEEN THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY THREE SQUARE
MILES THROUGH A COMBINATION OF
SIXTY FIVE DIFFERENT FACILITIES.
AND ELEVEN HUNDRED EMPLOYEES OUR
GOALS A SERVE OUR SHIN AND OFFER
PROFESSIONAL AND DEDICATED
RESPONSE TO THE CITIZENS OF SAN
BENITO COUNTY WHEN THEY CALL FOR
HELP.
OVER THE COURSE OF A YEAR WE
RESPOND TO MORE NO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND OF THOSE
CALLS.
COUNTY FAIR PROTECTS MORE IN
SIXTY COMMUNITIES INCLUDING THE
CITIES OF NEEDLES FONTANA.
UPLAND GRAND TERRACE VICTORVILLE
HYSTERIA YUCCA VALLEY IN ATLANTA
AND ALSO A NUMBER OF OUR
MOUNTAIN COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED WITH LIMITED EGRESS.
YOU MAY BE AWARE SEMINAL COUNTY
HAS HISTORICALLY EXPERIENCED
VERY LARGE AND DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES.
THAT HAVE TAKEN LIVES DECIMATED
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF ACRES AND
DESTROYED THOUSANDS OF HOMES
INCLUDING THE PANORAMA FIRE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY THE GRAND PRIX
AN OLD FIRES IN.
TWO THOUSAND THREE THE SLIDE
FIRE IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN IN THE BLUE
CAUGHT FIRE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
JUST TO NAME A FEW.
OUR NEIGHBORS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE HAVE DIDN'T HAVE MORE
UNFORTUNATE SITUATIONS
CALIFORNIA SEEN A RECORD NUMBER
WILD FIRES IN THE PAST YEARS
WHICH IS CAUSED MASS AMOUNTS OF
DOES THAT STATION. TO THE
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE.
AB THREE NINETY FOUR BUILDS UPON
PREVIOUS EFFORTS TO STRENGTHEN
WELFARE PREVENTION AND RECOVERY
THEY EXEMPTING FROM SEQUEL
PROCESS FOR URGENT PROCESS
PROJECTS.
THAT ARE RECOMMENDED BY THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY TO IMPROVE
FIRE SAFETY IN FIRE PRONE
SUBDIVISIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS LACKING SUFFICIENT
EGRESS ROUTES.
I APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
IS IMPORTANT MEASURE IN AN
URGENT AYE VOTE ON A BETWEEN
NINETY FOUR THANK YOU.
THE CHIEF.
HI JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE WORLD
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA -- WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL IS A WAY TO IMPROVE
COMMUNITY WILD FIRE SAFETY WE
SUPPORTED THE TEARS AB TWENTY
NINE ELEVEN LAST YEAR ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT FUNCTIONS AS THE
AUTHOR MENTIONED WAS TO HAVE THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY GO IN AND
IDENTIFY.
SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES THAT HIGH
FIRE IS THAT LACK A SECONDARY
ESCAPE ROUTE AND IMPORTANTLY TO
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ON SPECIFIC
PROJECTS TO HELP THOSE
COMMUNITIES SURVIVE FIRES --
WE'VE SEEN WAY TOO MANY -- WILD
FIRES IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
PARADISE HOPEFULLY WAS AN
EXCEPTION LAST YEAR WELL THEY
DID HAVE FOR SKATE ROUTES
CAPACITY WAS A PROBLEM -- SO
HERE WE THINK THIS IS A NARROWLY
TAILORED BILL ONLY LOOKING AT
THOSE COMMUNITIES IDENTIFIED BY
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY AND THOSE
PROJECTS IDENTIFIED BY THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY.
WITH BUILT IN SAFEGUARDS FOR
WETLANDS RIPARIAN AREAS AND ALSO
LISTED SPECIES THREATENED OR
ENDANGERED SPECIES -- PUBLIC
NOTIFICATIONS AS WELL SO WE
THINK THIS IS A GOOD COMPROMISE --
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES --
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS THAT WILL
BE TAKEN BECAUSE WE THINK THOSE
GO TOWARDS ACHIEVING THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT WITH THE BILL --
WE SUPPORT THE BILL AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON YELEY COVERAGE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS WERE ALSO HERE IN
SUPPORT BECAUSE WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING COMMUNITIES NEED
ADDITIONAL PATH TO SAFETY THANK
YOU.
YOUR SINGLE PICKY WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
HOW DOES TO THE MIKE -- CARLSON
ASSOCIATED CALIFORNIA LOGGERS IN
SUPPORT.
TIMBER INDUSTRY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT AND ALSO SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA OUR OFFICIAL POSITION
IS OPPOSING ESTIMATES ARE HAPPY
TO HEAR THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
DECIDED TO ADOPT THE COMMITTEES
MINUTES ON TO THREATEN --
FURTHER NARROWLY TAILORED THE
BILL AND SO I WOULD REMOVE
OPPOSITION WITH THOSE MOMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THE QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
MATHIS.
TRULY APPRECIATE YOU WORKING ON
THIS BILL FROM NOT AREA CO
AUTHOR PLEASE ADD ME AS IS MOST
CERTAINLY.
ANYONE YES SAID JUST AT THE ALSO
SAY THANK YOU FOR WORKING ON
THIS MISTER OBERNOLTE WE WE'RE
WE'RE IN TRAGIC TIMES INDEED.
I WAS ONE OF THE WANT TO ONE UP
IN AND VIEW THE AREA WITH YOU.
AND WHILE WE DO THEN WE DON'T
WANT TO GET RID OF ALL OUR
POLICIES WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE
AND GET BACK IN AND GET THEIR
LIVES BACK IN ORDER AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE CNN SO RICH LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THAT FOR ME THE MOST POIGNANT
TESTIMONY THAT I HEARD.
WHEN WE WENT TO THE COMMUNITY OF
PARADISE WAS THE PEOPLE WHO HAD
BEEN UNABLE TO GET OUT?
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THEY WERE
FOR GRASSROOTS AVAILABLE THEY
WERE ALL COMPLETELY GRIDLOCKED
WERE CLOGGED WITH -- BURNED
ABANDONED VEHICLES.
WE HEARD TESTIMONY FROM PEOPLE
WHO WERE FORCED TO SHELTER IN
PLACE IN THEIR CARS IN A WIDE
SPOT IN THE ROAD THE TICKET
INTERSECTION AND THANKFULLY FOR
THOSE PEOPLE IT WORKED OUT BUT
YOU CAN.
CLEARLY IMAGINE THAT FOR MANY
PEOPLE IT WOULDN'T.
I LIVE IN A COMMUNITY WITH ONLY
THREE ADDRESS ROUTES.
IN A FORESTED AREA VERY
SIMILARLY SITUATED FROM A FUEL
STANDPOINT TO PARADISE AND THERE
ARE MANY PLACES IN CALIFORNIA
WITH TWO OR ONLY.
ONE SO I THINK IT REALLY MAKES
SENSE TO TAKE A HARD LOOK AT
STREAMLINED LIGHTING THESE VERY
IMPORTANT PROJECTS NOT
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE A
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHIEF THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE -- ENJOYS SUPPORT
FROM THE CHAIR I TO WILL BE
SUPPORTING US PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM FOURTEEN AB THREE NINETY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN.
FLORA FLOOR AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA [inaudible]
LIMóN [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI AYE STONE
[inaudible] FIVE ZERO WE'LL GET
FIVE FIVE BOATS WILL HOLD OPEN.
THE DAY MISTER [inaudible]
SERVER PATTERSON.
LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE TO BILLS UP.
IT'S ALRIGHT WITH YOU WILL START
WITH.
AB.
THREE FORTY THREE FILE ITEM TEN
THANK YOU.
THAT MISSED BY STERN MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO PRESENT
[inaudible]
PEOPLE UP.
WELL WE WE DO KNOW THAT USING
FORCE BY MASS REDUCES THE RISK
OF LARGE CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
PROTECTS WATERSHEDS AND IMPROVE
THEIR QUALITY.
AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
HOWEVER WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
COST OF TRANSPORTING BIOMASS
ALONE CAN NEARLY DOUBLE THE COST
OF A FIRE HAZARD.
REDUCTION PROJECT SO IN RESPONSE
WERE PROPOSING AB THREE FORTY
THREE WHICH WOULD DIRECT THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY TO
IMPLEMENT A GRANT PROGRAM TO
OFFSET THE COST.
OF TRANSPORTING FUELS TO BIOMASS
ENERGY FACILITIES WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH
ME AND THE STAFF PROVIDING A WAY
FORWARD AND FOR THE AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL WHICH WE I
GRATEFULLY UP -- EXCEPT
UNDERSTAND THERE WERE CONCERNS
WITH RESPECT TO WHICH
COMMUNITIES WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE PROGRAM.
THE COMMITTEE RESPONDED BY
REVISING THEIR AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE SURE THERE WOULDN'T BE A
DELAY IN THAT IMPLEMENTATION
WHICH WAS.
VERY HELPFUL I DO THINK WE STILL
HAVE A FEW CONCERNS JUST ABOUT
HOW MANY FACILITIES WELL
ACTUALLY QUALIFY UNDER THE NEW.
CRITERIA BUT I REALLY DO BELIEVE
THAT WHICH WE HAVE TO TAKE
ACTION WE HAVE TO TAKE A EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS I'M I'M
GRATEFULLY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES.
AMENDMENTS BECAUSE WE NEED TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD AND WE NEED TO
PRACTICE THIS KIND.
OF REDUCTION IN THAT COST FOR
OBVIOUS REASONS TO HELP EXPLAIN
THE NEED FOR A BI THREE FOUR
THREE WE HAVE TODAY A MYSTIC
YOU'RE SINGLE PICKY WITH THE IT
WAS VICE PRESIDENT LEGIT AFFAIRS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION.
AND SPEAK ON THE VARIOUS
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS OF USING
BIOMASS DR STEPHAN KAFKA
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA BY A
MASS COLLABORATIVE OUT OF UC
DAVIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR IT WAS
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
YOUR SINGLE BECKY WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE -- ONE OF THE
GREATEST DISADVANTAGES THAT BIO
MASS FACES COMPARED TO WIND OR
SOLAR IS THE THE TRANSPORTATION
OF ACTUAL FUEL ITSELF AND THAT'S
THE PURPOSE OF AB THREE FORTY
THREE AND WHY WE THINK IT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THIS BILL
PASSED TODAY.
WE DO HAVE SOME CONSIDERABLE
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS FROM -- COMMITTEE
STAFF SPECIFICALLY -- THE
PRECLUSION OF BIOMASS FACILITIES
WHO HAVE CONTRACTS UNDER SB NINE
OH ONE AND THE PRECLUSION OF
BIOMASS FACILITIES THAT ARE
LOCATED IN NON ATTAINMENT AREAS.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA HAS TWENTY
THREE BIOMASS FACILITIES IN
THEIR TOTALITY. SEVEN OF WHICH
HAVE BIRAM CONTRACTS SO IF YOU
SUBTRACTED SEVEN FROM TWENTY
THREE IN.
I'M NOT A MATH MAJOR BUT I THINK
AT SIXTEEN AND THEN IF YOU THERE
ARE ADDITIONAL FOR FACILITIES
THAT ARE NON ATTAINMENT
SUBTRACTED THAT THEN.
YOU KNOW WE'RE LOOKING AT TWELVE
FACILITIES AND THEN PRESUMABLY
SINCE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ONLY
SMALL DIAMETER MORE MATERIAL
HAVING TO DO WITH FOREST WE'RE
NOT INCLUDING AG FACILITY SO.
I'M NOT SURE HOW MANY LEFT
FACILITIES ARE LEFT ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS MONEY UNDER THIS BILL IN
PARTICULAR AND THAT IS A CONCERN
THAT I HAVE -- WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THIS SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN REDUCE THE COST OF
TRANSPORTATION AND THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S IMPORTANT WE
ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
SPECIFY WHAT SMALL DIAMETER
MATERIAL IS I'M NOT SURE WHAT
THAT IS -- WE CURRENTLY DON'T
HAVE.
NOR WOULD WE EVER WANT TO TAKE --
LARGE DIAMETER TREES THAT
WEREN'T ALREADY DEAD AND TAKEN
TO A BIOMASS FACILITY BECAUSE
THERE'S A HIGHER AND USE FOR
THOSE.
MATERIALS HOWEVER WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT ISN'T INTENDED
TO MEAN THAT SLASH FROM A LARGER
DIAMETER TREE COULDN'T BE TAKEN
TO A BIO MASS FACILITY -- I
THINK OUT OF FORCE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME
ASCERTAINING THAT ONE LOT OF
THREE SLASH CAME FROM AN
EIGHTEEN INCH DIAMETER TREE AND
IN ANOTHER SECTION OF THE FORCE
THAT ONE CAME FROM THIRTY SIX WE
HAVE TO KEEP THE SEPARATE THAT'S
JUST NOT THE WAY THAT WORKS.
OUT IN THE FOREST SAID THOSE ARE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH DOCTOR.
LOW IN NAME IS STEVE KAFKA I'M
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF PLANT
SCIENCES AT UC DAVIS AND
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
BIOMASS COLLABORATIVE.
I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT OF MANY
PARTS ARE FOR CERTAIN DIRE
CONDITION TERMS OF NUMBERS OF
DEAD TREES BUT ALSO IN TERMS OF
OVERCROWDING HAVE CANOPY.
OF STRUCTURES THAT LEAD TO
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES MANY
PARTS OF OUR FORESTS.
WE ALSO KNOW THE NUMBER OF
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES ARE
INCREASING AND I'M ACTUALLY
MYSELF PERSONALLY VERY CONCERNED
THAT WE COULD SEE CONFLAGRATIONS
IN THE FUTURE THAT EVEN FOUR
FOOT WHICH ASSAULT LAST SUMMER.
WITH SO MANY DEAD TREES IN
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE SIERRA
NEVADA PARTICULARLY IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE'S FORCE THAT --
AND IF CONDITIONS ARE RIGHT IT
COULD BE JUST EXTRAORDINARILY
BAD.
WE ALSO I THINK ALL AGREE THAT
HEALTHY FORESTS ARE AN
UNAMBIGUOUS PUBLIC GOOD.
SO HOW DO WE ACHIEVE THAT GIVEN
THE GIVE DIFFICULT CONDITIONS --
THAT WE FACE THE HEALTHY FOREST
CONNECTED.
CONNECTORS CARBON SINKS NAY DO
ELSEWHERE IN THE WORLD BUT
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA'S FORCE ARE
SHIFTING OVER TO COURT AND
SOURCES IN THIS UNDERMINES THE
STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS AND VERY
SIGNIFICANT WEIGHT.
VERY HARD EARNED AN HARD WON
CLIMATE GAINES.
THE PRUDENT USE IN FACT WE'VE
SEEN WE SING RECOGNITION THIS
THE RECENT GOVERNOR'S UP A
PROPOSAL.
TO DEVELOPERS A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AHEAD OF THE FORCE FOR
SEASON TO FACILITATE.
SOME OF THE SOME OF THE ACTIONS
AT THIS BILL WOULD FACILITATE AS
WELL.
WE KNOW THAT THE PRUDENT USE OF
FORCE BY MASS CAN LEAD.
TO ALL KINDS OF NEW PRODUCTS
TRANSPORTATION FUELS BIOPRODUCTS
AND ENERGY PRODUCTION.
WE KNOW THAT WILL REDUCE
POLLUTION AND HEALTH COSTS AND
LOSS OF LIFE.
WE KNOW THAT WILL HELP CREATE
NEW JOBS ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
AREAS AND AMONG DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES CLOSE TO THE SOURCES
OF THESE BIOMASS.
AND IT'LL HELP OFFSET THE COSTS
OF CREATING RECREATING HEALTHY
FORCE IN THE STATE.
THERE MANY FORMS OF BIOMASS
AVAILABLE IN CALIFORNIA ROUGHLY
A THIRD POSSIBLY -- ACCESSIBLE
FROM URBAN SOURCES IN RESIDUALS
THIRD FROM AGRICULTURAL SOURCES
NO THIRD FROM FORESTRY.
BY AND LARGE THE MOST EXPENSIVE
SOURCES OF BIOMASS OR FROM
FORESTRY.
SO TRIPS AND TRANSPORTATION
COSTS OR MAJOR REASON THAT --
FORESTRY BIOMASS IS AMONG THE
MOST EXPENSIVE SOURCES.
SO WE HAVE TO HAVE AN ADEQUATE
SUBSIDY PROGRAM TO FACILITATE
THE USE OF THIS BIOMASS TO
ACHIEVE THE MANY POSITIVE
BENEFITS THAT CAN COME FROM ITS
USE.
LET ME GIVE YOU SOME EXAMPLES IN
THE LAST MINUTE BUT I HAVE.
A COMPANY CALLED SWEET WATER
ENERGY FOR EXAMPLE A CALIFORNIA
BASED TECHNOLOGY COMPANY HAS THE
ABILITY TO TAKE WOODY BIOMASS
NOW AND CONVERTED INTO SIMPLE
SUGARS.
CLEAN LIGNIN AND DUST REAL
ALCOHOLS THEIR BUILDING
INTERESTING NEW PROJECTS WHERE
MINNESOTA.
NEW YORK IN ESTONIA NOT
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA IS AN
EXPENSIVE PLACE TO TO ACHIEVE
THESE TECHNOLOGIES WE NEED TO
MAKE A CONDITION WHERE WE CAN
SEE THESE INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES DEVELOP.
CARBON NANOFIBERS CAN BE ADDED
TO CONCRETE WHAT DOES THAT DO
THAT REDUCES THE ABOUT A
CONCRETE YOU NEED IN A
PERMANENTLY REDUCES MOVES CARBON
FROM THE ATMOSPHERE.
AS A POSITIVE MY PROFILE
PRODUCTS FOR EXAMPLE THAT CAN BE
MADE FROM FORCED BY A MESS.
AND LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
FROM ONE CALIFORNIA COMPANY
THAT'S ABOUT READY TO BREAK
GROUND ON A NEW FACILITY THAT
WILL CONVERT WOULD INTO
TRANSPORTATION FUELS IN THIS
CASE ETHANOL.
THAT'S A MEDICINE.
THEY COULD AS EASILY USE ORCHARD
WOOD FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WHICH WILL REDUCE THE BURNING
PROBLEM BUT THEY COULD ALSO USE
SOFT WHICH SMITH FROM THE STAIRS
BUT TRANSPORTATION COSTS IN
THOSE CASES OR SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS TO THE USE OF THAT.
SO I WOULD SUPPORT.
THE PASSAGE OF AB OF THREE FORTY
THREE BECAUSE IT SOME MEASURE IT
WILL HELP REDUCE THE TO START ON
HELPING TO DIVERT TO ADDRESS
THESE VERY SERIOUS WILD FOR
PROBLEMS.
AND IT SHOULD ENCOURAGE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA AND JOBS.
WHICH ARE.
A WAY OF HELPING REDUCE SOME OF
THE EXPENSIVE COSTS OF OUR
CLIMATE PROGRAMS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
DOES NOT ADDRESS MANAGER MANAGER
BRIAN WHITE HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA LICENSE FORCED
ASSOCIATION AND FORCE LANDLORDS
OF CALIFORNIA.
A WE ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT THE
BILL AS IN PRINT WE'LL HAVE TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT JUST
AMENDMENTS BUT WE AGREE THAT
JUSTIN TRANSPORTATION COSTS
CRITICAL TO MAKE THESE.
BIOMASS POWER PLANTS A PENCIL
OUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JULIE NON ASK ABOUT
HALF THE CALIFORNIA ABOUT MASS
ENERGY ALLIANCE WE ACTUALLY ECHO
MISS COOKIES CONCERNS ABOUT THE
RESTRICTIVE NATURE OF THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE BIOMASS
PLANTS.
IT'S NOT THAT YOU'RE EXCLUDING
BIOMASS PLANTS FROM THIS
LANGUAGE YOU'RE ACTUALLY
RESTRICTING COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
HAVE ACCESS TO THESE BIOMASS
PLANTS AND BY THIS LANGUAGE YOU
HAVE.
RESTRICTED THE TEN SOUTHERN MOST
SIERRA COUNTIES WHO ARE HARDEST
HIT BY THE TREE MORTALITY --
CRISIS FROM PARTICIPATING IN
THIS PROGRAM SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU
TO KEEP THE DIALOGUE OPEN ABOUT
THE RESTRICTIVE NATURE OF THE
ELIGIBILITY THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR CHRISTMAS KELLY ON
BEHALF OF MENDOCINO REDWOOD
COMPANIES AND WE SHARE THE
CONCERNS THAT.
ARE TRUE ASSOCIATIONS OF BIOMASS
ALLIANCE IN THE FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION HAVE EXPRESSED WE DO
SUPPORT THE BILL IMPRINT BUT WE
ARE EVALUATING THE IMPACT OF
THESE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON STACY HEAT RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT WE DO
SHARE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS AS WELL BUT ALSO
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
ERIK KARLSSON REPRESENTED SOCIO
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS BUT ALSO LOG
HAULERS TRUCKERS AND WHERE THE
MOM POP SO IF YOU CAN'T AFFORD
TO DRIVE IT FROM THE FORCE TO
THE FACILITY IT'S UNFORTUNATELY
NOT A BUSINESS PROPOSITION
CONSEQUENTLY WERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
AND CONCERNED ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT'S WHERE WE ARE
OF COURSE WHEN WHEN WHEN WILD
FIRE PREVENTION.
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY FAROLE JOBS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
IS THERE ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING THEM WILL TURN TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- I'M SORRY
THERE'S ONE COMING UP.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR BRENNAN
DAWSON ARMY OFFICER COULD
CALIFORNIA AGAIN -- WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO REMOVE OPPOSITION
PENDING PUBLICATION OF THE
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS -- ADOPTION I MEAN --
REQUESTED AND WE REMOVE
OPPOSITION OPPOSITION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY -- THAT THE TO SAY MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR WORKING
ON THIS AND AND YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES WE TAKE AMENDMENTS AND
THEN OUR SUPPORTERS BECOME MORE
MARGINAL -- A PREVIEW WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND I SHARE
A LOT OF YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
DO WE HOW DO WE MAKE.
SOMETHING THAT I'VE BEEN TRYING
TO FOCUS ON SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE
HOW DO WE MAKE BIOMASS WORK FOR
THE FORCE. FOR AG FOLKS AND
CONTINUE TO WORK ON CLEAN AIR.
BUT NOT NOT TIE PEOPLE'S HANDS
AS A WAY OF OF MAKING SURE THAT
GETS DONE SO.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY AND AND WATCHING IT AS IT
GOES THROUGH.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE.
MR PARRIS ME LIKE TO CLOSE IT
WHAT.
I TO HAVE THEIR RESERVATIONS
THAT WERE EXPRESSED EARLIER.
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT WITHOUT
THESE AMENDMENTS I DON'T THINK
THIS WOULD GET THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND WE ARE OFTENTIMES PUT IN A
CIRCUMSTANCE IN WHICH WE NEED TO
TAKE.
ABOUT THREE QUARTERS OF A LOAF
INSTEAD OF THE WHOLE LOAF -- I
APPRECIATE THE WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH ME ON THIS AS I SAID
IN MY OPENING REMARKS.
THIS IS THE BEGINNING I HOPE AND
SO WITH THE PASSAGE AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION I HOPE WE
DEMONSTRATE THAT THERE ARE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES AND OPTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND ARE.
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MOVE THE BILL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS.
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN START TO
DEMONSTRATE.
THAT WE CAN EXPAND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INCLUDE SOME OF
THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED
FOR WHAT.
ON THE SURFACE APPEARS TO BE --
SOME CONCERN BUT LIMITS REALLY
THOSE REGIONS THAT HAVE SERIOUS
NEED FOR THE CLEAN UP AND THE
BIOMASS SO.
GIVEN WHAT THE CHOICES WERE I
APPRECIATED THE AMENDMENTS
KNOWING THAT THAT'S HOW WE GET
THIS.
BILL MOVING FORWARD I APPRECIATE
THAT AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON IT AND I WILL CONTINUE -- TO
TO EXPRESS AND REPRESENT THE
CONCERNS OF THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND YET HAVE
SOME RESERVATIONS ABOUT THE
LIMITATIONS OF THE AMENDMENTS.
WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON AND I
ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR WORKING
WITH US AND ADDRESSING THE
COMMITTEES CONCERNED WITH THE
MA'AM AND SIR THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WITH WITH A ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
ITEM TEN AB THREE FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA.
LARA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA ISLA
MON.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ I WROTE TO
TREAT.
RED TO GI STONE. NINE ZERO THANK
YOU AND YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL I
DIDN'T.
MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THE CALIFORNIA FOR
US CLIMATE ACTION TEAM.
WAS ASSEMBLED IN AUGUST OF
TWENTY FOURTEEN WITH THE PRIMARY
PURPOSE OF DEVELOPING A FOREST
CARBON PLAN WHICH WOULD SERVE AS
THE DETAILED IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
FOR CALIFORNIA'S.
FOREST HEALTH GOALS LAST YEAR
GOVERNOR BROWN APPROPRIATED
NINETY NINE POINT TWO MILLION TO
IMPLEMENT KEY RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE FOREST CARBON PLAN
HOWEVER.
THERE HAS NOT BEEN A MOVEMENT
FROM THIS LEGISLATURE TO REPORT
ON THE PROGRESS OF THE ENTIRE
PLAN TO FIND OUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH THE MONEY AND HOW
EFFECTIVELY.
IS IT BEING USED SO OF THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE CAL FIRE CAL EPA
IN THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY.
TO REPORT ANNUALLY UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR ON THE PROGRESS MADE.
ON THESE GOALS I WANT TO THANK
AGAIN THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
AMENDMENTS THAT STILL PRESERVE
THE INTENT OF THE BILL.
A TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE MAKING
PROGRESS IN OUR FOREST HEALTH
GOALS -- I HAVE WITH ME -- ONE
OF THE KEY MEMBERS OF THE FORCE
CLIMATE ACTION TEAM RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
REPRESENTED TODAY BY THE
REGULATORY AFFAIRS ADVOCATE MISS
STACY HIDDEN AND TO EXPLAIN THE
NEED FOR A BEACH A SIX ONE SIX
IS AGAIN I MISSED -- KRISTIN
CALL PICKY WITH THE ADVICE
PRESIDENT OF THE LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON STACY HEATING
WITH THE ROLE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND AS A FAMILY MEMBER PATTERSON
SAID I WAS ON THE FORCE CLIMATE
ACTION TEAM AND WAS INVOLVED IN
THE DISCUSSIONS AND FORMULATING
FORCED CARBON PLAN AND THAT WAS
TWO AND A HALF YEARS OF
DISCUSSION.
TO WHAT WE THINK IS A PRETTY
GOOD PLAN FOR HELPING.
TO MAKE CALIFORNIA'S FORCE MORE
RESILIENT AND HEALTHIER AND I TO
GO AND RESTORE OUR FOR STOOD
WATERSHEDS AND AS A STATE WE'VE
RESPONDED MUCH MORE QUICKLY TO
OTHER GHG EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
SECTORS THAN WE HAVE
CALIFORNIA'S FORESTS.
WE'VE DONE IMMEDIATE THINGS AND
TAKING IMMEDIATE ACTIONS AND AND
SAT RATE REQUIREMENTS ON
TRANSPORTATION AND SOLID WASTE
AND OTHER SECTORS AND IT'S TAKEN
US A LOT OF TIME TO GET TO FORCE
AND TO GET TO OUR WILD LANDS.
AND NOW THAT THE STATE IS THAT
SOME PRETTY CONCRETE GOALS IN
THE FOREST CARBON PLAN. TO HELP
MAKE OUR FORCE IN OUR WILD LANDS
MORE RESILIENT MAN THIS INCLUDES
INCREASING PACE AND SCALE FORCE
MANAGEMENT.
DEVELOPING AND SIMULATING AN
INNOVATIVE WOOD PRODUCTS
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA WHICH AS
WE JUST HEARD FROM OUR BIO MASS
DISCUSSION IS.
VITAL IN CLEARING OUR MATERIALS
OFF THE FOREST OTHERWISE THE GET
PILED AND BURNED WHICH IS
SOMETHING WE REALLY DON'T WANT.
AND RESTORING FOR SOME
WATERSHEDS THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED PASSED WILDFIRES --
WE BELIEVE THAT -- AB SIX
SIXTEEN WILL AT LEAST SERVE AS A
BASELINE FOR AT SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY IN MEETING
CALIFORNIA'S -- CARBON GOALS IN
THE SECTOR AND NOT ONLY THAT BUT
THEN OF COURSE WE ALL KNOW THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMPONENT THAT
COMES ALONG.
WITH -- MAKING CALIFORNIA'S
FORCE MORE RESILIENT AND MORE
RESISTANCE WILDFIRE IN THE
FUTURE SO WITH THAT WE ENCOURAGE
OUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
YOUR SINGLE BECKY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR HAS
INVESTED SOME PRETTY GOOD CHUNK
OF CHANGE -- AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE CAN GET HEALTHY FORESTS
THAT ARE OUT THERE AND ONE OF
THE BEST THE WAYS THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT.
OUR MONEY IS BEING SPENT WISELY
AND THAT WE'RE ACHIEVING THEIR
GOALS THE RESULTS THAT WERE
AIMING FOR IS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
SOME SORT OF REPORT
ACCOUNTABILITY PROCESS SO FOR
THOSE REASONS FOR SUPPORTING THE
BILL.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF THE BILL.
GERMAN MANAGER MEMBER BRIAN
WHITE HERE WE HAVE THE CALVARY
LICENSE FORCES SOCIALIZATION
WHERE THE RICHER STEPHAN
FORSTER'S AND ALSO THE FORCE
LANDOWNERS OF CALIFORNIA WHERE
THE SMALL NON INDUSTRIAL
TIMBERLAND OWNERS WE SUPPORT
BOTH.
THE BILL AND THE FORCE ACTION
CLIMATE OF PLAN THAT'S GOING
THROUGH AND WE THINK THE GOALS
OF BOTH ARE ARE CONSISTENT SO WE
ASK REVIVAL THANK.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PAUL
MASON WITH A SPECIFIC FOREST
TRUST.
WERE ACTUALLY TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION BASED ON THE
AMENDMENTS BUT WANT TO CLARIFY
WHY AN ORGANIZATION.
THAT BELIEVES SO STRONGLY
ENFORCED RESTORATION WATER SAID
IMPROVEMENT -- DIDN'T SUPPORT
THE BILL AS IT WAS INITIALLY
INTRODUCED AND IT REALLY COMES
DOWN TO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH IN OUR FOR US WE'RE
TRYING TO GET BACK TO A MORE
CARBON RICH CLIMATE RESILIENT
CONDITION WITH GOOD WATERSHED
FUNCTION.
LARGE TREES WELL SPACED WHERE
FIRE WOULD BE A NATURAL
OCCURRENCE NOT A CATASTROPHE.
AND THAT REQUIRES CERTAIN TYPES
OF RESTORATION ACTIVITIES
STANDING AND THAT'S THE
LEGISLATURE TAKEN A LOT OF STEPS
BOTH FUNDING AND STREAMLINING
EXEMPTIONS AND STUFF IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS TO GET THERE.
THE GOAL IS ARTICULATED IN THE
PLAN OF A HALF MILLION ACRES OF
FOREST ACTIVITIES DOESN'T
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN THOSE
ACTIVITIES AND JUST GOING OUT
AND YOU KNOW CLEAR CUTTING OR
OTHER COMMERCIAL ACTIVITIES THAT
MOVES AWAY FROM THOSE CONDITIONS
RATHER THAN TOWARDS THOSE
CONDITIONS.
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE LEAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REFINE THOSE GOALS TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE REALLY GETTING TO THE
OUTCOMES THAT WERE TRYING TO GET.
TO I THINK AS OPPOSED TO BE
AMENDED TO BE A REPORT ON THE
BROADER GOALS OR THE FOURTH
CARBON PLAN.
IT'S FINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. ZERO CALIFORNIA
WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH THE PACIFIC FOR TRUST WE
REMOVE OPPOSITION AS WELL.
THANK YOU I'LL MOVE NOW TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WITH QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE I DO WANT TO THANK
YOU ONCE AGAIN FOR WORKING SO
CLOSELY WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
SACRAMENTO I THINK IT'S A VERY
GOOD BILL I DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING
YOU'D LIKE TO SAY IN CLOSING.
NOW WHAT I'D APPRECIATE.
THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT BOTH OF
THE BILLS -- THESE ARE
BEGINNINGS I HOPE.
NOT TO WEB A BIGGER AND BROADER --
APPROACH -- TO FORCE MANAGEMENT --
WE HAVE TO TAKE SOME STEPS I
THINK AND I THINK THESE TAKES A
GOOD STEPS FORWARD.
I'M ASK FOR YOUR I SUPPORT THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY MOVING
THESE BILLS ALONG.
THANK YOU WITH THAT TO DO WE
HAVE WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND I BELIEVE OKAY THEM WE'VE
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
I AM SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SIX ONE
SIX BY THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA FLORA AYE CHAU CHAU
AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
YEAH I LIMóN.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ.
RIGHT TO CHOOSE. FOR A TO G. AYE
STONE [inaudible] EIGHT ZERO
THANK YOU.
JEALOUS OUT [inaudible]
MS GONZALEZ [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE FIRST TIME I'VE BEEN IN THIS
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB TEN EIGHTY WHAT
ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S ON THE
FOREFRONT OF REDUCING POLLUTION
FROM PLASTIC PACKAGING AND
PRODUCTS BY ESTABLISHING
COMPREHENSIVE HOLISTIC GOALS FOR
THE SOURCE REDUCTION.
AND RECYCLING OF SINGLE USE
PACKAGING AND PRODUCTS IN THE
STATE.
EVERY DAY SINGLE USE PACKAGING
AND PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA
GENERATE TONS OF NON RECYCLABLE
AND NON COMPOSTABLE WASTE
IMPACTING OUR HEALTH NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT.
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PLASTIC
POLLUTION STARTS WITH FOSSIL
FUEL EXTRACTION TO CREATE
PLASTIC IN AFFECTS INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES AND ECO SYSTEMS
ALONG THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
ARE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
OFTEN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR BEAR
A DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN OF THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS FROM
MANUFACTURING POLLUTION.
INCLUDING HIGHER ASTHMA RATES
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ALSO
TEND TO NOT HAVE LOCAL
INVESTMENT FOR CLEAN UP OF
LETTER.
AT THE END OF A PRODUCT'S LIFE
AND LIKE NATURAL MATERIALS THEY
DECOMPOSE NEARLY EVERY PIECE OF
PLASTIC EVER PRODUCED STILL
EXISTS IN OUR LANDFILLS OR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AS THESE ITEMS FRAGMENT TO
SMALLER PARTICLES KNOWN AS
MICROPROCESSORS THEY CAN
CONCENTRATE TOXIC CHEMICALS AND
CONTAMINATE.
IN.
OUR FOOD AND DRINKING WATER
SOURCES.
EXPOSURE TO THESE PLASTICS AND
ASSOCIATED TOXINS HAS BEEN
LINKED TO CANCERS BIRTH DEFECTS
IMPAIRED IMMUNITY ENDOCRINE
DISRUPTION AND OTHER SERIOUS
HEALTH PROBLEMS. FOR TOO LONG
WE'VE FOCUSED ON ONE OFF BANDS.
OF CERTAIN PRODUCTS TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THIS IN A GAME OF WHACK
A MOLE.
HOWEVER LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
STILL SPENDING OVER FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
IN ONGOING EFFORTS TO CLEAN UP
AND PREVENT LATER IN STREETS
STORM DRAINS PARKS AND WATERWAYS.
AN EXISTING RECYCLING%
INFRASTRUCTURE CANNOT KEEP UP
WITH THE PACE OF CONCEPTION OF
THESE PRODUCTS.
LESS THAN 9% THE PLASTIC IS
RECYCLED AND THAT PERCENTAGE IS
DROPPING SINCE THE INTERNATIONAL
MARKETS RESTRICTED THE AMOUNT
AND KINDS OF FOREIGN WAYS THAT
THEY WILL ACCEPT.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED A SOLUTION
LIKE A. B. TEN EIGHTY WHICH GOES
BEYOND WHAT CAN BE THROWN INTO A
BLUE VAN BUT INSURERS WE'RE
ACTUALLY REDUCING THE AMOUNT.
A SINGLE USE WASTE AND THAT THE
SINGLE USE PACKAGING PRODUCTS WE
DO USE ARE ABLE TO BE COMPOSED.
COMPOSED COMPOSITE COMPOSED IT.
AB OR ARE ACTUALLY BEING
RECYCLED INTO NEW PRODUCTS.
AB TEN EIGHTY WOULD ESTABLISH
GOALS THAT 75% OF SINGLE USE
PACKAGING OF PRODUCTS SOLD OR
DISTRIBUTED IN CALIFORNIA.
MUST BE SOURCE REDUCED OR
ACTUALLY RECYCLED BY.
TWENTY THIRTY SPECIFICALLY ALL
SINGLE USE PACKAGING AND
PRODUCTS WOULD HAVE TO BE
RECYCLED OUR COMPOSTABLE ON OR
AFTER TWENTY THIRTY AND WITH 75%
OF PLASTIC SINGLE USE PACKAGING
PRODUCTS. TO BE SOURCE REDUCED
OR RECYCLED.
THE BILL GRANTS CAL RECYCLE
AUTHORITY TO ADOPT REGULATIONS
TO ACHIEVE THESE GOALS AFTER
HAVING GONE THROUGH A SCOPING
PLAN DO IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WHICH INCLUDES STAKEHOLDER
INVOLVEMENT.
AS PART OF THIS PLAN CAL RECYCLE
WOULD WORK TO REFINE THE
DEFINITION OF SINGLE USE
PACKAGING.
AND PRODUCT TO DETERMINE THE
SCOPE OF ITEMS IT IMPACTED AS
WELL AS WHAT ITEMS WERE TRULY
RECYCLABLE OUR COMPOSTABLE.
AB TEN EIGHTY ALSO ESTABLISHES
IN TERM GOALS REQUIRING
MANUFACTURES A SINGLE USE
PLASTIC PACKAGING PRODUCTS TO
DEMONSTRATE A RECYCLING RATE OF
NOT LESS THAN 20% BY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND NOT LESS
THAN 40% BY. TWENTY TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY FIFTH GRADER CAN TELL YOU
THE PLASTIC POLLUTION IS WHEN
THE BIGGEST THREATS TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT WE SIMPLY CAN'T
AFFORD TO WAIT ON THIS ISSUE
ANYMORE.
WHETHER WE ARE MOTIVATED BY THE
ENVIRONMENT OUR OWN HEALTH OR
SIMPLY THE PUBLIC COST OF
DEALING WITH THE ENORMOUS AMOUNT
OF WASTE PRODUCED AT WITNESSES
HERE TO HELP TO TESTIFY ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
MY NAME IS MERCED I'LL GET IS
GUARDIANSHIP I'M THE FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A SWORD
WORD ORGANIZATION WORKING WITH
LATINO COMMUNITIES.
TO CONSERVE AND PROTECT R. COSTA
NOTIONS.
TODAY ON BEHALF OF A SOUL I AM
VERY PLEASED TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB. ONE TEN
EIGHTY AND WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH
A TARGET FOR ALL SINGLE USE
PLASTIC PACKAGING AND PRODUCTS
SOLD OR DISTRIBUTED IN THE STATE.
TO BE REDUCE RECYCLED OR COMPOST
SAID BY LEAST 75% BY.
TWENTY THIRTY AND I THINK WE'RE
ALL VERY FAMILIAR WITH THAT WITH
THE TRAGIC IMPACTS OF PLASTIC
POLLUTION AND THAT'S BEEN IN USE
AS WELL A LOT YOU KNOW WITH THE
WITH THE WELL THAT WAS FOUND
DEAD WITH EIGHTY POUNDS OF
PLASTIC IN THE STOMACH.
I SEE TURTLES WITH THE WITH THE
STRAWS UP THEIR NOSE IN ALL THE
COUNTLESS BIRDS -- I THINK ONE
OF THINGS WE DON'T TALK ENOUGH
ABOUT IS.
THE PLASTIC PRODUCED A PLASTIC --
PRODUCTION PRODUCTION AND
POLLUTION AFFECTS MORE THEIR AYE
VARMINT.
AND THE WILDLIFE EFFECTS -- IT'S
VERY REAL AND DEVASTATING.
IMPACTS FOR PEOPLE BOTH.
HERE AND ABROAD -- AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THESE ARE IMPORTANT
REASONS TO WHY THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY.
SPECIFICALLY PLASTIC PRODUCTION.
FACILITIES ARE TYPICALLY
VERTICALLY INTEGRATED AT THE
SOURCE OF OIL PRODUCTION AND ARE
LOCATED ALONGSIDE REFINERIESIN
THE MOST DISADVANTAGED
NEIGHBORHOODS THIS A SERIES
IMPACTS ON THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT
AND ON THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING
ON NEARBYCOMMUNITIES.
ADDITIONALLY ONE PLASTIC WASTE
IS EXPORTED TO OTHER COUNTRIES
THE EXES THAT CAN'T BE PROPERLY
MANAGE ALMOST ALWAYS ENDS UP
BEING DUMPED IN OR NEAR THE
POOREST COMMUNITIES.
AND EXACERBATE TO CYCLE OF
PRODUCTION AND POVERTY IN THOSE
AREAS.
IN FACT -- IS THIS PAST DECEMBER
DURING A MEETING OF THE EXPERT
GROUP OF MARINE THAT ARE INMY
CAR PLASTICS WHICH TOOK PART IN
A FIRST OF ITS KIND EVENT
ORGANIZED BY THE UNITED STATES
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAM.
WHICH START I HAS STARTED TO
EXPLORE THE EFFECTS OF PLASTIC
POLLUTION AS AN ISSUE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
WITHOUT IMMEDIATE ACTION TO
PLANET SIMPLY CANNOT SUSTAIN THE
GROWING RATE OF PLASTIC
PRODUCTION AND PRODUCTION AND
FOR THAT REASON WE'RE STRONG
SUPPORT AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF SOLACE
FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
IN STRONG WASTE -- URGE AN AYE
VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- I'M SURE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KERA MONTHS AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE YOUR
PARTNERS -- ON A NUMBER OF WAYS
TO VERSION RECYCLING PROGRAMS
AND WE ARE WORKING HAND IN HAND%
WITH THE STATE ON A NUMBER OF
THE CHALLENGES AT THAT IS
SOMETHING MEMBER OUTLINED.
MARKET DISRUPTIONS THE NEED FOR
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
EDUCATING THE PUBLIC THESE ARE
ALL ISSUES THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
BUT WE REALLY NEED TO DO MORE
AND THAT'S WHY WE SINCERELY
APPRECIATE -- THE PROCESS
OUTLINED IN THIS BILL --
PLASTICS ARE POLLUTING OUR
ENVIRONMENT OUR WATER WAYS AND
ULTIMATELY THEY ARE COSTING
CONSTITUENTS OUR RESIDENTS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
WE SUPPORT THIS APPROACH BECAUSE
IT FOCUSES ON THE FRONT AND ON
THE SOURCE REDUCTION RATHER THAN
DEALING WITH THE WASTE AFTER
IT'S ALREADY PRODUCED -- WE KNOW
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK I HAD TO
DO BUT REALLY APPRECIATE THE
NURTURES TRANSPORTED THIS BILL.
AND IF I MAY MADAM CHAIR -- I AM
HERE IN IN SOLIDARITY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL -- WE ARE YOU FOLKS
WE KNOW THERE'S A COMPANION BILL
IDENTICAL COMPANION BILL ON
THESE ON THE SENATE SIDE WE WENT
THERE COMMITTEE.
LAST WEEK WITH A FIVE TWO ZERO
VOTE AND I HAPPY TO TALK A
LITTLE ABOUT IT -- BUT IT IS
ACTUALLY TRUE THAT THAT THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT HAS A CREATED
CHALLENGES ON SO MANY DIFFERENT
LEVELS AND ONE THING I SHOULD
MENTION LOCAL GOVERNMENT SIDE.
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NOW OPEN
ON THE STATE OR SPENDING FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR ON ON LITTER CLEAN UP --
AND AND AND LITTER PREVENTION
ALONE AND THAT DOESN'T EVEN
START TO GET INTO THE ENORMOUS
CHALLENGES THAT ARE ABOUT TO
SLAM ARE THAT ARE ALREADY
SLAMMING OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
WITH THE COURTS TO WASTE
MANAGEMENT AND THE IMPACTS OF
NATIONAL SORT WHERE THE CHINESE
HAVE BASICALLY SAID THEY DON'T
WANT TO RECYCLING ANYMORE.
THEY'RE NOT WILLING TO TAKE IT
AND THAT IS THAT IS IS IS NOW --
CREATING A WATERFALL OF IMPACTS
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ABILITY TO
TO MANAGE WASTE IS IT'S
DISTRESSING HOW LITTLE -- FOLKS --
IT IS IT IS GETTING ACTION
RECYCLED -- THE STUFF THAT
ACTUALLY IT'S THROWN INTO THE
BLUE BANDS.
ARE BECAUSE OF THE CURRENT STATE
OF PLAY RECYCLING SUPPORT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE NOT ONLY IS TO
TO REDUCE WASTE BUT ALSO --
CREATE A MORE OF A MARKET FOR
RECYCLED CONTENT RECYCLABILITY
TRUE RECYCLABILITY NOT
RECYCLABILITY JUST IN THE IN THE
LAB BUT RECYCLABILITY IN IN THE
REAL WORLD -- IT'S IT'S AN
ELEGANT APPROACH IT IT IT IS
FLEXIBLE -- BUT ULTIMATELY HELPS
TO ADDRESS ONE OF THE MOST
PRESSING INFRASTRUCTURAL
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE RIGHT
NOW -- AS A STATE AND AND AT LET
ALONE ALL THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS ASSOCIATED SO WITH THAT
I I'M HAPPY TO TO PARTICIPATE
DISCUSSION ANSWER WHATEVER
QUESTIONS WILL CLAP.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN FOR
JOINING US -- BUT WITHOUT ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NICK OFFICE OF CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND AVAILABLE FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS -- MARKETERS
ARE GOOD FOR THE DIRECTOR OF A
QUICK HERE I COME THEY SEE
NASTRAN SERVING OVER FIVE
THOUSAND FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
FARMWORKERS WERE STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
VICTORIA ROOM WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MELISSA ROMERO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
THE STORY OF SUSPECTS STUFF
PROJECT CENTER FOR OCEANIC
AWARENESS RESEARCH AND EDUCATION
THE FIVE GYRES INSTITUTE PLASTIC
POLLUTION COALITION WHICH CHOI
CHU MARCH FOUNDATION AND CAL
BURKE AND SUPPORT [inaudible]
STRONG SUPPORT. THREE IS A
BROKERAGE ON BEHALF OF HEAL THE
BAY UPSTREAM ZERO ACE USA AND
SEVENTH GENERATION ADVISORS AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JUST MILAN BAHA
OFFICER BROUGHT A FOUNDATION
CLEAN WATER ACTION THE
CALIFORNIA COMPOST COLLISION
SAVE AYE SHOWS.
AND THOSE HOUSE OSPINABERMAN
CALIFORNIA TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WAS
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHAUN RECKONS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF LOCAL CONSERVATION CORD IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT.
GET AFTERNOON JAMIE GO ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA RELIEF AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ESPERANZA VELMA
WITH CAFE TO AND WITH THE UC
BERKELEY CHECK ON THAT THE
ALUMNI ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
AND ONLY SERVER -- DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
KELLY JENSEN ON BEHALF RECOLOGY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THE LARGEST
COMPOST DURING THE STATE.
PERSONAL GET US ON THE OFFICE
STOP WASTE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL AT
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IN SUPPORT.
READ AT US ON BEHALF OF PRE
RETHINK WASTE IN THE BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS IN
SUPPORT.
INJURY MUSICIAN -- WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS A
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
RVCA MUSTARD OR NOT A WITH THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND.
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT -- RESPECT
CHECK A COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARK PRAYER FOR
REPUBLIC SERVICES. 4% OF FOR THE
WASTE STREAM IS PLASTIC FILM IT
IS 70% OF OUR PROBLEM AT
MATERIAL RECOVERY FACILITIES WE
ARE DRIVE OUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALONG THE PARK
REPRESENTING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COALITION FOR WATER AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO CAITLYN COLUSA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COAST KEEPER ALLIANCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LAUREN COMMISSAIRE CLUB
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
BUT AS THE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
LARA FRONT IN BEHALF OF THE
NORTHERN DISTRICT OF THE
CALIFORNIA REFUSE RECYCLING
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. ONE OF THE
MEN ON A WITHOUT A ONE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
JIM WHEN BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
JOHN KENNEDY WITH RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE A SUPPORTIVE AMENDED
RECOMMENDATION WE APPRECIATE
WHAT THE AUTHORS HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO DO TO RESPOND A
NATIONAL SOARED INCREASE
RECYCLABILITY AND COMPOSED
ABILITY.
AND CREATE AND STATE
MANUFACTURING JOBS AT THE SAME
TIME WE'RE DEALING WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE WITH RESPECT
ORGANIC WASTE RECYCLING.
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE IT'S
EXTREMELY PROBLEMATIC FOR A
NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SO WE WANT TO AVOID
A LOT OF THOSE PROBLEMS BY
THINKING AHEAD THINKING FORWARD
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE.
A A COMPLETE SOLUTION HERE WHEN
WE TRY TO DEAL WITH THIS WASTE
STREAM SO THANK YOU LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD -- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TIM
CHEST ACHE WITH THE AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL -- LET ME.
FIRST START BY SAYING THAT WE
ARE NOT OPPOSED TO WHAT THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO ACHIEVE IN
FACT OUR ORGANIZATION HAS SET
SOME VERY AMBITIOUS STANDARDS
1100% RECYCLABILITY.
AND RECOVER ABILITY FOR PLASTIC
PACKAGING BY.
TWENTY THIRTY WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE ISSUES WITH THE
CURRENT RECYCLING -- MARKETS --
GIVEN SITUATION CHINA.
A NUMBER OF OUR COMPANIES AND
NUMBER OF OUR DOWNSTREAM USERS
IN THE CONSUMER PRODUCTS SECTOR
HAVE TAKEN SOME SERIOUS STEPS
AND COMMITMENTS TO INCREASING
THE AMOUNT OF MATERIAL TO COVER
USING RECYCLED CONTENT -- AND
TRYING TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
MATERIAL -- THAT ENDS UP IN OUR
OCEANS AND RIVERS.
HAVING SAID THAT THERE ARE SOME.
ISSUES WITH THE BILL THAT WE
THINK WARRANT SOME CONSIDERATION
AND ONGOING DISCUSSION AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE THOSE TODAY.
ONE IS THE SCOPE OF THE BILL.
IS UNCLEAR THE BILL USES ARIOUS
TERM SINGLE USE PACKAGING
SINGING THIS PRODUCTS.
SINGLE USE CONSUMER GOODS --
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE SOME
CLARITY AND UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT ALL THIS MEANS THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT POINT I THINK NEEDS TO
BE CONSIDERED AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD.
THIS BILL ALSO GRANTS UNFETTERED
AUTHORITY TO CAL RECYCLE. TO
IMPLEMENT A WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED IN FACT THE BILL SAYS
ANY OTHER REGULATIONS ARE
POLICIES THE DEPARTMENT DEEMS
NECESSARY.
THIS IS A SWEEPING DELEGATION OF
AUTHORITY TO CAL RECYCLE WE
THINK THERE OUGHT TO BE SOME
OVERSIGHT AND RULE BY THE ROLE
BY THE LEGISLATURE.
PRACTICAL TIME LINES.
IN OUR VIEW.
ARE NECESSARY RIGHT NOW THE BILL
SAYS WITHIN A YEAR OUR CYCLE
SUPPOSED TO DEVELOP INITIAL
SCOPING PLAN.
INITIAL RECYCLING RATE NEEDS TO
BE DETERMINED BY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE DON'T THINK
THAT'S AN ACHIEVABLE GOAL
PRACTICAL TIME JOHN TIME LINES
ARE ARE NEEDED DAY DISNEY GABBY
NEED TO BE COLLECTED RECYCLING
RATES ANY BE CALCULATED.
EXPANSION OF EXISTING COLLECTION
INFRASTRUCTURE IS GOING TO BE
NECESSARY.
DEVELOPING DOMESTIC MARKETS FOR
MATERIAL THAT ONCE PREVIOUSLY
WAS EXPORTED CHINA.
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME.
IT'S UNCLEAR ON THE TOPIC OF
SOURCE REDUCTION IT'S UNCLEAR TO
US WHAT EXACTLY.
THAT MEANS AND HOW RESPONSIBLE
ENTITIES WOULD COMPLY PACKAGING
SERVES A NECESSARY PURPOSE TO
GET PRODUCT FROM MANUFACTURE TO
MARKET TO THE CONSUMER IN A SAFE
AND EFFICIENT MANNER SIMPLY
USING LESS PACKAGING.
MAY NOT EITHER BE TECHNICALLY
FEASIBLE OR MAY NOT EVEN BE.
IN QATAR COULD POSSIBLY BE IN
CONFLICT WITH WITH STATE FEDERAL
LAW.
THE FINAL POINT I MAKE IS THAT
THE STATE CURRENTLY OPERATES HAS
BEEN ON THE BOOKS SINCE THE
EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES.
CAL RECYCLABLE MEN'S THE RIGID
PLASTIC PACKAGING CONTAINER LAW
REQUIREMENT THAT PACKAGING FROM
EIGHT OUNCES TO FIVE GALLONS
EITHER RESOURCE REDUCED OR
CONTAIN A PERCENTAGE 25%.
RECYCLED CONTENT.
MANY COMPANIES ARE COMPLYING
WITH THAT HAVE TAKEN STEPS TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF MATERIAL
THAT THEY UTILIZE PROPOSED
CONSUMER PERSPECTIVE IN THE
MANUFACTURE OF NEW PRODUCTS.
IT'S UNCLEAR HOW THIS LAW THE
EXISTING LAW.
WOULD COME WOULD COMPORT WITH
WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED UNDER SOME
A BILL.
TEN EIGHTY SO HAVING SAID THAT I
I WE WE ARE OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED -- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH OPPONENTS ON THIS
WE'RE NOT OBJECTING TO WHAT THIS
BILL ULTIMATELY HOPES TO ACHIEVE.
WE THINK THERE'S SOME SERIOUS
QUESTIONS AND WORK THE NEEDS TO
BE DONE TO TRY TO ADDRESS THESE --
BEFORE THE FINAL WORK PRODUCT --
COULD POTENTIALLY BE SENT TO THE
GOVERNOR SO WITH THAT WE ARE ARE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED CREATE THE
OPTION TO MAKE THESE COMMENTS
THANK YOU AND PLEASE STAY THERE
I BELIEVE THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A QUICK.
QUESTION FOR YOU FROM ONE OF THE
MEMBERS IN JUST A MOMENT.
THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
BEN CHAIR MEMBERS JOE ADLER ON
BEHALF OF PLASTICS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION -- WE TESTIFIED LAST
WEEK TO THE CENTER ALLEN AND
WE'RE IN THE SAME POSITION NOW
WE'VE OUTLINED OR WE EIGHT ECHO
ALLOW WITH MR SHESTAKOV SAID WE
OUTLINED OUR POSITION IN OUR
LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE.
WELL AS WE SAID THE CENTER ALLEN
TO THE ASSEMBLY ONE WE WANT TO
BE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD THINGS
THAT CAN BE DONE AND WE WERE
LOOKING FORWARD TO GETTING
STARTED.
THANK YOU.
THE COOKING UNITS ON BEHALF OF
THE HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION AND WE
ALIGN OUR CONCERNS WITH AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL THANK YOU.
ADAM WRIGLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ALSO HAVE A OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED FOR THE REASONS STATED
AND WE APPRECIATE -- THE AUTHORS --
INTEND TO ADDRESS THIS IMPORTANT
PROBLEM AND I'VE BEEN EDUCATED
MEMBERS TO COME TO THE TABLE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MATT CERTAIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION AS
WELL WE COULD WORK EFFECTIVELY
WITH SENATOR.
ALLEN LAST YEAR ON FOOD
PACKAGING LEGISLATION AND WE
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS
ON THIS AND FOOD PACKAGING.
AGING IS THE SAME REGARDLESS OF
WHERE FOOD IS SERVED IS WHAT WE
WOULD LEAVE YOU WITH THANK.
ERIN ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION ASSOCIATE OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE MISTER SHASTA
ACT LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ.
AND SENATOR ALLEN -- TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM THANKS.
DENNIS ALBION AND HAVE THE
GROCERY MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS THE
AMERICAN BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION
AGAIN WE ASSOCIATE OUR COMMENTS
WITH -- MISTER SHAW STICK AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING ON
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DON CAP KIßM
HALF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WITH A LINE MY
COMMENTS ARE WITH THOSE OF THE
PER SPEAKERS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING TOGETHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA MOVE NOW
TO THE COMMITTEE I BELIEVE MS
EGGMAN HAD A NOT A I JUST WANT
TO SAY -- WELCOME IS CONTROLS TO
THIS COMMITTEE AND TO WORKING IN
THE SPACE -- AT AN AS YOU'RE
WORKING A BIG POLICIES LIKE THIS
I UNDERSTAND THAT SOMETIMES
DEFINITIONS AND WORKING THESE
THINGS OUT CRITICAL WHILE.
WORKING ON SOMETHING SIMILAR --
THAT WILL COMPLEMENT WHAT YOU'RE
DOING I'M SURE.
SO I'M PREPARED TO MOVE THIS
BILL TODAY TO IF IT HASN'T BEEN
MOVED YET TO CONTINUE MOVING IT
FORWARD -- AND I TRUST THAT YOU
CAN HAVE IT PEOPLE AT THE TABLE
BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW THIS IS A
PROBLEM WE HAVE TO GRAPPLE WITH
AND WE NEED TO COME TO TABLE
FIGURE OUT HOW TO WORK IT OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN A SECOND -- THE
MOTION I DO APPRECIATE THAT
THEIR ACTION YOUR POINT WITH
THIS BILL -- I HOPE AS WE'RE
DOING THIS WORK THAT WERE ALSO
THINKING ABOUT HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THERE'S A MARKET.
READY TO TAKE THESE PRODUCTS THE
LASTING WHY DO THEY SEE SOME OF
OUR OTHER.
PROGRAMS OUT THERE WE HAVE A
BUNCH OF RECYCLED MATERIAL
SITTING IN WAREHOUSES.
AND SO I HOPE THAT THOSE
DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE IN AND OUT
OF THIS BILL -- THERE'S A NUMBER
OF BILLS OUT THERE THAT WAS VERY
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE ISSUES
WHETHER IT'S MANDATING A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF RESPECTABLE.
ELEMENTS IN OUR PRODUCTS OR
OTHER THINGS BUT I HOPE WE'RE
HAVING A DISCUSSION NOW AND NOT
IN.
TWENTY THIRTY ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
MR STONE.
JUST A BRIEF COMMENT THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
WE OFTEN SEE WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH PLASTICS WE'VE TRIED
SOMEONE OFTEN ONE ALSO REALLY
NOT GONNA WORK BANDS AND OTHER
THINGS BUT SOMETIMES THAT'S ALL
THAT'S LEFT TO US.
AS WE REALLY TRY AND GET THE
ATTENTION OF EVERYONE WHO IS
USING A PROLIFERATING ESPECIALLY
SO.
IT'S NICE TO HEAR OR ALL OF THE
OPPOSITION AS BEING WILLING TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THIS AND I HOPE
THAT THAT REALLY HOLDS TRUE.
BECAUSE TO OFFICE IT'S EASIER TO
KILL SOMETHING OF THIS GO THEN
REALLY WORK THROUGH THE PROBLEM
AND IT'S GOING TO TAKE.
DESIGN MANUFACTURE DISTRIBUTION.
AND FIGURE OUT OF THE BACK AND
HOW WE MANAGE THE RECYCLING.
AND WHEN WE FOCUS ON TO THAT END
BUT WE CAN'T FORGET THE WE'VE
ALWAYS HEARD THIS AS WE WERE
GROWING UP REDUCE REUSE RECYCLE
WILL ALWAYS SEEM TO BE DO LATELY
IS FOUR FOUR BECAUSE THE
RECYCLING RECYCLING RECYCLING WE
KNOW THAT THAT SYSTEM.
IS IN A BIT OF COLLAPSE IT IS
NOT WORKING.
SO WE HAVE TO REDUCE WHAT WE USE
WE HAVE.
TO REPURPOSE AND THINK ABOUT
THAT BUT ALSO LOOKING AT
PACKAGING AND CONTENTS OF
PRODUCTS CLASSICS ARE NOT GOING
AWAY.
BUT HOW MUCH IS THE EACH OF THE
ITEMS OF SOME OF THE IS IS
REALLY THE INQUIRY THAT WE NEED
TO MAKE.
A PARTNER WITH INDUSTRY A
PARTNER WITH THOSE WHO ARE
TRYING TO BE IN THE ECONOMY AND
MAKING MONEY THAT'S FINE.
BUT HELP US SO THAT WE ARE NOT
LEFT TO HAVING INDIVIDUALS AND
GOVERNMENT IS CLEANING UP THE
MESS IT'S GREAT COASTAL CLEANUP
DAYS IT'S A REAL RALLYING CRY
FOR PEOPLE. TO GO OUT THERE AND
DO THAT BUT THE AMOUNT OF TIME
AND MONEY THEY GET SPENT BY
TAXPAYERS.
LOCAL.
AGENCIES AND INDIVIDUALS
CLEANING UP THE MESS THAT WE'VE
CREATED OUR ENVIRONMENT IS A
LITTLE BIT FRUSTRATING WHEN A
BETTER SOLUTION WOULD BE TO
BRING.
ALL THE PARTIES TOGETHER FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN.
ALLOW THE PRODUCTS TO BE IN OUR
ECONOMY THE ONES THAT PEOPLE
REALLY WANT TO BE ABLE TO USE.
BUT SOLVE THE AMOUNT OF PLASTIC
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE
PRODUCTS IN THE AT SO I THINK
THERE REALLY ARE SOLUTIONS HERE.
AND IT THESE BIGGER SCALE THINGS
ARE DIFFICULT.
BUT IF WE CAN GET ALL THE
PLAYERS TAKING SOME OF
RESPONSIBILITY REALLY HELPING
ALL THIS OUT -- HOPEFUL THAT
THERE'S A GREAT PATH HERE SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD THINKING.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ALL I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR -- BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AUTHOR AND THE SENATE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
I'M VERY PROUD TO BE AN AUTHOR.
OF THE BILL AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT CERTAINLY HAS
CAPTURED THE ATTENTION OF OUR
VOTERS OF THE PUBLIC.
AND IN CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW WE DO
A PRETTY DECENT JOB OF KEEPING A
LOT OF THESE INVER OF THESE
POLLUTANTS OUT OF OUR IMMEDIATE
OUT THIS OUT OF OUR IMMEDIATE
ENVIRONMENT SO WE DON'T SEE THIS
MUCH BUT THAT'S NOT THE CASE
AROUND THE WORLD.
AND CERTAINLY WITH A LOT OF THE
PLASTICS THAT WE SHIPPED
OVERSEAS -- YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENS
WITH A LOT OF THOSE THAT END UP
NOT BEING RECYCLED AND BEING
INSTEAD DUMPED INTO THEIR
ENVIRONMENT.
AND SO PEOPLE REALLY ARE
DEMANDING THAT WE DO A LOT
BETTER AND THE PUBLIC -- WHEN
THEY PURCHASE A PRODUCT THEY
DON'T -- ALWAYS EXPECT THAT
PRODUCT TO THEN BE WRAPPED IN
PLASTIC AND SHIPPED IN MORE
PLASTIC -- AND THE MANUFACTURERS
AND THE SHIPPERS AND THE
RETAILERS -- SOMETIMES TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT BUT A
LOT OF TIMES UNFORTUNATELY DON'T
AND WHAT THEY DO INSTEAD IS THEY
DUMP A LOT OF THIS.
MATERIAL INTO OUR COMMUNITIES
AND EXPECT OUR COMMUNITIES TO
PAY THE COST -- WITH THEIR
POCKETBOOKS AND YOU KNOW
ENVIRONMENTALLY -- OF FOR THEIR
OWN PROFITS AND THAT HAS TO YOU
KNOW I THINK I AS A BODY WE HAVE
TO TAKE VERY DEFINITIVE ACTION
AGAINST THAT I THINK THE
PUBLIC'S EXPECTING IT.
AND CERTAINLY OUR CHILDREN
DEMAND IT SO AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK -- THIS GONZALEZ AND
MISTER ALLEN FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I'M VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS TODAY.
WITH BACK AND WE HAVE A VOTE
PLEASE ROLL CALL PLEASE -- DO
YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY
ANYTHING IN CLOSING NOW I JUST
WHEN I THINK -- THE MEMBERS FOR
THEIR COMMENTS SPECIFICALLY --
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW AND AND RECYCLED PRODUCT
AND THINGS THAT WE AS CONSUMERS
SO OFTEN EVEN IF WE THINK WE'RE
DOING THE RIGHT THING EVEN IF WE
ARE TRYING OUR BEST? TO TO PUT
EVERYTHING IN THE BLUE BAND TO
WATCH THINGS OUT TO USE LESS --
WE NEED SOME HELP AND WE NEED
SOME HELP BY THE MANUFACTURES
AND WE NEED THIS TO BE AT THE
EFFORT I THINK BY THE ENTIRE
CIRCLE OF OF OF USERS -- AND
THOSE WHO PRODUCE IT -- YOU
TALKED ABOUT OTHER COUNTRIES AND
SEEN THE WASTE AND SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WE ACTUALLY SEE THAT
WASTE TO WE SEE IT EVERY SINGLE
DAY AND WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES -- TO CLEAN UP SO MUCH
OF THE LETTER AND I AND PRODUCTS
THAT END UP IN OUR WATER STREAMS
THAT END UP IN OUR OCEANS AND
REPRESENTING A WORKING CLASS
COASTAL COMMUNITY.
I PROBABLY SEE IT A LOT MORE
THAN SOME OTHER COASTAL
COMMUNITIES NOT JUST ON ON
COASTAL CLEANUP DAY ON THE BEACH
BUT EVERY SINGLE DAY.
IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS -- IN OUR
PARKS AND AND ON THE ON THE
GROUNDS.
OF OUR STREETS AND SO -- THIS IS
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED --
FOR THE WELL BEING OF ALL
COMMUNITIES BUT IS SPECIFICALLY
AN ISSUE I THINK IN SOME OF OUR
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
WHO ARE BURKE BURDEN NOT ONLY.
AT THE END RESULTS WITH THE
LETTER BUT OUR BIRD IN THE VERY
BEGINNING WHERE THESE THINGS ARE
MADE AND THE TYPE OF
MANUFACTURING GOING ON AND THE
EFFECTS OF THAT MANUFACTURING
ALL THE WAY THROUGH -- OF COURSE
IN THE PRODUCTS WE EAT AND DRINK
AND THEN THE LETTER AS WELL SO --
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
I AM TWENTY FOUR AB TEN EIGHTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LIMóN.
LOW MOAN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ.
WROTE SURGERY.
STONE [inaudible]
STONE I ONE ROLE OPEN.
A SOME EVER PETRIE-NORRIS
[inaudible]
GOOD.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY
TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB
SIXTY FIVE THIS BILL WILL INVEST
IN GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE
CALIFORNIA COAST.
IN ORDER TO COMBAT SEA LEVEL
RISE AS THIS BODY WELL KNOWS
CLIMATE CHANGE IS THE
FUNDAMENTAL CHALLENGE
CONFRONTING OUR GENERATION.
AS OUR STATE CONTINUES TO LEAD
ON COMBATING CLIMATE CHANGE AND
WE WORK TO ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE
GOALS WE ALSO MUST SAFEGUARD
CALIFORNIA DEVELOPING STRATEGIES
TO ADAPT TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND STRATEGIES TO MITIGATE THEN
ON OUR COAST THE CALIFORNIA
COAST IS EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILES OF BREATHTAKING BEAUTY.
HOME TO NEARLY 70% OF
CALIFORNIANS AND CRITICAL ENGINE
OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
BUT THAT'S ALL UNDER THREAT FROM
SEA LEVEL RISE SEA LEVELS ARE
PROJECTED TO RISE BY FIVE FEET
BY THE END OF THIS CENTURY AND
IF WE DO NOT ACT CALIFORNIA WILL
LOSE MORE THAN HALF OF OUR
COASTAL HABITAT TO SEA LEVEL
RISE.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE AND BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ARE DIRECTLY AT RISK
UNLESS WE ACT NOW.
AND OUR BEST DEFENSE IS NATURE
ITSELF OUR COASTLINES ARE AMONG
THE MOST DYNAMIC ENVIRONMENTS ON
EARTH.
THEY'RE CONSTANTLY SHAPED BY
WAVES WINDS TIDES AND STORMS
NATURAL ECOSYSTEMS THRIVE ADMITS
THIS CHANGE AND HAVE INDEED
DEVELOP THE CAPACITY TO SHAPE
THAT CHANGE.
SOME EXAMPLES OF NATURAL OR
GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE SOLUTIONS
INCLUDE DUNES WHICH REDUCE
FLOODING AND REPLENISH BEACHES
KELP AND SEAGRASS WHICH REDUCE
WAVE IMPACTS AND MARSHES WHICH
CAN REDUCE FLOODING AERATION.
AND NATURAL INFRASTRUCTURE
DOESN'T JUST COMBAT SEA LEVEL
RISE THIS APPROACH CREATES
COASTAL HABITATS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT FOR CARBON
SEQUESTRATION AND BUILD
RESILIENT ECOSYSTEMS.
ADDITIONALLY ACCORDINGTO THE
EPA GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE ALSO
COSTS LESS THAN CONVENTIONAL
GRAY INFRASTRUCTURE MAKING THIS
A COST EFFICIENT.
RESILIENT APPROACH TO COASTAL
ADAPTATION.
AB SIXTY FIVE WILL INVEST IN
GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE SOLUTIONS
THAT ARE PROVEN TO WORK IS WHEN
WE PROTECT NATURE NATURE
PROTECTS US.
I'M PLEASED TO INTRODUCE TO
SUPPORTERS TODAY TO ADD TO
COMMENT.
RVCA MASTER NADO FROM THE TRUST
FOR PUBLIC LAND TO I GET THAT
RIGHT BUT YOUR LAST NAME.
DEVELOP POTTER FROM THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY.
THANK YOU -- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RECALL MUST REALLY NOT A
WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND.
CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMAN BERBER UP
PETRIE-NORRIS FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD.
AND AS SHE MENTIONED WE THERE'S
A LOT OF STEAK WITH OUR
COASTLINE EIGHT HUNDRED MILES OF
MOST OF THE PEOPLE.
A NINETY SIX BILLION DOLLAR
ECONOMY THAT'S RELATED TO
OUTDOOR ACTIVITIES A LOT OF THAT
IS ON THE COAST A LOT OF TOURISM.
A LOT OF SPECTACULAR LANDSCAPES --
NATURAL SYSTEMS SHOULD ALWAYS BE
EXPLORED BEFORE GRAY
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR ALL THE
REASONS THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NOTED.
THEY ARE.
LESS EXPENSIVE.
THEY DO FOSTER -- NATURAL
SYSTEMS AND ECOSYSTEMS AND
HABITATS.
AND WE BELIEVE THERE ARE MORE
EFFECTIVE FRANKLY.
SO -- REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
BRING THIS FORWARD WARMER --
STRONG SUPPORT AND THINK THIS IS
JUST A SIMPLE BUT REALLY SMART
BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- MICHELLE PASSER
OVER THE NATURE CONSERVANCY I'M
THE DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
PROGRAM AND MY COLLEAGUE
ISABELLA IS IN THE AUDIENCE HERE
SO WE WE OFTEN.
TECH YOU KNOW DON'T NOT A
PROBLEM -- SO -- WE APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP --
BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN PETRIE-NORRIS
AND I THINK YOU COVERED A LOT OF
THE REASONS WHY IT'S IMPORTANT --
TO FOR US TO USE NATURAL FOR
STRUCTURE TO HELP SAFEGUARD
COMMUNITIES.
AGAIN SANTA VOIDABLE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE -- AND YOU AS YOU
MAY KNOW FROM THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL REPORT THAT WE ARE
ALREADY EXPERIENCING THE EARLY
IMPACTS OF SEA LEVEL RISE THIS
INCLUDES.
A MORE EXTENSIVE COASTAL
FLOODING DURING STORMS --
PERIODIC TIDAL FLOODING AND
INCREASE COASTAL EROSION AND SO
WHILE WE DO NEED TO CONTINUE TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS TO AVOID THE
POTENTIAL WORST CASE SCENARIOS
WE ALSO DO NEED TO BE PREPARED
FOR THE UNAVOIDABLE IMPACTS TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WE DO THINK
AB.
SIXTY FIVE DOES THAT -- IT
REINFORCES THE USE OF NATURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURES ARE SAYING AS A
KEY TOOL TAKE A SAFEGUARD HUMAN
AND NATURAL COMMUNITIES AGAINST
YOU LOVE ARISE -- AND IT DOES
THIS BY CLARIFYING THE KINDS OF
NOT NATURAL INFRASTRUCTURE --
THAT THE COSTA CONSERVANCY MAY
INVEST IN -- SUCH AS THE
WETLANDS BEACHES HELP FOR US IN
TITLE MARCHES THAT WERE
MENTIONED -- THIS WILL HELP
THEIR COMMUNITIES FROM ENHANCE
CLIMB INVESTS -- THE OTHER
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THIS BILL --
DOES IT AUTHORIZES THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
AND BASED ON OUR EXPERIENCE
WORKING WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
LOCAL COMMUNITIES THIS IS A HUGE
GAP -- AND IT REALLY IS A
BARRIER -- FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
RIGHT NOW REALLY CROSS THE BOARD
TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE I'M SO
WE THINK THIS IS ALSO -- PRETTY
CRITICAL -- SO WITH THAT WE'RE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF AB SIXTY FIVE
AND WE DO URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WE GET CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
LEARN COMMON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
A CAITLYN COLUSA WITH CALIFORNIA
COAST KEEPER ALLIANCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
AARON RODRIGUEZ WITH UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT.
VICTORIA AROUND WITH AN RTC IN
SUPPORT.
JUST MULLIN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TEEN SEES LOBBYING COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
ERNEST CHECK OF NIKISCH WORKS
MECHANISTIC NOT IN SUPPORT.
ALLEY SERVER -- DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
HELLO JAMIE GO ON BEHALF OF A
SCHOOL AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE OF THEM IT ON A
WITHOUT ONE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THREE SEPARATE VERGE ON BEHALF
OF YOUR THE BAY IN SUPPORT.
READ ADDISON BEHALF OF OCEAN
CONSERVANCY IN CALIFORNIA TROUT
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PEAK OF THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SIGNAL TURN TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS WITH
COMMENTS.
YEAH WITH A MOTION A SECOND WAVE
A ROLL CALL PLEASE -- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE.
THANK YOU ROLL CALL.
ITEM ONE AB SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATRICK NORRIS
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN
[inaudible]
GARCIA.
HI Là MON.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
STONE AYE. FIVE ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW YOU'RE ALSO
PRESENTING ON AB ATENOLOL YES I
AM.
AND I'VE GOT SOMEONE IN THE
MOVIE.
THE MOST IN A SECOND
[inaudible]
I GOT.
IT'S CLEAR THE MOTION A SECOND.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
ON THIS I BETTER MISSION A
SECOND HELLO YES I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
OKAY.
ARE YOU A WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
I DO I OKAY SORRY I'M HERE TO
ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI BY TEN
ELEVEN THE FIRST OF THIS BILL IS
TO ENCOURAGE THE PARTICIPATION
OF FIVE OH ONE C. THREE NON
PROFITS IN.
RESTORATION PROJECTS BY
PROVIDING LEGISLATIVE GUIDANCE
TO THE COASTAL COMMISSION WITH
RESPECT TO PERMIT FEE WAIVERS
ADAM AND WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
COASTAL COMMISSION ON THIS AND
IF THEY HAVE BEEN SUPPORTIVE.
IT'S A ALTHOUGH I HAD TO
ALTHOUGH THE CAUSE COMMISSIONS
CURRENT REGULATIONS TO ALLOW FOR
THE REDUCTION OR WAIVER OF
FILING FEES.
BECAUSE THE ACT ITSELF IS SILENT
ON HOW THE COMMISSION SHOULD
CONSIDER THESE REQUEST.
AND DAD AB AT TEN ELEVEN WILL
ALSO REQUIRE THE COMMISSION TO
GIVE ADDITIONAL CONSIDERATION TO
NONPROFITS WHO WISH TO RESTORE
SENSITIVE HABITAT HABITAT AREAS
AND IMPROVE PUBLIC ACCESS ALONG
THE COAST.
ACCORDING TO THE COMMISSION ONLY
TO NON PROFITS OVER THE LAST
DECADE HAVE PLAYED FOR A FEE
WAIVER WHICH SUGGESTS THAT.
YES WITH THE CURRENTLY IN PLACE
IT IS NOT AN EFFECTIVE INCENTIVE
TO OUR GOAL IS THAT -- WILL BE
ABLE TO PRINT TO BOLSTER THE
PARTICIPATION OF OF THESE NON
PROFITS.
AND INCENTIVIZE CRITICAL
PROJECTS TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF OUR COASTLINE AND MAKE
CALIFORNIA MORE RESILIENT AND
FACE OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND REALLY PLEASED TO
HAS ALFREDO ERA DANDO HERE.
HI TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
FEDERAL ON THE HERE ON BEHALF OF
US -- AN ORGANIZATION WORKING
WITH LOOKING COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA -- TO CONTINUE PICKED
A COSTA PROVIDE ACCESS TO OUR
COASTLINE.
I'LL BE ACTUALLY REALLY BRIEF
I'LL JUST SAY THAT -- REDUCING
BARRIERS LIKE ACOSTA PERMITTING
FOR THESE KINDS OF PUBLIC
INTEREST PROJECTS -- THEIR
SPEARHEADED BY NON PROFITS MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE ESPECIALLY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AS THIS BILL DOES --
AT HABITAT RESTORATION AS WELL
AS COASTAL ACCESS PROJECTS --
BABIES CAN OFTEN BE LIMITING
FACTORS WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
ADMIN PIECE OF THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AT THE MINIMUM -- AND
WITH ESCALATING COSTS DEPENDING
ON THE ON THE SIZE OF THE
PROJECT -- IT COULD BE
OVERWHELMING FOR FOR NONPROFIT
STICK ON THESE KINDS OF THINGS
AND WE KNOW THAT WE NEED EVERY
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX AS WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON NUMEROUS
ISSUES INCLUDING NATURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE MPLEMENTATION AS
WAS CLOSED BUT A TATIAN WRIT
LARGE AND COAST LEXUS PROJECTS
OF ANOTHER COAST.
SO WITH THAT I'M REALLY HAPPY.
TO BE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SOMEONE BURKE -- CUT IF YOU'RE
NOTICES BILL AND TONIGHT BUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THINK MANAGER WE KEEP DONE HERE
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION AS GOOD
CITIZENS AND MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY RIVER SUPPORT OF THIS
EFFORT THAT PROVIDES ACCESS AN
ADDITIONAL -- ENCOURAGEMENTS
NONPROFITS TO HELP HAVE --
EFFORTS TO CLEAN UP OR COAST AND
PROVIDE OUR CITIZENS WAY TO
ENJOY IT SO WITH THAT WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WELL HAVE MADE ON A WITHOUT A
ONE CALIFORNIANS RUN SUPPORT OF
THIS.
LOW INCOME SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SIR CHRISTY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION AND ALTHOUGH
THE COMMISSION AS AN AGENCY IS
NOT HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
A FORMAL POSITION YET THEY WILL
BE DOING SO AT THEIR APRIL
MEETING.
AS THE AUTHOR MENTION WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE ON THE LANGUAGE
AND WE THINK THIS ALLIANCE WITH
THE INTENT THE GOALS OF THE COST
LIKE POLICIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OPPOSITION ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I MOVED TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE ACTUALLY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF COMMENTS.
SIGNAL TO A VOTE.
I DON'T TWENTY THREE A. B. TEN
ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATRICK NORRIS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
GARCIA GARCIA I LIMóN.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY MELENDEZ RIGHT
TO JURY STONE.
STONE I FIVE ZERO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU.
MISTER HOLDEN.
YOU ARE HERE FOR AB [inaudible]
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE YEAH.
BETTER HEARING MEMBERS THANK YOU --
I'M HERE TO PRESENT -- SEVEN
FIFTY FIVE WHICH ESTABLISHES THE
STORMWATER PERMIT COMPLIANCE
FUND.
WITHIN THE STATE TREASURY.
THIS BILL ALSO INCREASES THE
CALIFORNIA TIRE FEE BY A DOLLAR.
FIFTY TO RAISE REVENUE TO FUND
PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS FOR
MUNICIPAL.
SEPARATE STORM SEWER SYSTEM
PERMIT COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS.
AFTER JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOR THE TIRE FEE WILL
DROP FROM.
THREE TWENTY FIVE PER TIRE.
TO TWO TWENTY FIVE THE
COMPETITIVE GRANTS OFFERED BY
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD.
WOULD GO TOWARD LIMITING SINK
POLLUTANTS IN WATER.
WHICH ARE YOU BECAUSE BY TIRE
WEAR AND OTHER SOURCES.
I PLAN ON CONTINUING TO WORK ON
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS WITH THE
BOARD CALL RECYCLING THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX.
AND FEE THAT CURRENTLY
ADMINISTERS THE TIRE FEE FOR
CALL RECYCLE AND A. R. B..
STORM WATER RUNOFF AND POLLUTION
ARE COMMON CAUSES TO THE HIGH
COST OF WATER INFRASTRUCTURE.
A SOPHISTICATED SYSTEMS ARE
REQUIRED TO TEST FOR AND TREAT
POLLUTANTS.
I RECOGNIZE THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION AND WEIGH THEM WITH
THE REALITIES CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE CONFRONTED WITH A
LOOK FORWARD TO EXPLORING WAYS.
WE CAN MAKE THIS APPROACH VIABLE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
IN ORDER TO COMPLY WITH THE M.
S. FOR PERMITS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE TO INVEST BILLIONS IN
WATERSHED INFRASTRUCTURE AND
STORM WATER CAPTURE TECHNOLOGY.
TO MAINTAIN A HEALTHY QUALITY OF
WATER BILLIONS THEY SIMPLY DO
NOT HAVE.
THIS BILL IS CONSISTENT WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE TO ADDRESS
STORMWATER FUNDING FOR LA COUNTY.
BUT MAKES GRANTS AVAILABLE TO
MUNICIPALITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
FOR THESE REASONS I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AND WITH ME -- TO
TESTIFY AS A WITNESS IS PAUL
HOOPER DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AND COMMUNITY RELATIONS SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS.
THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER HOLDEN --
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PAUL HUGH
BLUR.
I'M HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE
THIRTY CITIES OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS AS
THIS SPONSOR OF AB.
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE AS ASSEMBLYMAN
HOLDEN STATED AB SEVEN FIFTY
FIVE WOULD INCREASE THE
CALIFORNIA TIRE FEE BY A MODEST
DOLLAR FIFTY PER TIRE TO HELP
CITIES FUND CLEANUP PROJECTS TO
REDUCE AND ELIMINATE ZINC.
FOUND IN STORM WATER RUNOFF TIRE
WEAR HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED VICE
SURVEYS AS A MAJOR SOURCE OF
ZINC AND URBAN RUNOFF.
THIS LEGISLATION IS MODELED ON
THE SEVENTY FIVE CENTS PER TIRE
FEE FOR THE CALIFORNIA AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL FUND.
MADE AVAILABLE TO THE STATE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD AND LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS. TO FUND PROGRAMS AND
PROJECTS THAT MITIGATE TO
REMEDIATE AIR POLLUTION CAUSED
BY TIRES IN THE STATE.
ZINC IS AMONG SEVERAL DOZEN
HEAVY METALS AND OTHER
CONTAMINANTS.
THAT ARE CONSIDERED HIGH LEVEL
WATER QUALITY THREATS FOR
IMPAIRED WATER BONTA BODIES IN
THE LOS ANGELES REGION AND
THROUGHOUT LARGE AREAS IN
CALIFORNIA.
ELEVATED ZINC CONCENTRATIONS IN
URBAN RUNOFF MUST BE ADDRESSED
TO CHIEF CLEAN WATER.
ACT COMPLIANCE IN MANY
CALIFORNIA URBAN AREAS.
THE REMOVAL OF CONTAMINANTS
INCLUDING SING FROM STORM WATERS
AN URGENT ISSUE FOR A NUMBER OF
CITIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AS ASSEMBLY MEN HOLDEN AND
STATED.
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY FOR THE
EIGHTY EIGHT CITIES IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THE ESTIMATE IS
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS BY TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
TO REMOVE A SINK AND OTHER
CONTAMINANTS FORCE CLEAN WATER
ACT COMPLIANCE. SIX BILLION
DOLLARS ALONE FOR THE THIRTY ONE
CITIES IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AS NOTED BY SOME WOMEN HOLDEN AB
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE COMPLEMENTS THE
MEASURE W. A INITIATIVE THAT WAS
RECENTLY APPROVED BY THE VOTERS
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY. TO TAKE
ON THE ISSUE OF STORM WATER
CONTENT CAPTURE AND CONTAMINANT
REMOVAL.
AB SEVEN FIFTY FIVE IS PART OF
THE TOOL BOX OF OPTIONS NEEDED
FOR STORM WATER COMPLIANCE.
AND IS PREMISED ON THE SOUND
PUBLIC POLICY THAT OUR PRODUCT
IF DEMONSTRATED TO BE A MAJOR
SOURCE OF A CONTROLLED
CONTAMINANT WHEN USED AS
INTENDED.
SHOULD INCORPORATE IN ITS COST
STRUCTURE.
A FEED TO HELP OFFSET THE COST
OF MITIGATING THE CONTAMINANT
YOUR TIME IS THE TIME IS UP --
CASH WITHOUT AYE -- CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS AND AS FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANOTHER WITNESS.
OKAY ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THIS MEASURE.
LARA COMES HERE CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SELECT US ON BEHALF OF OF STOP
WASTE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE JEFF SIEVERS ON HALF
THE U. S. TIRE MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION.
THE ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS THE
AT TWELVE MANY FACTORS BASS THE
UNITED STATES TO MAKE TIRES.
I WAS UP INSURANCE THIS BILL AND
REMAIN OPPOSED TO IT FOR SEVERAL
REASONS -- FIRST -- BASICALLY IT
SEEKS TO NEARLY DOUBLE THE TIRE
TAX.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ALTHOUGH HE STATED BY THE
SUPPORTERS -- THERE MANY METALS
THE FALL IN THE WATER YET WE'RE
IDENTIFYING ZINC AS ONE THE
AUTHORS ALSO STATED THAT IS
CAUSED BY TIRES.
IN BY MOST OF THE STUDIES THAT
HAVE BEEN DONE THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD TIRES ARE ACTUALLY BUT ONE
ELEMENT THAT MAY BE CONTRIBUTING
TO IT.
THE BIGGEST SOURCE OF ZINC SEEMS
TO BE GALVANIZED METAL BUT IT'S
ALSO A NATURALLY.
OCCURRING SUBSTANCE IN THE
ENVIRONMENT AS WELL AS USED IN --
INDUSTRIAL USE.
SECONDLY -- YEAH THE COST -- AND
GOT TO MENTION THIS TO BE IN
EXCESS OF TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS
TO ADDRESS IT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
RAISING THE TIRE FEE DOLLAR --
FIFTY FOR THE ROUGHLY THIRTY
MILLION TIRES ARE SOLD ANNUALLY
IS A BUT A DROP IN THE BUCKET IS
NOT GOING TO GET THERE TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE -- THIRDLY
I'D SAY.
TIRES ARE NOT NECESSARILY THE
SOURCE THE PROBLEM IN FACT MAY
BE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
AND CURRENTLY CAL RECYCLES
ACTUALLY STUDYING THIS LOOKING
AT LEACHING FROM -- GROUND TIRE
RUBBER SEE IF IT ACTUALLY IS AN
ISSUE -- THEY'RE CURRENTLY DOING
THE STUDY THIS YEAR THEY SHOULD
BE ALLOWED TO FINISH ALSO
THEY'VE ACTUALLY FUNDED STUDIES
IN ACTUALLY IDENTIFIED GROUND
TIRES AS A WAY TO REDUCE HEAVY
METALS FROM GOING INTO THE STORM
RUNOFF.
THEY ANISHA RESULTS ON THAT ARE
VERY VERY POSITIVE SAID THIS MAY
ACTUALLY PART OF THE SOLUTION
NOT NECESSARILY THE PROBLEM.
AND FINALLY I'D LIKE TO SAY -- I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
THIS IS PRIMARILY A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ISSUE YET THE
SOLUTION IS TO TAX EVERYBODY IN
THE STATE -- IF THIS WAS AN
ISSUE FOR THIS FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE -- THEN WHY ARE SELECT THE
SAN FRANCISCO IN THE BAY AREA
AND SOME THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES NOT REPORTING ANY
ZINC RUN OFF AS PART OF THE
WATER WASTE.
YET SOARED INTO TAX THE ENTIRE
STATE FOR THIS PRODUCT AND THEN
THE LANGUAGE SPECIFICALLY IN
SECTION THREE SAYS IS
ESSENTIALLY MONEY CAN ONLY BE
USED BY -- BY LOCALITIES THAT
ARE EXCEEDING THEIR THEIR LIMITS
WHICH HAPPENED ALL BE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SELL -- FOR THOSE REASONS AND
SEVERAL OTHERS WOULD LIKE TO
KEEP SEEKING ALTERNATIVES AND
LOOK FOR WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
[inaudible]
HI.
JACK MORE DONOVAN BEHALF OF THE
AUTOMOTIVE SERVICE COUNCILS IN
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA AUTOMOTIVE
BUSINESS COALITION AND
CALIFORNIA TIRE DEALERS
ASSOCIATION.
THE DOLLAR FIFTY TAX IS IS AN
OAK A REGRESSIVE TAX IT FALLS
HARDEST ON LOW INCOME AND HARD
WORKING FAMILIES -- TIRE DEALERS
HAVE COUNTLESS STORIES WERE
POTENTIAL CUSTOMERS DELAY THE
PURCHASE OF TIRES UP BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD HIM AND THEY
SIMPLY DRIVE AWAY AND DANGEROUS
BALD TIRES -- IT THE TIRES ARE
EXPENSIVE YOU HAVE A SALES TAX
ON TOP OF THE TIRES YOU HAVE A
DISPOSAL FEE YOU HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL -- TIRE FEE -- WHICH
IS CURRENTLY A DOLLAR SEVENTY
FIVE AND THIS IS JUST GOING TO
THIS DOLLAR FIFTIES ON TOP OF
ALL THOSE FEES.
WE RECOGNIZE THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
THREATS CAUSED BY THE POLLUTANTS
THAT ENTER THE STORM WATER.
RUNOFF BUT WHY ARE WE PICKING ON
TIRES OF ZINC IS IN MANY
CONSUMER PRODUCTS OUTDOOR METAL
SERVICES FOR EXAMPLE GALVANIZED
STEEL -- IS COATED WITH A LIQUID
ZINC AND YOU HAVE -- LIGHTING
AND STREET LIGHTS AND SIGNS AND
BENCHES AT ALL CONTRIBUTE TO THE
STORM WATER IT -- PROBLEM SO WE
BELIEVE ANY NEW FEES OR TAXES
SHOULD BE SHARED FAIRLY AMONG
ALL THE PRODUCTS THAT BECAUSE
POLLUTANTS.
TO ENTER THE STORM OF WATER --
RUNOFF NOT JUST TIRES.
SO WITH THAT -- WE RISK WESTERLY
RI IT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
HIS NAME ORGANIZATION YOUR
POSITION PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON
SERRA -- ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION.
SEAN WAS THE NATIONAL FEDERATION
OF IN A BUSINESS ALSO OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW WE'LL TURN TO THE
COMMITTEE IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible] SEVEN SEGMENT.
BUT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD MR HOLD IN THIS A I HAVE
I ALSO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
THE THE JUMP IN IN THE IN THE
FEE.
BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND AS
SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENTS AN AG
AREA ABOUT THE PROBLEM WITH DUMB
TIRES ALL OVER THE PLACE TO SOME
IS GONNA PAY FOR THAT -- AND SO
I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY AND WITH THAT WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE IT UP WE WATCHING AS IT
GOES FORWARD AND AND SEE WHAT
THE END PRODUCT LOOKS LIKE I
UNDERSTAND.
LIKE MANY THINGS IT'S A WORK IN
PROGRESS.
I THANK YOU MISTERHOLDEN I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS.
FOR AWHILE -- AND THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF DISCUSSION BACK HOME OF
THE COST TO CLEAN UP --
CONTAMINANTS -- LOTS OF
CONTAMINANTS SUCH AS THIS ITEM.
I HAVE A A QUESTION THOUGH ABOUT
THE THE FIND ARE ALL THE FEES
JUST COMING FROM THE CONSUMER
ARE THERE ANY OTHER FUNDS IN
THERE THAT ARE COMING FROM.
MANUFACTURERS ARE I MEAN HOW ARE
WE SHARING THESE COST AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY.
YEAH THE FEES AS THE FEARS
ATTACHED TO THE THE COST OF OF
THE TO THE TIRE AND IT'S ONE OF
A NUMBER WAYS TO TRY TO GENERATE
SOME REVENUE AS WAS POINTED OUT
IS IT GOING TO BE ENOUGH NO BUT
IT'S ONE TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX TO
TRY TO GET.
US THERE -- THE THE COSTS ARE --
ARE IT AS A FEE -- TO COMPLIMENT --
THE THE WATER.
THE WATER BOND PROP ONE DOLLARS
OF THEIR A LOT OF FUNDS THAT ARE
OUT THERE THEY'RE OVER
SUBSCRIBED AND SO TO TRY TO
IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS FEE AS ONE
THAT WOULD APPLY TO AND I
BELIEVE WITH NEW TIRES I TURNED
A SURE WHO WERE. TO TO FURTHER
DESCRIBE BUT IT'S A WAY TO JUST
GENERATED BASED ON FOR THE
RETAILER.
YEAH IT IS IT'S A FEE PAID BY
THE CONSUMER -- AS SAME AS THE
EXISTING TIRE FEES ARE -- I CAN
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN THAT THE
MANUFACTURER HAVE.
ABOUT THE IMPACT ON THE THE
CONSUMER DEMAND FOR THEIR
PRODUCT BUT WE THINK IT'S REALLY
A DE MINIMUS FEET.
A DOLLAR FIFTY PER TIRE -- AND
TYPICALLY FOLKS REPLACE THEIR
TIRES ONCE EVERY FOUR YEARS SO
IT'S ON AN ANNUALIZED COST ABOUT
A DOLLAR.
FIFTY PER PER YEAR -- IT IS DOES
GO TO THE DOES GO TO THE
CONSUMER.
THERE'S BEEN -- QUESTION AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S A WAY TO
DIRECT THIS TO THE MANUFACTURER --
FRANKLY I WISH THERE WERE
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ZINC
THAT ENDS UP ON THE PUBLIC
ROADWAYS AND IS WASHED INTO THE
STORM WATER SYSTEM -- BUT RIGHT
NOW THAT'S THAT'S THE MODEL IS
THAT THIS IS A FEE THAT GOES ON
ON TO THE TIREDNESS PAID BY THE
CONSUMER.
AND TO BE CLEAR I'M NOT OPPOSED
TO A FEE ON THE CAUSE ON THE
CONSUMER.
I JUST FEEL THAT IT SHOULD BE
SHARED WITH THE MANY FACTORS AS
WELL AND NOT JUST ON THE
CONSUMERS.
I AGREE WHEN WE THINK ABOUT HOW
OFTEN WE PLACER TIRES.
CONSUMERS GIVING ME. FOURTEEN
DOLLARS EVERY THREE TO FIVE
YEARS -- NOT NOT TOO BAD I'LL
BUT I DO THINK IN OFFERING AS WE
NEED TO BE THINKINGOF THE
POLITICAL WILL SO IT'S ALSO.
BE SHARED WITH THE MANUFACTURE
ALONG THE WAY.
I AND SO IT'S NOT.
AN OPPOSITION BUT I THINK AS
WERE THINKING OF HIGHLIGHTED
CREATING FUNDS AND GROWING APART
THAT'S BIG ENOUGH -- OR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES I THINK WE
NEED TO BE HAVING THAT
DISCUSSION AS WELL.
AND I'LL SECOND THE MOTION.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE
COMMITTEES -- AYE VOTE -- IT IS.
FOR CITIES THAT I REPRESENT --
VENDETTA REPRESENTED IN THE
SECULAR VALLEY IN OTHER PARTS.
THEY'RE SMALL CITIES AND THEY
HAVE NOW BEEN SADDLED WITH AN MS
FOUR PERMIT COSTS OF BUILDING.
FACILITIES INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
ESSENTIALLY COULD BANKRUPT THESE
COMMUNITIES AND WE THINK THIS IS
JUST A ONE SMALL ADDITIONAL
EFFORT ALONG WITH THE PASSAGE OF
MEASURE W. LAST FALL.
THEY CAN HELP GET US THERE TO AT
LEAST ADDRESS ISSUES THATWE ARE
NOW MANDATED -- TO RESPOND TO SO
HI WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
I THINK IT WOULD NOT MAKE A ROLL
CALL.
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB SEVEN FIFTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA FOR SEA ISLE
Là MON [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ WROTE SURGERY.
WELL TO GI STONE. FIVE ONE THANK
YOU WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF IN
OKAY RICHARD THANK THANK YOU I
DON'T SEE MR MAYS SO MISTER
GARCIA.
AND WILL YOU DO A THREE FIFTY
TWO FIRST. THREE FIFTY TWO YES
OKAY IF IF YOU'RE PREPARED OR WE
CAN SWITCH NO NO NO THAT'S FINE
WHATEVER EIGHTY SIX IS FINE OVER
HERE SO EIGHTY SIX IS FINALLY
GOT THREE FIFTY TO APPEAR
ALREADY SO OKAY WHICHEVER
BILLION.
ONE I HEARD A MOTION ON HER
SECOND.
I WILL -- KEEP IT BRIEF FOR THIS
IS NOT ABOUT MORE.
TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX OR THE LOAF
OF BREAD THIS IS ABOUT EQUITY
WHEN IT COMES HEARD.
JERRY OF FUNDS -- WE'RE LOOKING.
AT MAKING SURE THEY WERE
INCLUDING DAYTIME POPULATIONS
ALONG THE BORDER REGIONS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ALASKA THIS BILL CAME BEFORE THE
SAME COMMITTEE THERE WAS A LOT
OF QUESTION ABOUT.
HOW THIS COULD PERHAPS IMPACT --
AND MAKE IT -- NOT EQUITABLE FOR
OTHER PARTS OF CALIFORNIA IF
POSITIONING THE BORDER REGIONS
TO COMPETE.
BETTER FOR THESE FUNDS THE
MESSAGE WAS.
THAT -- THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
LIVING ON THE BORDER AND COUNTY
THAT THEY TIME POPULATIONS -- IS
THAT.
MEXICO CALIFORNIA REGIONS IN PRO
COUNTY CYNICAL COUNTY CANNOT
PARTNER -- TO ACCESS THESE
DOLLARS WHEREAS OTHER COUNTIES
WITHIN THE STATE.
OTHER INNER AGENCIES CAN DO SO --
WE HAVE A GRAPH THAT WOULD LOVE
TO SHARE IF NEED BE ON HOW THESE
FUNDS HAVE BEEN DISTRIBUTED OVER
THE COURSE OF TIME.
AND IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT THE
BORDER REGIONS HAVE NOT RECEIVED
ITS FAIR SHARE OUR JOB.
AS LEGISLATORS IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE BRING BACK YOU KNOW --
EQUAL SHARE OF FAIR SHARE TOWARD
DISTRICTS AND AGAIN -- I CAN HI
LIKE THAT WITH THE GRAPH OF IF
NEEDED RESPECTFULLY ASK FREE I
WOULD ON THIS BILL.
A COUPLE WITNESSES THAT WILL
SPEAK TO THE MATTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR FRIEDMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
MATT DESERT AND I IN THE AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICER FOR
COUNTY.
ON BEHALF OF IMPERIAL COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THEY PEARL
COUNTY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT I'M HERE TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT.
OF AB.
THREE FIFTY TWO THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT FUNDING FOR THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
REACHES COMMUNITIES LIKE
IMPERIAL COUNTY SUFFERING FROM
CUBA THE POPULATION BURDEN
PURSUANT. TO THE COMMUNITY --
PROTECTION PROGRAM A. B. -- SIX
SEVENTEEN COUNTY INCLUDE SEVERAL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND IS
ONE OF THE POOREST IN THE STATE
SUFFERING FROM THE HIGHEST
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE.
UNHEALTHY AIR POLLUTION AND MORE
THAN DOUBLE THE STATE'S RATE OF
ASTHMA RELATED EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS AND HOSPITALIZATION OF
CHILDREN.
AS A MATTER OF FACT MOST OF THE
COUNTY HAS A CALLIN VIRUS GREEN
PERCENTILE OF 70% OR HIGHER.
HOWEVER WE HAVE RECEIVED VERY
LITTLE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUNDING OVER THE YEARS BECAUSE
THE METHODOLOGY USES THE
APPROPRIATE.
FUNDING THAT NET VALUE WITH THE
GRANT APPLICATIONS FAVORS
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE DENSELY
POPULATED.
A UNIQUE FEATURE OF APPEAL
COUNTY THAT ALSO POSES A
CHALLENGE FOR US IN A DRESS AND
OUR AIR QUALITY IS OUR LOCATION
AS WE ARE ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
INTERNATIONAL GATEWAYS TO MEXICO.
OUR RURAL SPARSELY POPULATED
COMMITTEE SHARES A BORDER AN AIR
BASE AND WITH THE DENSELY
POPULATED CAPITAL BAJA
CALIFORNIA THE CITY OF MEXICALI.
COPULATION IS AT LEAST SEVEN
TIMES THAT OF THE ENTIRE
POPULATION OF IMPERIAL COUNTY.
OUR NEIGHBORS CROSS THE BORDER
ON A DAILY BASIS FOR VARIOUS
REASONS AND WE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY ARE FACED WITH THE
CHALLENGE OF SERVING IN
SUPPORTING SUCH A LARGE INFLUX
AND POPULATION ON A DAILY BASIS.
AB THREE FIFTY TWO CORRECT SAID
IN EQUITY AND SIX TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO PROGRAMS FUNDED BY.
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND BY EXPANDING THE LIST OF CO
BENEFITS AND ALLOWS THE COUNTIES
OF IMPERIAL SAN DIEGO TO INCLUDE
OUR DAYTIME POPULATION NUMBERS.
AND THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND GRANT APPLICATIONS.
THE BILL COUNTY NEEDS YOUR HELP
TO MAKE ASSESSING THESE FUNDS
MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN BIBLE.
IN ADDITION TO THEIR DISTRICT IN
THE COUNTY SUPPORT I'VE BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH OUR LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUP
COMMITTEE CIVIC OF THEIR BY WITH
LISA METAL.
WHO HAD THE PLEASURE OF OF?
BEING IN FRONT OF YOUR COMMITTEE
LAST WEEK.
HE'S ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND THIS BILL AND
I ASK YOU FOR YOUR AYE VOTE OR
YOUR AFFIRMATIVE OF I WILL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ERICA FELL CHAIN ON THE
GOVERNMENTAL PROJECTS MANAGER
FOR THE COULD TELL THAT LEASES
HAITIAN OF GOVERNMENTS.
SEE BAG OF THE GOVERNMENTS
REPRESENTING TEN CITIES TWO
TRIBES IN THE COUNTY RIVERSIDE
WE RECEIVED ONE OF ONLY TEN
PLANNING GRANTS AWARDED IN THE
FIRST ROUND OF THE
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
AND WE WERE RECENTLY NOTIFIED
THAT WE WILL BE ONE OF ONLY FIVE
PLANNING GRANTS FUNDED IN THE
SECOND ROUND AND TODAY WE'RE
HERE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SEE BACK IN OUR MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN COMMITTED TO HELPING
CALIFORNIA CHIEF IT'S GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION GOALS BUT WE HAVE
FOUND IT DIFFICULT TO EVEN
COMPETE FOR SOME OF THE FUNDING
PROGRAMS.
WE SUPPORT THREE FIFTY TWO
BECAUSE IT MAKES SEVERAL
NECESSARY CHANGES TO PROGRAMS
LIKE TCC.
AB THREE FIFTY TWO BRANDS A LIST
OF CO BENEFITS AS DEFINED BY THE
STATE AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND IT
HELPS ADDRESS SOME OF THE
DENSITY CHALLENGES THAT REGION'S
LIKE OURS FACE WHEN WE TRY TO
APPLY FOR CAP AND TRADE FUNDING.
THE COACHELLA VALLEY IS OFTEN
SEEN AS AN AREA OF GREAT WEALTH
BUT IN REALITY IT'S A SOCIO
ECONOMIC DIVERSE REGION WITH
AREAS OF EXTREME POVERTY
PARTICULARLY IN THE EASTERN ON
CORPORATE COMMUNITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS DIVERSITY IS
NOT FULLY REFLECTED IN CALABAR
SCREEN IN THE ENTIRE C. BACK
REGION INCLUDING BOTH THE
COACHELLA VALLEY VERDE VALLEY.
THERE ARE ONLY EIGHT CENSUS
TRACTS THAT RANK IN TOWN BY YOUR
SCREEN'S TOP 25% THAT DEFINES
ITS DISADVANTAGE.
NOT A SINGLE CENSUS TRACK IN THE
ENTIRE C. BACK REGION RANKS IN
THE TOP 5%.
OTHER MAPS INCLUDING AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY ARE MUCH BETTER REFLECTION
OF OUR SOCIO ECONOMIC DIVERSITY.
AS IT STANDS NOW CALIBER SCREEN
HAS A DIRECT IMPACT ON WHETHER
OUR COMMUTES CAN EVEN APPLY FOR
FUNDING.
IF THEY CAN'T APPLY IT ALSO
IMPACTS THEIR SCORE CONSIDER THE
TCC PROGRAM.
SEE BAG WILL BE A PARTNER ON TWO
OF THE FIFTEEN GRANTS THAT ARE
WERE WORDED FOR THE PLANNING
FUNDS.
AND WE'RE INVESTING TIME IN
FUNDING INTO PREPARING FOR
FUTURE ROUNDS OF IMPLEMENTATION
GRANTS AND OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
AND YET AS THE RULES ARE WRITTEN
NOW NOT A SINGLE SENTENCE TRACK
IN EITHER OF THOSE PLANNING
CURRENT AREAS.
COULD EVENQUALIFIED TO APPLY
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING
WE APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND HOPE YOU WILL JOIN US IN
SUPPORTING THE SPELL.
THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
JAPANESE DEFAULT ON THE AT THE
SAME PER DIEM COUNTY FOR
SUPERVISORS ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
MARK ORDERS ARE NOT ACCEPTED
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF LUCK BUT
IF YOU HAVE COME TO SEE THAT IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION WANT TO
SPEAK.
OKAY WITHOUT WILL GO TO THE
COMMITTEE.
GARCIA -- THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR BEING IN
THIS FOR IT I'VE.
VISITED THE CALEXICO MAKE IT
BORDER AND GOT TO BE REMINDED OF
THEIR QUALITIES AS IF YOU'RE A
QUALITY ISSUES THERE BUT IT IS.
A CONTEST AND WE HAVE TEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE ON ONE SIDE OF
THE BORDER AND A MILLION PEOPLE
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE BORDER
AND ON THE DIFFICULT IS THAT
THAT CREATES A THIRD DIFFERENT
TOOLS OUT THERE TO TRY TO
ADDRESS ISSUES -- I WOULDN'T BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T THINK ABOUT
THE FACT THAT IN GENERAL WE HAVE
AND THEN A VERY GOOD JOB OF
GETTING DOLLARS INTO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES OTHER
THERE'S THERE'S ADVANTAGE.
I DENSELY OR NOT MY DISTRICT IS
ONE OF THE MOST DISADVANTAGED.
AND WE HAVE BROUGHT IN SOME OF
THE LEAST DOLLARS.
OUT THERE.
THE SPEAKERS DISTRICT ALSO AND
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT THAT AND SO I
JUST THINK IN GENERAL WE HAVE TO
BE THINKING.
HOW DO WE DO THINGS BETTER AND
THE TOOLS WE HAVE ARE NOT ENOUGH
AND SICK OF BEING EITHER TOLL TO
THE TOLL QUE?
MY MY STAFF ASKED THE QUESTION
YOU KNOW OF MAYBE IF WE START
COUNTY IN OUR DAYTIME POPULATION
WITH ALL THE TRUCKS COMING IN
AND OUT OF OUR DISTRICT.
WE MIGHT BE BETTER OFF AND
BETTER BETTER SUITED TO COMPETE
FOR SOMEBODY'S DOLLARS ON LASSEN
FOR ANY OF THOSE AMENDMENTS
TODAY.
BUT DID FIND SOME IDEAS OUT
THERE HOW WE START THINKING
OUTSIDE THE BOX TO MAKE SURE
THESE DOLLARS ARE COMING TO
COMMUNITIES LIKE YOURS LIKE MINE
AND ALL THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
THAT THAT EACH HAVE THEIR OWN
UNIQUE -- ISSUES THAT WE NEED
OVERCOME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I WOULD JUST SAID NO THAT
WASN'T A QUESTION BUT THE COMMON
IS VERY WELL TAKEN BECAUSE I
THINK THAT IS.
THE INTENT OF THIS.
EFFORT HERE IS TO CONCENTRATE
OUR INVESTMENTS WERE WOLVES WILL
OR WE WILL SEE THE MULTIPLE
BENEFITS COMING FROM THAT RIGHT
AND SO WHY CERTAINLY OPEN.
TO THE SUGGESTION IN THE
DIALOGUE -- THAT THAT WE BEGIN.
WITH THAT IDEA BUT ULTIMATELY IT
REALLY IS WORKING WE GET A
BIGGER BANG FOR OUR BUCK REDUCE
THE EMISSIONS AND CREATE OTHER
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES FOR THESE
REGIONS OF THE STATE.
AS WAS MENTIONED BY OUR AIR
POLLUTION DISTRICT DIRECTOR --
THIS IS THE REGION THAT HAS THE
HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN
STATE CALIFORNIA.
ON A GOOD DAY AT 16% ON A BAD
DAY IT'S AT 28% SO WE CAN MAKE A
TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE BUT JUST
IN THE REDUCTION OF EMISSIONS
BUT ALSO AND STIRRING UP SOME.
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL
AS INVESTMENTS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE ON THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
OKAY ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM ELEVEN AB THREE FIFTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LIMóN [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MELINDA'S.
AND DOES NOT VOTING.
MURATSUCHI.
RIGHT TO GI STONE.
STONE I SIX ZERO THANK YOU THANK
YOU WAS OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN -- YOUR NEXT BILL PLEASE
CHECK AB THREE EIGHTY SIX THAT
WILL CODIFY AN EXISTING PROGRAM
THAT HAS BEEN RECENT PRAYER TIES
UNDER THE LOW.
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM --
THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY FOCUSES
ON FARMWORKERS WHO OWN THEIR
HOMES -- RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THE SECOND [inaudible]
GOOD.
HI MY NAME IS SOUGHT MEDICAL
SETTING AGAIN AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CODE OF YOUR
COMPANY.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
ARTICLE BUT THE LISTA STATEWIDE
OR ASSOCIATION OF FEDERALLY
DESIGNATED AGENCIES IMPLEMENTING
AND ADMINISTERING FARMWORKERS
SERVICE PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA.
MICHAEL BUT IF HE WAS MEMBER
AGENCIES CURRENTLY OPERATE
EIGHTY TWO SERVICE CENTERS.
THROUGHOUT THIRTY FOUR
SIGNIFICANT AGRICULTURAL
COUNTIES OFFERING COMPREHENSIVE
SERVICE PACKAGES TO RURAL
AGRICULTURAL REGIONS WE SERVE
OVER ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
AND OVER FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND ARE
FARMWORKERS OUR MEMBER AGENCIES
PROVIDE EDUCATION WORKFORCE
TRAINING JOB PLACEMENT HOUSING
ENERGY SERVICES AND SELF
SUFFICIENT SERVICES TO MIGRANT
AND SEASONAL FARM WORKER.
AND OTHER RURAL AND SEMI RURAL
WORKING POOR.
THE LEGISLATION THAT WILL HELP
TO SERVE FARMWORKERS WHO ARE
LOCATED WITHIN AGRICULTURAL AND
RURAL COMMUNITIES OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
CENTRAL COAST NORTHERN
SACRAMENTO AND THE DESERT.
THERE ARE ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND FARM WORKERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FINDING FROM
THE NATIONAL AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SHOWED
THAT 28% OF FARMWORKERS SAID
THEY LIVED IN THE HOME.
OWNED BY THEMSELVES OR A FAMILY
MEMBER.
IT'S ME.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT HAS RECEIVED CAP AND
TRADE FUNDS. TO SERVE THE POOR
THROUGH THEIR NETWORK OF PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC COMMUNITY NON PROFITS.
HOWEVER.
THE DEPARTMENT'S NETWORK HAS
EXPERIENCED CHALLENGES REACHING
FARMWORKERS.
THIS CHALLENGE HAS NOT BEEN
OVERCOME AFTER MANY DECADES.
THIS LEGISLATION WILL ENSURE
FARMWORKERS HOMES WILL RECEIVE.
EXTENSIVE WEATHERIZATION.
SOLAR PANELS.
AND MORE IMPORTANT BATTERY
BACKUPS.
EXCUSE ME.
AND I'M NOT SAYING.
IN OTHER EFFICIENCY MEASURES
NEEDED TO REDUCE THEIR
ELECTRICAL CONSUMPTION TO
VIRTUALLY ZERO AND THUS GREATLY
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
BY THIS HOUSEHOLDS AND
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE.
THEIR DISPOSABLE INCOME.
ALLOCATING COVENTRY FIVE FOR
FARMWORKERS IS ESSENTIAL AS
FARMWORKERS ARE THE BACKBONE OF
A FIFTY MILLION BILLION PLUS
THEIR CULTURAL.
INDUSTRY THAT FEEDS CALIFORNIA.
AMERICA IN THE ENTIRE WORLD.
AGAIN THIS PROGRAM WILL
SUBSTANTIALLY RAISE THEIR
DISPOSABLE INCOME.
UNDER CONTRACT THAT WE HAD YOUR
TIME IS UP SO IF YOU CAN.
OKAY GIVE TO TESTIMONIALS.
ALL ONE PERSON WE SERVED.
SAID MY ELECTRIC BILL WENT FROM
EIGHTY DOLLARS TO FIVE DOLLARS
ANOTHER ONE SAID IT WENT FOR
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS. TO TWENTY
DOLLARS AND THAT IS WHAT IT'S
ALL ABOUT SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND FIVE
BUILT.
THROUGH THICK THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ARE ANIMAL
REPRESENTING THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
DOESN'T JUST.
A CREE ENERGY EFFICIENCY BUT IT
ALSO IMPROVES QUALITY OF LIFE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
THE BRANCH -- BUT THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AGRICULTURE NETWORK IN
SUPPORT.
MY SILVA I REPRESENT PRODUCE
INCORPORATED N. I SUPPORT THE A.
B.. THREE EIGHTY SIX BILL.
FERNANDO GONZALEZ REPRESENTED
CENTRAL VALLEY OPPORTUNITY
CENTER AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
BILL. ONE COMMA ZERO CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
READ ADDISON BEHALF THE CENTRAL
COAST ENERGY SERVICES THERE ARE
NUMBER OF PROBLEMS AT THE
PROGRAM AND APPRECIATE THESE
EFFORTS TO TRY TO FIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYBODY WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO COME
TO A CLOSE RESPECT AS FOR I WILL
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND WAY
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB THREE EIGHTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I FLORA.
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LIMóN [inaudible]
THIS.
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MELINDA'S.
LINDA'S AYE MURATSUCHI RIGHT TO
G. AYE STONE [inaudible]
STONE I THANK YOU YOUR BILL IF
OF SEVEN ZERO THANK YOUR BILL
ITSELF MR MAYES.
WELCOME.
A GOOD AFTERNOON JERRY MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE EIGHTY THREE
TO ESTABLISH A CLEAN ENERGY.
FINANCING CLEARING HOUSE WITHIN
THE OFFICE OF THE TREASURE.
THIS OFFICE WOULD ACT AS A
COORDINATOR OF THE TREMENDOUS
PUBLIC INVESTMENT THE CALIFORNIA
MAKES ANNUALLY THROUGH VARIOUS
STATE AGENCIES AND PROGRAMS.
A SIMILAR BILL IS RUN LAST YEAR
BY SENATOR STERN WHO REQUESTED A
REPORT FROM THE SENATE OFFICE OF
RESEARCH.
THE DOUBLE OF THE COMPLEXITIES
OF OUR CLEAN ENERGY PROGRAMS
THIS RESEARCH FOUND OVER FORTY
DIFFERENT.
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
ADMINISTERED BY OVER FIFTEEN
DIFFERENT OFFICES.
ALL WITH THE GOAL OF DISCOVERING
NEW PATHWAYS FOR CLEAN ENERGY.
DESPITE BILLIONS IN PUBLIC
DOLLARS THAT WE SPEND ANNUALLY.
WE MUST MAKE SURE WE SPEND THOSE
DOLLARS EFFICIENTLY AND ASSIST
OUR PRIVATE CAPITAL PARTNERS TO
BECOME MOBILIZE.
IN ORDER TO MEET OUR GOALS FOR
EXAMPLE.
OF THE CQC RELEASED A STUDY
DETERMINING THAT WILL TAKE
APPROXIMATELY FOUR BILLION.
ANNUALLY TO MEETS THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY TARGETS IDEALLY NEW
TECHNOLOGY SPURRED THIS SPREAD
BY THIS LEGISLATION.
COMBINED WITH MARKET COMPETITION
WILL HAVE TO DRIVE DOWN COSTS SB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT STRUGGLE
TO PROGRESS LAST YEAR DUE TO THE
QUESTION OVER WHICH AGENCY WOOD
MISTER THIS TASK.
THIS YEAR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE IS INTERESTED
BUT THE NOTE -- IS NOT YET
OFFICIALLY IN SUPPORT.
AND HAS BEEN ENGAGE WITH UP WITH
MY STAFF ABOUT HOW TO CREATE AN
OFFICE THAT WE PRODUCTIVE
TOWARDS OUR MISSION TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
MAKE CALIFORNIA BETTER PLACE TO
LIVE.
I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT I WILL
BE ACCEPTING -- THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- THAT ARE LISTED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND THEN
THERE'S SOME DISCUSSION WILL GET
INTO HERE IN IN A LITTLE BIT.
ABOUT I WANT TO CONTINUE KEEP
WORKING WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS I
DO HAVE WITH ME TODAY TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT -- DEMOCRATS.
THANKS MY NAME'S TIM MCCRAE I'M
WITH THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP IS THE
LEAD CO SPONSOR FOR THE BILL
WE'RE HAPPY THAT THIS BILL HAS.
ATTRACTED BY PARTISAN INTEREST
AND BIPARTISAN AUTHORSHIP FROM
ASSEMBLYMAN BASES SOMEONE
FRIEDMAN.
LEADERSHIP GROUP HAS BEEN A
LEADING BUSINESS VOICE TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA SETTING
AMBITIOUS CLEAN ENERGY AND
GREENHOUSE GAS SCHOOLS. TO THANK
YOU. TO MEET THOSE AMBITIOUS
GOALS AS WELL AS CONTINUE
ECONOMIC GROWTH CALIFORNIA'S
STILL NEEDS SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS
OF FINANCING.
THE FIRST STEP IS TO GET THE
MYRIAD OF PROGRAMS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS ON THE SAME PAGE
THE SENATE OFFICE OF RESEARCH
HAS IDENTIFIED FORTY OF THEM.
AND THEY LIVE SPRINKLED
THROUGHOUT STATE GOVERNMENT WITH
THEIR SIDE LOAD.
THAT COORDINATION CAN BETTER SET
UP CALIFORNIA FOR THE CRUCIAL
SECOND STEP TO ATTRACT PRIVATE
CAPITAL PARTNERS TO LEVERAGE
SIGNIFICANT PRIVATE DOLLARS SO
THERE'S A MUCH BIGGER POOLS OF
MONEY TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
CLEAN ENERGY NEEDS THAN JUST THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE FUNDED TO
DATE.
WHAT'S THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP CARE THREE
REASONS FIRST WE REPRESENT MANY
OF THE TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN
PROVIDE CLIMATE SOLUTIONS THAT
FINANCING CAN HELP CONCERT WITH
CONSUMERS AFFORD.
SECOND WE REPRESENT PRIVATE
CAPITAL INTERESTS WHO COULD
PARTNER WITH THE PUBLIC CURRENT
PUBLIC PROGRAMS AND THIRD
SILICON VALLEY IS A A LAND OF
ENGINEERS ENGINEERS VIEW THINGS
NAY PROBLEM SOLUTION FRAMEWORK.
WE'VE YOU CLIMATE CHANGE THE
PROBLEM TO BE SOLVED AND WE WANT
TO PLAY A ROLE IN HELPING TO
SOLVE IT.
THANKYOU FOR YOUR TIME IN
CONSIDERING THIS IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BLAKE
JOHNSON HER BEHALF TEACHERS ARE
FEELING A Mà.
OVERALL THE BROAD SUPPORT THE
INTENT OF THE EFFORT -- OUR
OFFICE OF THE GUN WORKING WITH
AUTHORS OFFICE IN REVIEWING THE
LANGUAGE AND THE SAYS WILL BE
NECESSARY TO CARRY OUT THE
LEGISLATION SUCCESSFULLY -- WE
KNOW THAT WE NEED TO MAKE HUGE
STRIDES IN A CLIMATE GOALS WE
CAN'T DO IT ON TAXPAYERS RATE
PRAYER FUNDS ALONE.
ON STAGE IS OFF THIS HAPPY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH AUTHORS
OFFICE.
AS A RESOURCE AND WE BELIEVE
THIS COULD BE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO LEVERAGE OUR
EXISTING WORK AND EXPERTISE IN
THE CHURCH OF OFFICE.
AND MAKE AN IMPACT INTERESTING
BROADER STATE COORDINATION AND
LEVERAGING PRIVATE CAPITAL TO
TARGET LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND ENERGY EQUITY.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
HELLO.
EXCUSE ME VICTORIA AROUND AGAIN
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT AND
WANT TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH.
THE AUTHORS -- AS THE BELIEVE
ALSO MOVES THROUGH THE PROCESS
THANK YOU.
THERESA BURKE VERGE ON BEHALF OF
CERES AND SUPPORT.
JULIE NOT ASK ABOUT HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE MY APOLOGIES TO THE
COMMITTEE BUT MY BOARD IS JUST
VOTED TO HAVE A SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED POSITION ON THIS BILL.
AND FAILED TO COMMUNICATE TO THE
COMMITTEE BEFORE THIS BUT WE
JUST WANT TO SAY WE ABSOLUTELY
LOVE THIS PROGRAM WE THINK IT'S
A FANTASTIC IDEA WE JUST THINK
THAT THIS BILL IS AN APPROPRIATE
PLACE TO REDEFINE THE DEFINITION
OF WHAT A RENEWABLE RESOURCES.
WE THINK THAT BY A MASS IS BEING
TREATED DIFFERENTLY FOR SOME
REASON WE ASK THAT THAT BE TAKEN
OUT AND JUST.
IF YOUR RENEWABLE YOUR NOBLE AND
THAT PROBE THIS PROGRAM SHOULD
INCLUDE THAT THANK YOU.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT IF AMENDED
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU
ANYBODY -- WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL?
OKAY SEEING NONE WILL MOVE TO
THE COMMITTEE IF ANYONE ON THE
COMMITTEE HAS ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS SEGMENT -- JUST DO YOU
HAVE A RESPONSE TO THE BIOMASS
ISSUE MISTER MISTER ME.
SO THAT'S THE STICKING POINT --
I DON'T THINK THAT THIS
LEGISLATION IS THE RIGHT.
VEHICLE TO TO TO WAGE OR THAT TO
TRY TO SOLVE -- MORE THAN BEING
GAUGE IN THAT WAR BETWEEN WHAT'S
RENEWABLE NOT RENEWABLE IN
REGARDS TO THE BIOMASS -- I HAD --
INTENDED -- ON SHOULD BE BEFORE
YOU AN OFF FATHER'S AMENDMENT
WHICH WOULD STRIKE THAT LANGUAGE --
BUT WANTED TO LEAVE IT UP -- TO
THAT THE CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE
AND REGARDS TO THOSE QUESTIONS
AGAIN I DON'T THINK IT'S THE
INTENT IS NOT THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL.
A TO WAGE WAR THERE AND SO THAT
THAT LANGUAGE IS BECOME A
STICKING POINT FOR SOME VARIOUS
GROUPS -- BUT WANTED TO SEE WHAT
THE PLEASURE OF OF THE CHAIR IS
A YOU TO TAKE THAT THE AUTHORS
WORK. TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
I'M I BELIEVE THAT WE'VE
ACCEPTED THE AUTHORS MOMENT.
SO WE'VE ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENT --
IN RESPONSE TO THE BIOMASS
INDUSTRIES CONCERNS.
THANK IN YOUR ARE YOU OKAY WITH
ACCEPTING THAT TODAY THE FOR
MOVING FORWARD WITH THAT YES I'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO PUT THE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS AND THEN
TODAY.
YES.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY WITH WITHOUT THEN -- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND WAVE ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM TWELVE AB THREE EIGHTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MASON
FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA FLORA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LIMóN [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
MULLIN DOES NOT VOTING.
RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
RIGHT TO GI STONE [inaudible]
STONE I SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO
THE BILL ITSELF THANK YOU WILL
MEASURE.
AND FEEL.
WE NOW TO COMMIT HIS BILLS.
MS GARCIA WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT
.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS ON A
BEGIN MY THINKING AND ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
APPRECIATE ALL THE STAFF.
WORK ON THIS LAST YEAR I REQUEST
THAT IF THEY'D AUDIT OF THE
MATTRESS RECYCLING COUNCIL TO
DETERMINE THAT THE FEVER IS
BEING COLLECTED.
I'M ACTORS AS WAS DONE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE LAW AND HOW
AM I SEE WITH YOU SEEN THAT
FUNDING TO REACH CALIFORNIA
MATTRESS RECYCLING GOALS.
THE I. TO REPORT HIGHLIGHTED A
NUMBER OF ISSUE THAT NEEDED TO
BE ADRESSED.
ASSEMBLY MET MEMBER BIGELOW ALL
THAT CONCERNS ABOUT RURAL AREAS
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE USED
MATTRESS WE CYCLE.
HE AND I INTRODUCED AB ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN TO IMPLEMENT
CHANGES RECOMMENDED BY THE STATE
AUDITOR.
THIS BILL IS A WORK IN PROGRESS
MY STAFF AND WITH THE BAILIFF
THAT HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH.
THE MATCHES THE SECOND COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL REAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES THE CALIFORNIA
AND CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT WHILE
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
IMPROVEMENT EVERYONE INVOLVED
JUST WANTS TO MAKE SURE THE
PROGRAM IS MORE SUCCESSFUL.
AND THAT EVERYONE WHO BUYS A NEW
MATTRESS CAN RECYCLE THEIR OLD.
ONE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS BONNIE VALUE ON THE
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN YOU TODAY --
I DO APOLOGIZE FOR NOT ETTING
OUR LETTER IN ON TIME BUT WE'RE
HAPPY TO BE HERE AND TO VOICE
OUR SUPPORT FOR AB.
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN WE LIKE TO
THINK IT'S A REMEMBER GARCIA FOR
HER ONGOING LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE -- ONE FOR CALLING THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT THAT HELPED IDENTIFY THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PROGRAM
UPDATES AND IMPROVEMENTS. FOR
HER EFFORTS THESE PAST SEVERAL
MONTHS TO FACILITATE AGREEMENT
AMONG STAKEHOLDERS ON POLICY
CHANGES.
AND FOR THOSE -- RESULTING
PROPOSE LEGISLATIVE UPDATES AND
MODIFICATIONS TO INCREASE
PROGRAM EFFECTIVENESS AND
TRANSPARENCY AS CALLED AND
CALLED FOR IN THE AUDIT.
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
SPONSOR THE ORIGINAL USE
MATTRESS RECOVERING RECYCLING
ACT SB TWO FIFTY FOUR IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WHICH
ESTABLISHED -- THE COLLECTION
RECYCLING PROGRAM THIS WAS DONE
SO WITH THE SUPPORT OF
MANUFACTURERS RECYCLERS BUSINESS
LEADERS AND ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS
WELL THIS PROGRAM IS A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY.
IT IS STILL RELATIVELY NEW AND
IN NEED OF REVISIONS THAT
REFLECT LESSONS LEARNED IN THE
PAST FEW YEARS SINCE ITS
INCEPTION.
THE PROPOSED CHANGES THAT AB ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN WOULD MAKE ARE
LARGELY CONSISTENT WITH THE
AUDIT RECOMMENDATIONS AS WELL AS
THOSE DISCUSSED AMONG
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS. FOR THESE REASONS
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
APPRECIATIVE OF THEM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA FOR
TACKLING THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU AND JUST SO WE'RE
CLEAR MR SEE ARE YOU ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE -- YES ALL OF THEM
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
WITHOUT OTHER OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISH TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL.
YES JOHN KENNEDY WITH WORLD
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE ON THIS
BILL -- MAKES A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES TO INCREASE
THE YOU KNOW THE STRINGENCY THE
INTEGRITY OF THE PROGRAM -- AND
WE ALSO APPRECIATE EFFORTS TO
TRAIN INCREASE -- RECYCLING AND
DISPOSAL OPPORTUNITIES AND RURAL
AREAS SO LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE IN
THE DISCUSSION AND WORKING WITH
YOU THANK YOU.
LAUREN COME A SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
OUR PERSONAL HE DOES ON BEHALF
OF NATIONAL STORAGE ACTION
COUNCIL WANNA THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND HER STAFF FOR
BRINGING US TO TABLE EARLY ON
AND YOU KNOW.
WORKING ON THE ISSUES -- YOU
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS BUT
WE APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND HER STAFF LETTING US THANK
YOU WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS BREE CLARKE.
SEIZING.
A VICE PRESIDENT FOR POLICY IN
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL FLEET PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION ARE ESPA. FOR OVER
ONE HUNDRED YEARS AS BUT HAS
REPRESENTED THE MATTRESS
INDUSTRY ON MATTERS OF COMMON
CONCERN.
AND IN TWENTY THIRTEEN AS FOR
CREATED THE MATTRESS RECYCLING
COUNCIL OR MRC A FIVE OH ONE C.
THREE NON PROFIT ORGANIZATION TO
IMPLEMENT.
AND ADMINISTER MATTRESS
RECYCLING PROGRAMS IN STATES
THAT HAVE ENACTED MATTRESS
RECYCLING LOS.
THE MEASURES RECYCLING COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA IS CERTIFIED AS AN
APPROVED MATTRESS RECYCLING
ORGANIZATION BY CAL RECYCLE AND
LAUNCHED IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN IS BUT IN THE
MATTRESS INDUSTRY ARE VERY PROUD
OF THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THE
MRC CALIFORNIA.
AND ARE INTERESTED IN THE
ORGANIZATION'S CONTINUED SUCCESS.
HOLLY THE SPECIFIC DETAILS OF
MRC SUCCESS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO MY COLLEAGUE MIKE O'DONNELL.
IS BY APPRECIATES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK TOGETHER
WITH THE AUTHORS COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND THE BROADER STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS INTERESTED IN AB ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN WALLACE BUT DOESN'T
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION YET ON
THE BILL WE ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH EVERYONE INVOLVED.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONTINUED DISCUSSIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MICHAEL DONOVAN MANAGING
DIRECTOR OF THE MATTRESS
RECYCLING COUNCIL.
MRC APPRECIATES THE
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
DEVELOPED WITH THE AUTHORS OF
THIS BILL.
COMMITTEE STAFF CAL RECYCLING
THE BROADER STAKEHOLDER WORKING
GROUP ON EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
EVER SEE LAUNCHED ITS CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM NEARLY TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND IN A VERY SHORT TIME BUILT A
NETWORK OF COLLECTION LOCATIONS
THE SERVICE EVERY COUNTY IN THE
STATE.
THROUGH A COMBINATION OF
PERMANENT DROP OFF LOCATIONS IN
COLLECTION EVENTS.
WHAT WE'RE PROUD OF OUR PROGRESS
CONTINUED EXPANSION OF THE
PROGRAM IS A PRIMARY FOCUS OF
MRC?
AS A START UP AMHERST HIS
ACCOMPLISHED NEARLY ALL OF OUR
STATED OBJECTIVES.
WE MET OUR 201-620-1720 EIGHTEEN
COLLECTION GOALS AND ARE ON PACE
TO ACHIEVE OUR TWENTY NINETEEN
TARGET.
OUR SUCCESS TO DATE IS NOT A
CEILING BUT A FLOOR UPON WHICH
WE WILL INCREASE OUR SERVICE
LEVEL PUBLICOUTREACH.
AND LONG TERM PLANS TO MEET AND
EXCEED THE RECYCLING OBJECTIVES
ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
BY SB.
TWO FIFTY FOUR CONSUMERS ARE
WORK IS BY BY MATTRESS THIS
ROBUST EFFORT INCLUDES A PUBLIC
EDUCATION PROGRAM THAT CONSISTS
OF POINT OF SALE MATERIAL.
PAY TV ADVERTISING RADIO PRINT
MEDIA INTERNET BILLBOARDS
DIGITAL MARKETING ALL TARGETING
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS INCLUDING
LOW INCOME AND MULTI CULTURAL
COMMUNITIES.
MRC ALSO FUNDS LOCAL ILLEGAL
DONE CLEAN UP EFFORTS AND
COLLECTS DATA AND WHERE.
AN ILLEGAL DUMP STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS TO BETTER STAND HOW
AMMERSEE CAN ADDRESS THE PROBLEM
TODAY BOB PLANNING FOR A BETTER
CLEANER TOMORROW.
WE CREATE GREEN JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA WE CAUGHT BY CONTRACT
WITH.
TEN MATTRESS DECONSTRUCTION
FACILITIES OPERATING ACROSS THE
STATE INCLUDING LOCAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS SMALL
AND MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
THAT PROVIDE LIFE SKILLS AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS FOR THEIR
DIVORCE DIVERSE.
WORKFORCE.
MOST IMPORTANTLY THE MATTRESS
RECYCLING COUNCILS RECYCLED
NEARLY FOUR MILLION MATTRESSES
IN CALIFORNIA.
WE DIVERTED OVER A HUNDRED AND
TEN MILLION POUNDS OF MATERIAL
IN CALIFORNIA LANDFILLS.
AS THE PROGRAM GROWS SO WILL MRC.
WE ARE PREPARING A RECYCLING
NETWORK FOR THE FUTURE BY
INVESTING IN IMPORTANT RESEARCH
THAT WILL INCREASE OUR RECYCLING
RATE.
WHILE IMPROVING THE SAFETY AND
THROUGHPUT OF OUR CONTRACTORS.
UNDER SB TWO FIFTY FOUR MRC
CREATED A PROGRAM THAT IS AN
OUTSTANDING EXAMPLE OF
GOVERNMENT AND BUSINESS
COLLABORATION.
MRC AND IS BY BY MATTRESS
PROGRAM ARE A PRIVATE PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIP THAT SUPPORTS GREEN
JOBS CLEANS UP COMMUNITIES AND
IMPROVE THE ENVIRONMENT.
AB ONE EIGHTY SEVEN IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS AND MRC IS COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
IMPROVE AN ALREADY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL.
SEEING NO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CONCLUDE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY MEMBER
OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK.
THE TRUTH.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOVE MOVE AND SECOND I WANT TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS IMPORTANT
AREA THANK YOU WITHOUT ROLL CALL.
ITEM FOR AB ONE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
AYE GARCIA AYE LOW MOAN.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE MURATSUCHI FOR A TO
G. AYE STONE.
STONE I TEN ZERO MR MATHIS.
YOUR NEXT IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PRESENT
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OFTEN START WITH -- IT'D BE.
TWO FIFTY SEVEN MEMBERS AB TWO
FIFTY SEVEN IS A MEASURE
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE OPTIONS FOR
OUR ROLE RESIDENTS. TO DISPOSE
OF THEIR EXCESS BILE MAX THE
BILL.
THE MOTION A SECOND.
ALL MAY A QUICK IN RURAL AREAS A
LOT OF TIMES ARE PEOPLE HAVE TO
COLLECT ON THE TERM MEANS
EVERYTHING TO ME WITH -- FIRE
REGULATIONS -- AND SEVERAL OTHER
THINGS -- WITH AGRICULTURE.
AND WHAT OFTEN HAPPENS IS THEY
PUT TOGETHER ANY BERMAN PILED
THIS BILL ON PROVIDES A WAY FOR
THEM TO DISPOSE OF THE WASTE
WITHOUT HAVANESE BURN PILES AND
MOVE IT TOWARDS A BIO MASS
FASHION AND WITH THAT I WILL.
STOP TALKING AND ASK YOU FOR
YOUR I HAVE A MR MATHIS ARE YOU
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS YES.
MADAM CHAIR.
WITNESS SPEAKING IN FAVOR FOR
YOUR SINGLE PICKY WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL -- WE
THINK THAT THIS BILL IS A
CREATIVE AND INGENIOUS WAY TO
TRY AND ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO BE
ABLE TO USE BIOMASS IN A WAY --
AND AND BRING COMMUNITIES
TOGETHER TO MAKE IT AFFORDABLE
TO BE ABLE TO DO SETS SO WE'RE
SUPPORTING THE BILL.
THANK YOU ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL.
JOHN KENNEDY WITH RC RC IF WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL AS A WAY TO
GET THE FUEL OUT OF THE FOREST
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE GO UP AND
BURN PILES OR SOME OTHER
MECHANISM THANK YOU.
JULIE MANAUS GIVE ALL REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE GREAT BILL WE ARE DR.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
MEMBERS ASH FOR YOUR EITHER.
THANK YOU ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHICH TO COMMENT MR
STONE.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
ATTEMPT HERE BUT TO FOR US TO BE
PIECE MEALING OUT G. G. R. F.
WITHOUT A BROADER PLAN I THINK
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT SUB THREE
NEEDS TO TAKE A VERY CLOSE LOOK
AT AND THAT.
I WOULD.
KEEP WANTING TO COME BACK AND
MAKE SURE THAT THE ASSEMBLY
LOOKS BROADLY AT HOW WE'RE GOING
TO BE SPENDING GIGI ARRIVE.
COME UP WITH A PLAN FOR THAT SO
THAT WE CAN PHILLIP CONSISTENTLY.
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS INSTEAD OF
THAT HAPHAZARD WAY THAT WE HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSING IT SO I'M NOT
GOING TO SUPPORT THAT IS AT THIS
POINT IS I JUST.
I THINK THIS IS THE WRONG WAY TO
GO ABOUT GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION.
FUNDS EXPENDITURES AND IN TRYING
TO MANAGE THAT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU AND I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO COMMENT THAT I AGREE WITH YOU
ABOUT THE ISSUE OF G. R. FUNDING --
IN GENERAL ON THE AMENDMENTS TO
REMOVE THE JUROR FUNDING PORTION
FROM THE BILL SO NOW THE BILL
DOES NOT EXPRESSLY -- USE YOUR
RIGHT NOW I'M MORE OF THAT BUT
THAT'S PROBABLY THE ONLY SOURCE
THAT THIS IS GOING TO BE VIABLE
FOR SO IN THIS CASE WE HAVE A
PROGRAM WITHOUT ANY FUNDING.
AND WITHOUT NECESSARILY A
MECHANISM TO TRY TO APPROACH
THAT I DON'T THINK IT'S IT'S AN
APPROPRIATE GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AGAIN CHOOSE YOUR
OFFICE THAT THE LOGICAL PLACE
FOR THIS TO GO WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT THESE KINDS OF
PROGRAMS.
AND LOOKING AT ITEMS THAT ARE
REDUCING.
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS SORT OF
MORE BROADLY IN A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE WAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS COMMENTS.
BUT THAT MISTER METHOD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ABSOLUTELY I THINK
THIS IS A GREAT WAY TO START
GETTING RID OF BURN PILES --
ACTUALLY USE THAT INSTEAD OF
LOSING THAT ENERGY -- AND HAVING
THE ADMITTANCE GOING TO THE YEAR
WE CAN ACTUALLY HARNESS THAT IN
MAKE IT INTO RENEWABLE ENERGY.
ON THIS ALSO GIVES THE COUNTIES.
ARE THE ABILITY TO OPT INTO
THESE PROGRAMS VERSUS BEING
FORCED BY ANOTHER GOVERNMENT
MANDATE SO WITH THAT MEMBERS ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
I THINK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE ITEM
SEVEN AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LOW MOAN.
LOW MOAN AYE MATHIS HI MATHIS I
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S MELENDEZ
AYE MURATSUCHI.
RIGHT TO CHI AYE STONE
[inaudible]
SO NO [inaudible] NINE ONE THANK
YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT
YOUR NEXT BILL.
YES MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT AB TWO THIRTY
ONE A MEASURE DESIGNED TO
INCREASE OUR STATE'S.
COMMITMENT TO RECYCLED WATER.
AS YOU ALL ARE WHERE OUR STATE
IS PRONE TO FREQUENT AND
DISASTERS DROUGHTS.
SADLY IT'S OUR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE.
THAT ARE THE MOST AFFECTED.
OUR LAST ROUTE RESULTED IN THE
DISASTER IN ONE OF MY
COMMUNITIES EAST PORTICO.
AS MOST OF YOU ARE AWARE THE
TOWN STILL HASN'T HAD RUNNING
WATER IN FIVE YEARS.
FAMILIES ARE STILL LEFT WITHOUT
ACCESS TO CLEAN DRINKING WATER
RUNNING WATER IN GENERAL.
WE HAVE UNDERTAKEN MANY STEPS.
TO GET THE TOWN CONNECTED TO
NEIGHBORING PORTABLES WATER
SYSTEMS HOWEVER THE PROCESS IS
SLOW.
ALTHOUGH WE ARE NEARING THE
POINT WHERE EAST PORTABLE CAN
RETURN TO SOME SENSE OF NORMALCY.
SMALL LOW INCOME TOWNS LIKE THIS
ONE ARE SEVERELY.
UNDER PREPARED FOR THE NEXT
DROUGHT.
WE MUST ALWAYS LOOK AHEAD.
A WHAT MIGHT BE FALL OR
DISADVANTAGE.
AND AT RISK COMMUNITIES ONE WAY
THAT WE CAN BETTER PREPARE. FOR
THE DISASTERS AHEAD.
AND EVEN TO MITIGATE THEIR
DAMAGES.
THIS FOUND WITHIN AB. TWO THIRTY
ONE TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED SB EIGHTY
EIGHT WITHIN THE LANGUAGE THERE.
WAS A SEQUEL EXEMPTION FOR
RECYCLED WATER FACILITIES AND
TERTIARY TREATMENT PLANTS.
WHY THIS EXEMPTION WAS VASTLY
NEEDED THE SHORT SUNSET DATE
ALONG WITH THE SPECIFIC
REFERENCE TO THE DROUGHT?
STATE OF EMERGENCY HAMPERED
EFFORTS TO UTILIZE THE EXEMPTION
FOR THE EXPANSION OF THESE
FACILITIES UNFORTUNATELY NO NEWS
FACILITIES WERE ABLE.
TO CAPITALIZE ON THE SEQUEL
EXEMPTION BECAUSE OF THE SHORT
TIME FRANK.
MY MAJOR SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT
ANY FUTURE.
DROUGHTS.
WHICH IS SO SEVERE AS TO MERIT A
DECLARATION OF OUR EMERGENCY BY
THE GOVERNOR SHOULD RECEIVE THIS
EXEMPTION.
MEMBERS THIS IS VERY SIMPLE.
WE HAVE AND NEED TO GET THESE
PLANTS UP IN THESE FACILITIES
OPERATING.
AND IT JUST MAKES IT WHERE IF
THE GOVERNOR DEEMS IT A STATE OF
EMERGENCY WERE ALLOWED TO MOVE
THROUGH.
AND CUT THROUGH THE RED TAPE AND
GIVE PEOPLE WHAT THEY NEEDED.
I SIMPLY ASK YOU FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE BRENNAN DAWSON WAS
SIERRA CLUB -- SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA OPPOSES AB TWO THIRTY
ONE IN OUR VIEW IT'S UNNECESSARY
AND IT'S DESIGNED SO WHICH
PREVENT THE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
PROCESS IS THAT C. PROVIDES.
TO LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AB TWO THIRTY ONE WOULD PROVIDE
A SECRET EXEMPTION WHERE ONE IS
NOT NECESSARY THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT ALREADY
AUTHORIZES THE GOVERNOR DURING A
STATE OF EMERGENCY TO ISSUE A
PROCLAMATION.
OF A STATE OF EMERGENCY IN
SUSPEND ANY REGULATORY STATUTE
WITH IT TOOK GOVERNOR DETERMINES
AND DECLARES THE STRICT
COMPLIANCE WITH THE STATUTE
HINDER.
ANY WAY TO PREVENT.
OR HINDER OR DIGIT DELAY THE
MITIGATION AFFECTS OF AN
EMERGENCY SO AS SUCH YOU THIRTY
ONE WOULD PROVIDE A SECRET
EXEMPTION FOR ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE ALREADY SUBJECT TO POTENTIAL
EXPEDITED REVIEW.
MOREOVER THE BILL PORTS EQUALS
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
REQUIREMENTS AS WE KNOW SEEKER
REQUIRES PROJECTS TO BE ANALYZED
IN A REPORT AND THAT
UNDERSTANDING MINUTE -- TO
UNDERSTAND A MITIGATE THEIR
ENVIRONMENT IMPACTS AND IT
PROVIDES CRITICAL PUBLIC
OVERSIGHT.
THEY NEVER IT INEVITABLY LEADS
TO BETTER INSISTING COMMUNITIES
FOR ALL OF US EXEMPTION FOR
SEQUEL UNLESS NARROWLY TAILORED
SEVERELY LIMIT A COMMUNITIES
PARTICIPATION IN GOVERNMENT
PROCESS.
AND DECISIONS ARE LIKELY TO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS COMPLETELY SERVICE
CIRCUMVENTING SEE BECAUSE TRUE
INTENTION AND INTENDED PURPOSE.
AND LASTLY THE SEQUEL PROCESS WE
COULD PROVIDE A LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY WHEN IT COMES OR
CYCLE WATER. FOR THE PUBLIC
RECYCLED WATER BY THE DROUGHT
RESISTANT WATER SOURCE THAT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD MOVE TOWARDS
AND BECOME MORE RESILIENT
SUSTAINABLE IN FUTURE THAT'S
WERE -- MY ORGANIZATION IN THE
SOME MEMBERS AGREE.
HOWEVER THERE ARE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT ARE NOT -- THAT ARE
AWARE THAT RECYCLE WATER ALSO
HAS CHALLENGES AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC ARE WARY OF RECYCLED
WATER USE AND NEEDED NEED TO BE
INFORMED OF ITS ANTI.
OF ITS BENEFITS PUBLIC
INVOLVEMENT ENVIRONMENTAL
MITIGATION THAT SECRETIVE RIDES
BY GIVING WAY THIS NECESSARY ON
THIS NECESSARY INFORMATION CAN
HELP YOU GET THE PUBLIC ON BOARD
WITH RECYCLED WATER. FOR SUCH
IMPORTANT IMPLEMENTATION IN A
WAY THAT'S ON SAFELY WITH THAT
WE OPPOSE C. A. B..
TWO THIRTY ONE THANK YOU ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO VOICE THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING NONE OUR TURN -- TO
MISTER MATHIS FOR ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS OR ACTUALLY ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OF QUESTIONS.
I'LL JUST -- SAY THAT I CAN'T
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY I
UNDERSTAND -- THAT YOU HAVE VERY
GOOD MOTIVATIONS WITH THIS BUT I
AGREE WITH THEM --
REPRESENTATIVE SINCE YOUR CLUB
THAT GIVEN THAT WE HAVE DONE
THIS DURING THE LAST DROUGHT AND
IT WASN'T USED BY ANY WATER
AGENCY AND THAT WERE IT NOT IN
DROUGHT CURRENTLY.
AND THIS IS A PERFECT TIME FOR
THE AGENCIES YOU TALK ABOUT THAT
FEEL THAT THEY HAVE ISSUES WITH
WATER AND WANT TO DO THE RECYCLE
PROJECTS TO GO AHEAD AND DO
THEIR SUPER PROCESS AND DO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK THAT.
THESE PROJECTS REALLY SHOULD DO
TO INVITE THE PUBLIC DISSIPATION --
IT'S HARD FOR ME.
TO PASS SOMETHING ANTICIPATING
SOMETHING IN THE FUTURE WHEN I
CAN'T REALLY QUANTIFY EXACTLY
WHAT THE BARRIER IS.
SO THAT'S MY POSITION I AS
ANYBODY ELSE HAVE ANY --
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
OKAY WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ABSOLUTELY MADAM CHAIR YOU
KNOW EVERY EFFORT. TO MOVE --
EMERGENCY DRINKING WATER.
IS ALWAYS.
MET WITH EXTREME HEAVY
RESISTANCE ESPECIALLY IN THIS
COMMITTEE.
CALL PAUL AN E. TWENTY TO LOOK
DEEP DOWN AND REALLY THINK ABOUT
THESE COMMUNITIES -- YOU KNOW WE
WE DEAL WITH THIS WITH THE
DROUGHT WE SEE.
YOU KNOW WE JUST -- PASS SOME
SEQUEL REFORM TO HELP MAKE
FAMILIES HOLE FROM THE FIRES
WERE STILL TRYING TO MAKE
FAMILIES HOLE FROM THE DROUGHT.
AND YOU KNOW IT IT JUST BLOWS MY
MIND THAT EVERY TIME.
THERE'S YOU KNOW THERE THERE'S A
STADIUM IN OAKLAND THAT'S GOING
TO BE BUILT ON THE WATERFRONT
DELICIOUS WAY SHE WILL.
FOR WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR NEW
BUILDING HERE. FOR FOR THE NEW
ANNEX FOR OUR OWN OFFICES ALL
THIS IS WHERE SHE WILL FOR THAT.
WHEN IT COMES TO WATER? FOR
FAMILIES THAT HAVE GONE WITHOUT.
IT'S A WE WE CAN'T DO THAT WE
NEED TO SLOW DOWN THE PROCESS
AND AND QUITE FRANKLY I'M SICK
OF IT MEMBERS.
WATER IS THAT VITAL THING THAT
WE NEED.
IT IS THE VERY FIRST STEP ON
MANTLE'S HIERARCHY OF NEEDS.
AND WE'RE NOT DOING IT WE WE
WAIVE SEQUEL FOR EVERYTHING ELSE.
BUT NOT FOR WATER.
IN MEMBERS A I ASK YOU TO JOIN
ME TODAY.
AND SEE WATER MATTERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND VOTE YES
ON THIS THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
ROLL CALL PLEASE ITEM FIVE AB
TWO THIRTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRIEDMAN NOW
FRIEDMAN -- FLORA FLORA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NO GARCIA.
GARCIA NO LOW MOAN.
Là M<c.cyan> NO MATHIS YES MATHIS</c>
AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY NO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI NO STONE [inaudible]
STONE NO [inaudible] THREE SEVEN
THANK YOU WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ALRIGHT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR MCCARTY.
MISTER MCCURRY ARE UP FOR YOUR
TWO BILLS.
WHICH ONE IS YOUR WHEN A WOMAN
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY WHICH WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO
FIRST BILL DUE.
TO SEVENTY EIGHT OKAY THANK YOU.
WITNESSES APPEAR I'M HERE TODAY
TO PRESENT THIS MEASURE WHICH
WOULD ALLOW.
NOT GUARANTEE ALLOW PAROLEES TO
BE CONSIDERED FOR PARTICIPATION
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS.
WE KNOW THE GOVERNOR CREATE THIS
GREAT PROGRAM IN THE SEVENTIES
THE LARGEST CONSERVATION CORPS
IN THE COUNTRY MODELED AFTER
PROGRAM CRATE DURING THE GREAT.
DEPRESSION THE MOTTO THIS
PROGRAM IS HARD WORK LOW PAY
MISERABLE CONDITIONS BUT
APPARENTLY SOME INDIVIDUALS
WOULD LOVE THIS OPPORTUNITY
INDIVIDUALS IN THE PROGRAM --
WORK ON ISSUES LIKE FORCED YOU
MANAGEMENT CLEAN ENERGY
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND FIRE
FIGHTING OFFER OFTEN EARNING
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS.
AND INDICES CERTIFICATES ALONG
THE WAY THIS PROGRAM IS MAINLY
FOR PEOPLE BETWEEN THE AGES OF
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY FIVE IN
CALIFORNIA.
INDIVIDUALS ON PROBATION ARE
ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE BUT WE
EXCLUDE PEOPLE ON PAROLE AND
THINK ABOUT THAT INDIVIDUALS
INCARCERATED CAN GO AND FIGHT
THE FIRES WHILE THEY'RE IN
PRISON.
WHEN THEY'RE PAROLED THEY CAN'T
JOIN THE CONSERVATION CORPS DO
THE EXACT SAME WORK THIS IS
UNFAIR DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR
TRYING TO FIGHT RECIDIVISM IN
CALIFORNIA?
HI THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT WE
KNOW WOULD WORK AND GIVE YOUNG
PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTRIBUTE TO US ABOUT OUR
SOCIETY AND HELP THEM -- MOVE
ALONG THE WAY AS WELL -- THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW AGAIN ALLOW NOT
REQUIRED THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CONSERVATION CORPS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS TO
ASSESS INDIVIDUALS.
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS I THINK
IT MAKES SENSE FOR CALIFORNIA
AND FOR INDIVIDUALS LOOKING --
TO MAKE THE BEST OF THEIR LIVES
AFTER THEIR AFTER TIME
INCARCERATED WITH ME TODAY ARE A
FEW INDIVIDUALS TO SHARE THEIR
FIRST HAND STORIES AND ASK FOR
YOUR I'VE.
MOVED THE BILL -- THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE HI MY NAME IS
JOHN RIGGINS AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FRESNO YOU'LL
SEE LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS.
I'M ALSO REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURTS AND THE
FOURTEEN LOCAL NONPROFIT STATE
CERTIFIED CONSERVATION CORPS
THEY REPRESENT.
WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT WE BELIEVE THE
COURT PROVIDE ACCESS EDUCATION
AND JOB TRAINING FOR YOU.
TAUGHT THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHO
EXPERIENCE EXTREME VARIOUS ONE
POINT IT.
MANY OF THE YOUNG ADULTS WE
SERVE OUR PARENTS HOMELESS AND
IMPOVERISHED.
COURSE PROVIDE THEM WITH AN
AVENUE TO LEARN A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA AND WE SEE PAID ON THE
JOB TRAINING THE LCDS CURRENTLY
EXCEPT YOU.
WITH CRIMINAL HISTORIES
INCLUDING THOSE ON PAROLE.
WE DO THIS BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND
THAT ONE MISTAKE IN THE YOUNG
PERSON'S LIFE SHOULD NOT PREVENT
THEM FROM HAVING A PRODUCTIVE
FUTURE.
DURING OUR TWENTY SIX YEARS OF
OPERATION AND FRESNO.
THE FRESNO LCC HAD THEM ROLL
NUMEROUS CORN INVOLVE YOUTH
INCLUDING THOSE ON PROBATION AND
PAROLE AS PART OF LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERALLY FUNDED REENTRY
PROGRAMS.
AS A DIRECTOR OF THE LCC MANY OF
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE THAT HAVE COME.
FROM INCARCERATED BEEN SOME OF
OUR BEST -- CORE MEMBERS.
AB TWO SEVEN A WILL PROVIDE AN
AVENUE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE ON
PAROLE TO ENROLL INTO THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS.
IT HAS BEEN ESTIMATED THAT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- THIS
YOU CAN SPEND BETWEEN FIFTY TO
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO INCARCERATE YOUNG
ADULT.
IN COMPARISON THE YOUNG PERSON
CAN GO THROUGH THE CORE FOR
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS RECEIVE A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA VALUABLE JOB SKILLS.
IN A SENSE OF BELONGING TO THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE -- NEXT YOU
WILL HEAR TESTIMONY FROM A
CURRENT LTC CORE MEMBER BALK
WHEN YOU BORROW WHO SHARE HIS
STORY WITH YOU.
IN ADDITION I'VE ALSO BROUGHT
WITH ME A CURRENT LCC CREW
SUPERVISOR MR DAHLE FOR LEYVA.
THE DUFF OVER THE FORMER.
FRESNO CORPS MEMBER THAT ENTERED
THE PROGRAM ON PAROLE.
YES SIR SEVERAL YEARS IN PRISON.
BUT ALSO IS NOW WORKING FATHER
AND HE ROLE OF TWO YOUNG
DAUGHTERS HE'S ALSO ATTENDING
COLLEGE.
A DAHLE FOR THE LIVING PROOF
THAT THE IMPACT THE CORE PROGRAM
CAN HAVE ON A FORM INCARCERATED
YOUNG PERSON.
IF TIME PERMITS ASSET TO LISTEN
TO A STORY.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY AND
CAL STANDS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS IMPORTANT POLICY.
NUMBER TURN IT OVER.
TO THE PARK OF HELLO THANK YOU
FOR OUR MY NAME'S PARTY BAR A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY BACKGROUND.
I COME FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA I
GREW UP IN THE NORTH SIDE OF
FRESNO.
YOU CAN MAKE.
SORRY.
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY BACKGROUND
I COME FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA I
GREW UP IN THE NORTH SIDE OF
FRESNO.
RUNNER STREET MY PARENTS FROM
DRUGS MY GRANDPARENTS TOOK CARE
OF US.
THEY MADE SURE WE HAD CLOTHES ON
OUR BACKS I NEVER WENT TO SCHOOL.
MY PARENTS ENDED UP IN PRISON MY
DAD GOT OUT GOT CLEANED TOOK
TOOK US BACK.
WELL MY MOM STAYED ON DRUGS I
ENDED UP IN PRISON. FOR BAD
CHOICES I MADE.
WHILE I WAS INCARCERATED AND A
GUEST SPEAKER.
FROM THE COR -- THE BOND THE
WALL PROGRAM.
WHO SPOKE ABOUT THE EEOC AND ALL
THE PROGRAMS THAT?
ALL THE PROGRAM IS A MEMBER
MENTOR SHIP THEY OFFERED WHEN I
WAS DONE WITH MY TIME I GOT OUT
A MONTH LATER I AM ROAD IT'S TO
THE CORE.
THE COURT PROVIDED ME.
AND A COUPLE OF MY SOLDIERS WITH
JOB TRAINING COUNSELING WHEN
NEEDED IT CERTIFICATION FOR US
TO BE JOB READY.
THEY PROVIDE A SAFE CLOSE CAMPUS
SO WE CAN GET A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA.
BE COLLEGE BOUND.
THIS OPPORTUNITY HAS CHANGED MY
LIFE BY SHOWING ME CHAU MYSELF I
CAN BE A BETTER MAN I CAN
PROVIDE FOR MY FAMILY I WILL BE.
RECEIVING MY HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
THIS JUNE.
SOME THINGS I WOULD NEVER DOT
SOMETHING I NEVER THOUGHT I
COULDN'T.
COULD DO IT GIVES ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRAVEL GET MY
FAMILY HOPE THAT THERE'S GOOD
OPPORTUNITIES OUT THERE.
BETTER THAN RUNNING THE STREETS
HE GIVES ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHOW MY KIDS.
NOT TO HAVE A GOOD CHARACTER AND
THAT JUST BECAUSE WE LIVE IN A
BAD NEIGHBORHOOD DON'T MEAN WE
CAN'T.
GO PLACES AND BECOME SOMEBODY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON WHEN
THERE'S A DUFFEL ABLE.
AND HOME I WAS A FORMER COR
MEMBER NOW I'M A SUPERVISOR.
OFF FROM INCARCERATION TO
FREEDOM MIGHT NEVER HAD ANYTHING
TO FALL BACK ON I WAS KEEP GOING
BACK TO SAM LIFESTYLE.
IT WAS BY NECESSITY.
NOT BYCHOICES -- THERE WAS
SOMETHING THAT I NEED TO DO TO
PROVIDE FOR MY FAMILY FOR MYSELF --
I'M TOLD IS MY FAMILY UNTIL I
STARTED TO ATTEND A LITTLE
CONSERVATION CORPS WHERE PEOPLE
HAVE COMMITTED THEIR LIVES TO
HELP OUR YOUNG MEN AND LADIES.
THERE ARE GOING THROUGH SIMILAR
SITUATIONS LIKE MINE AND
PARTICLES.
HOUSE IF HE TOOK THE TIME. TO
EQUITY WITH JOBTRAINING AND A
HIGHER EDUCATION THAT CHANGED MY
LIFE.
AT TEN ARE LOW I ATTEND OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE TIME
SUPERVISOR EMPLOYED BY LCC.
I WORK HARD TO TRAIN OTHER
YOU'VE.
THAT ARE ENROLLED IN OUR PROGRAM
AND PASS ON THIS GREAT SERVICE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES OF ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SPEAKING
IN.
FAVOR OF THE BILL.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL MOVED TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YES SOME NUMBER MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
ASSEMBLYMAN MCCARTY WOULD YOU
MIND -- ASKING YOUR WOULDN'T
PARCO IS IT IF WOULD YOU MIND
SWITCHING SEATS WITH THE
GENTLEMAN IN THE BLACK SHIRT SO
THAT I CAN ASK A QUESTION YOU
DON'T HAVE.
TO TURN YOUR HEAD.
IT'S IT'S A LITTLE AWKWARD AND
UNCOMFORTABLE THANK YOU SIR
APPRECIATE THAT -- IF YOU
WOULDN'T.
MIND JUST TELL ME I'VE BEEN TO
THE CONSERVATION CORPS THAT'S
LOCATED IN MY DISTRICT -- BUT I
WAS WANTING IF YOU COULD TELL US
BRIEFLY THE TYPES OF THINGS THAT
YOU DID WHILE YOU WERE AT
CONSERVATION CORPS.
A LOT OF DAYS THAT I HAD DONE
WHEN I WAS LOOKING AT THE LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS ARM.
I'M I'M IN THE STUDENT COUNCIL
THAT WE HAVE ON OUR SITE AND I'M
ACTUALLY THE STUDENT COUNCIL
PRESIDENT.
OF OUR SCHOOLS SO I'M THE ONE
THAT SHOWS OUR CAMPUS AROUND WE
HAVE DIFFERENT -- SITE VISITS WE
HAVE ONE FROM OUR TJ **** OUR
CONGRESSMEN I WAS ABLE TO GIVE
HIM TO TALK ABOUT MYSELF OF OUR
WHOLE FACILITY -- WE JUST
DIFFERENT BLOCK PARTIES WE TRY
TO BRING BROKEN NEIGHBORHOODS
BACK TOGETHER -- WE JUST TRY TO
DO AS MUCH AS WE COULD INTO THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT
OF KIDS OUT THERE THAT.
THAT DON'T HAVE NO RUSH TO GO
WHEN YOU SAY BLOCK PARTY WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN IT'S BASICALLY I
A BIG EVENT WE DO AND I AM
BROKEN NEIGHBORHOODS -- IT'S A
FREE VENTS OPEN TO THE PUBLIC
AND IT JUST BRINGS EVERYBODY
TOGETHER JUST TO SHOW WHAT WE
CAN DO NOT.
LIKE I SAID JUST BECAUSE WE LIVE
IN A AND A AND A BROKEN
NEIGHBORHOOD OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE CAN GO
SOMEWHERE I LIVE.
I MEAN FROM WHERE I CAME FROM.
TO SERVE FROM WHERE I CAME FROM
TO NOW WHERE I AM NOW I NEVER
THOUGHT I COULD SEE MYSELF HERE.
I WASN'T EVEN SUPPOSED TO BE
HERE AT THIS TIME I WAS ACTUALLY
SUPPOSED WAS BEING PARKS RATED.
BUT I'M HERE NOW AND I'M
ACTUALLY TRYING TO GO FOR THEIR
LIFE OKAY THANK YOU AND THE
GENTLEMAN HERE WOULD YOU MIND
JUST TELLING US WHAT YOU
SPECIFICALLY DID IN THE
CONSERVATION CORPS I'M JUST.
CURIOUS WHAT TYPES OF ACTIVITIES
YOU WERE.
GROWING UP I TO HAVE ANY TYPE OF
JOB TRAINING ON THE LOCAL
SERVICE TOOK A DID TOOK THE
INITIATIVE.
ON TRAINING US IN DIFFERENT TYPE
OF WORK RELATED TRAINING I WOULD
SAY ONE OF THEM WAS CONSTRUCTION.
WE HAVE GONE WE HAVE GOT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH HEAVY
EQUIPMENT BOBCATS -- TRENCHING
TRENCH DIGGING WHICH THOSE ARE.
WORDS THAT I NEVER EVEN KNEW IN
MY LIFE THE ONLY WORDS THAT I
KNEW WAS A WHAT'S THAT I'VE
LEARNED IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS
WHERE GROW BACK -- NOW THAT I'M
THERE WE HAVE SOME FORKLIFT
TRAINING WHICH IT'S SAW WE TRAIN
OF COMMERCE TO LEARN HOW TO
OPERATE FORKLIFTS SO THAT COULD
GIVE HIM A BETTER ADVANTAGE AT
HOME JOB.
PLAY WHEN WE PLACE ONE JOBS --
WHEN HE WAS MENTIONING BLOCK
PARTIES THAT'S A CONTRIBUTION
BETWEEN THE LOW CONSERVATION
CORPS AND PARTNERING WITH THE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT?
WHICH IS -- IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE THAT I HAVE BUILT.
A RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM AND
IT'S IT'S AN EXPERIENCE THAT I
NEVER THOUGHT I COULD NOT SIT
DOWN AND SPEAK TO A POLICE
OFFICER.
AFTER.
BEING ARRESTED BY THEM -- NO
LONGER DO I HAVE TO WRITE ON THE
BACK OF A COP CAR.
BUT I GET TO WRITE ON THE SIDE
OF THEM AND THAT'S WHAT THEY
BRING TO THE TABLE.
IT'S EDUCATION THE THEY PROVIDE
A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA IF YOU
DON'T HAVE ONE AND DAY YOU GET
TO EARN A GRANT.
TO ATTEND COLLEGE AND THAT'S
WHAT I HAVE LEARNED AND I'M.
ATTENDING CITY CALLED TWEN AS WE
SPEAK.
OKAY THANK YOU GENTLEMEN -- SO
ASSEMBLYMAN MCCARTY WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND I WANTED PEOPLE TO
HEAR SPECIFICALLY WHAT YOU
EXPERIENCE THERE BECAUSE I JUST
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND.
WHERE THE MOTION IS COMING FROM
FROM YOU AND THAT YOU KNOW
YOU'RE RIGHT YOU'RE WE ARE NOT?
THE SOME OF OUR MISTAKES.
EVERYBODY MAKES MISTAKES AND WE
CAN CHANGE AND YOU THE FACT YOU
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW
YOUR KIDS THAT IN YOUR NEIGHBORS
AND YOUR FAMILY -- THAT'S A GOOD
THING YOU KNOW SO -- I AM GOING
TO BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY
AND I'LL BE AN ENCOURAGING MY
COLLEAGUES TO DO SO AS WELL AND
I JUST I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
COMING HERE TODAY IT'S PROBABLY
NOT EASY. TO COME FORWARD AND IN
PUBLIC KNOWING YOU KNOW IT'S
GOING TO BE TELEVISED DIDN'T
HAVE STRANGERS JUDGING YOU --
BUT BUT IT IS STILL IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T DO THAT --
THAN OTHER PEOPLE THEY'RE NOT SO
SURE THAT THE SAME HOPE IS THERE
FOR THEM SIDE I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR DOING THANK YOU.
MR MATHIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- YEAH I
JUST WANT TO ASK YOU GUYS I MEAN
THE BIG THING.
IN IN DON'T DON'T MISTAKE ME
FIRST SHOOT I'M JUST -- OKAY
FROM YOU SAID PORTALS -- DO YOU
GUYS REALLY SEE LIKE WHEN YOU'RE
DOING THE BLOCK PARTIES WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING TO THE YOUNGER
GENERATION I MEAN ONE OF THE
BIGGEST THING FOR ME IS BREAKING
THE CYCLE AND AND YOU FIND THEY
CAN SHARE A COUPLE OPPORTUNITIES
WHERE YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO TALK.
TO THE YOUNGER GUYS COMING UP IN
AND REALLY KIND OF STEER THEM IN
A BETTER DIRECTION THAT WAY
BECAUSE I I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE MISS THAT -- WITH THE
WITH THE CORE IN IN WHAT YOU
GUYS ARE ABLE TO DO BECAUSE
YOU'RE ABLE TO GET THESE GUYS.
AND GIRLS ON THE YOUNGER AND
REALLY KIND OF BE LIKE HEY LET
ME TELL YOU WHAT'S REALLY GOING
ON SO COULD YOU SHARE SOME.
TIME WHERE YOU'VE DONE THAT OR
SOMETHING JUST.
BECAUSE THIS IS PUBLICIZING I
THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE IN HERE WE GET
THESE NOTES ARE LIKE -- YOU KNOW
THESE ARE BAD GUYS AND THESE
GUYS HAVE BEEN IN JAIL AND ALL
THAT BUT I I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT LIKE -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
MULLIN AS YOU STATED YOU KNOW
IT'S WE WE RECOVER FROM OUR
MISTAKES WE GROW AND WE LEARN --
IN.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO PAY IT
FORWARD.
SO IF YOU COULD SHARE AND I
THINK THAT BE REALLY GREAT.
I CAN SAY TO INCARCERATION I
NEVER KNEW THAT FOR COMMITTING A
FOR COMMITTING A CRIME I WILL BE
ABLE TO GET A LENGTH.
OF BIG NUMBER OF TIME IN PRISON
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT IS THIS
DOES DOES THAT SAID YOU CAN IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD SOME.
GOING TO PRISON AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'S A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME AWAY FROM YOUR
FAMILY MEMBER SOMETIMES FROM
YOUR OWN CHILDREN.
HE CREATES THIS SAW.
THIS DIFFERENT PERSONALITY DO
YOU HAVE TO LIVE ON THEIR END
THERE BUT GETTING OUT IS LIKE.
WHAT DO YOU DO WITH THE DELIVERY
AND OR TO GET OUT AND BE
SOMEBODY DIFFERENT WHICH?
IT'S PART OF WHAT THE LOCALS
VISUAL LOOK ACROSS VISION COURT
AND PRINTED IT MYSELF.
BECAUSE I I WENT INTO OF KNOWING
THAT THEY HAVE.
THEY HAVE GIVEN ME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TO RISE ABOVE THE
SEA LEVEL WHEN.
COMING BACK IN BEING ABLE TO
SHARE MY STORIES.
SAD STORIES WITH CORE MEMBERS
AND THE CONSEQUENCES OF AND THEN
ENDING UP IN A IN A PRISON CELL
THAT'S NO BIGGER THAN A CLOSET.
ARM.
SOMETIMES YOU COULD SEE WHEN
THEY THEY GET IT.
THE ONLY TO BE ENTERED THERE'S
OTHER WAYS TO TO MAKE A LIVING
AND THAT'S THE THAT'S REWARDING
TOWARDS MYSELF BECAUSE I KNOW
FOR A FACT ONE LIFE OUT OF
PRISON IT'S IT'S WHAT THAT.
THIS WERE DOING WHAT I'M DOING.
THANK YOU.
YEAH -- LIKE YOU SAID IT'S JUST
THE REALITY OF HOW YOU GONNA
LIVE WHEN YOU GET OUT YOU'RE
GONNA TAKE IT WHICH IF WE'RE
GONNA LEAVE IT.
I HAVE WE COULD GET OUT AND DO
THIS HOW WE'RE DOING IT NOW TO
BE HERE.
I'M PRETTY SURE IT WILL BE --
DID WE CHANGE SOMEBODY ELSE'S
LIFE YOU KNOW WHEN WE'RE OUT
THERE DOING THE BLOCK PARTIES
ARE WE TALK TO ANYBODY I WAS
JUST -- IT DOESN'T MATTER THE
AGE LIMIT AS LONG AS WE TRY TO
CATCH IT EARLY WE COULD TRY TO
HELP HIM OUT.
THIS PROGRAM HAS A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO GIVE US A LOT
OF STUFF THAT WE COULD JUST TAKE
A RUN.
BUT I GOT TO THE PEOPLE AT THE
I'M A LOCAL COURTS OF TO YOU
GUYS WHEN WE DO THAT THE
ORIENTATION.
I TIME IT'S UP TO YOU GUYS IF
YOU GUYS WANT TO GRAB THIS STUFF
AND RUN WITH IT HAVE NOT.
IT'S STILL GOING TO BE THERE.
AND AS A MATTER IF YOU LEAVE
GOING LEAVE TO ALWAYS GONNA OPEN
YOU OPEN ARMS AND ARE ALWAYS
THERE FOR YOU AND IF WE COULD
JUST CATCH IT ADDED ADDED ADDED
EARLY TIME.
I'M PRETTY SURE IT CAN HELP
SOMEBODY IN THE LONGER LIKE IT'S
HELPING ME RIGHT NOW
[inaudible]
APPRECIATION -- SOONER KERR A
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS FORWARD ON A SUPPORT TODAY
AND I LOOK FORWARD.
TO IN THE IDEA TO HELP IN THE
LONG LIMóN NO.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM ANY OF THEM MANY MEMBERS.
BUT THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
NO AGAIN APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION IN THIS IS
PERMISSIVE WE HIRE ABOUT LESS
THAN FIVE THOUSAND OFFICIALS
EACH YEAR IN THE CORE AND UNDER
THEIR LIFE OUT THERE TWO YEARS
AGO FOR PEOPLE ON PROBATION LESS
THAN 1%.
CAN PARTICIPATE OR HAVE BEEN
PARTICIPATING SO THIS SHOULD BE
BE PERMISSIVE SO LITERALLY WOULD
BE A CASE BY CASE SITUATION.
I TRUST OUR QUARTER ACTORS ALONG
WITH OUR OFFICIALS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS REHAB
TO MAKE SURE WE CHOOSE THE RIGHT
INDIVIDUALS AND SO.
I THINK THIS IS A WISE DECISION
ASKING PRIVATE THANK YOU THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS
FOR AND I SPECIALLY WANT TO
THANK THE WITNESSES FOR COMING
AND HELPING US TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WAIVER RECALL PLEASE.
ITEM EIGHT AB TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LIMóN.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY HI MCCARTY AYE
MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ AYE MURATSUCHI.
NOT TWO G. AYE STONE.
OWN AYE.
NINE ZERO THANK YOU THE BILL
ITSELF.
YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEC [inaudible]
SOME [inaudible]
ALREADY [inaudible] TWO WEEKS.
YES WE ARE ACCEPTING
[inaudible]
YES.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FIRST I'D LIKE TO START
OFF BY SAYING THANK YOU AND YOUR
TEAM FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS
BILL RELATE TO RECYCLING IN
RESTAURANTS AND WE'D LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE SUGGESTIONS FROM THE
FROM THE COMMITTEE -- THE THIS
AS WE KNOW IS A BIG TOPIC FOR
THIS COMMITTEE IN CALIFORNIA HOW
WE FOCUS ON OUR AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE GOALS.
WITH RELATED WITH RELATIONSHIP
TO RECYCLING WE KNOW THAT -- WE
HAVE SEVERAL BASS LAWS THAT ARE
HELPING US STEP UP WHEN IT COMES
TO RECYCLING BUT MORE --
CERTAINLY -- CAN BE DONE.
IN -- IN RESTAURANTS WE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE RECYCLING IN THE
BACK OF THE RESTAURANT BUT NOT
ALWAYS IN THE FRONT OF THE
RESTAURANT AT SOME OF YOU WITH
THAT.
UP HERE WITH PARENTS LITTLE KIDS
YOU MAY KNOW IF YOU GONE TO A
RESTAURANT AFTER THE MEAL.
YOU HAVE SOME RECYCLING OR SOME
FOOD TO TAKE CARE OF AFTERWARDS
AND USUALLY THERE'S ONLY ONE BIT.
SO IN THE BACK OF THE RESTAURANT
THERE ARE MULTIPLE BANDS FOR
ORGANICS RECYCLING AND WASTE BUT
THE FRONT OF THE RESTAURANT WE
DON'T HAVE THOSE OPTIONS AND WE
NEED TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE.
THIS IS A GREAT PLACE TO START
WE KNOW THAT SOME RESTAURANTS
ARE ALREADY DOING THIS AND WE'LL
BE WORKING WITH THEM. TO STEP IT
UP AND HELP FOCUS OTHER
RESTAURANTS DOING THE SAME THING
THIS WILL HELP REDUCE OUR GHGS
HELP CALIFORNIANS LEARN HOW TO
PROPERLY SORT THEIR WASTE AND
RECYCLED.
AND ALLOW ALL OF US TO MAKE
SMARTER CLIMATE CHOICES I WITH
ME TODAY IS CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE THE SPONSOR THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU.
I CAPTION AGAIN THE COLLAPSE OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
WHAT WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE SPELL THE LEGISLATURE PASSED --
TWO PIECES OF LAW ONE IN TWENTY
ELEVEN ONE IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN REQUIRING
BUSINESSES TO HAVE A FIRST
RECYCLING SERVICE AND THEN
ORGANICS COMPOSTING SERVICE --
WHAT WASN'T COMPLETELY CLEAR WAS
WHEN THE BUSINESSES SUBSCRIBE TO
THIS COMPOSTING SERVICE AND
RECYCLING SERVICE?
DO THEY ALSO HAVE TO PUT OUT
BINS FOR THEIR CUSTOMERS.
AND MOST BUSINESSES HAVE PUT OUT
BINS FOR THEIR CUSTOMERS AS WELL
FOR THEIR FEW FOLKS WHO HAVEN'T.
AND THIS BILL JUST CLARIFIES
THAT -- WHAT WE THINK WITH THE
INTENTION OF THE ORIGINAL WANT
TO BEGIN WITH THANK YOU?
AIR MARINO ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
GIRL SOCIAIS SHIN -- ALTHOUGH WE
DON'T HAVE A SUPPORT POSITION AS
OF THIS MOMENT AJ ONE LADY ON
THE WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR -- COMMITTEE STAFF AND
ALTER STAFF TO SORT OF CLARIFY --
THE INTENT OF THE BILL IN TERMS
OF GETTING AT OR ORGANIC WASTE
BINS -- GROCERS TRADITIONALLY
HAVE BEEN ON ON THE CUTTING EDGE
OF OF WASTE REDUCTION THE WINNER
STAND WE HAVE DUTIES UNDER SB --
THIRTY THREE TO GET MORE WASTE
DIVERTED -- ALL OF OUR MEMBER
COMPANIES DO THIS -- ALREADY OF
FOR THEIR OWN SORT OF IN HOUSE
EFFORTS -- THIS WOULD -- GO A
LONG WAY TOWARDS -- ENCOURAGING
THOSE WHO HAVEN'T ANY GET TO
START DOING IT AGAIN WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH US A
MEMBER MCCARTY.
AND COMMITTEE STAFF TO CLARIFY
FURTHER -- WHAT THE BILL'S
TRYING TO GET AFTER SOME THANK
YOU SO MUCH?
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I'M CHAIR AND MEMBERS KELLY
JENSEN ON BEHALF RECOLOGY BETTER
SOURCE SEPARATION MEANS BETTER
RECYCLING IT'S VERY SIMPLE
THANKS FOR THE BILL. THREE
SEPARATE COVERAGE ON BEHALF OF
THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
LOOK AT US ON BEHALF OF STOP
WASTED SUPPORT. FOR COMMON THE
OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION A SECOND TO ANYONE
HERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL.
HI MATT SUDDEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION I AM THE SKUNK AT
THE GARDEN PARTY HERE -- I JUST
I WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HE HAS REACHED OUT EARLY
AND OFTEN ON THE ISSUE AND THE
HISTORY HAS BEEN OUTLINED BY
SOME OF THE SUPPORTERS CORRECTLY --
AND SO THIS THIS IS HAPPENING --
BEHIND THE RESTAURANT IT'S
USUALLY YOU KNOW BEHIND IN THE
ALLEY OR IN THE STREET OR
SOMETHING WHERE WE ARE RECYCLING
NOT JUST -- THE THE TYPICAL BLUE
BEEN RECYCLABLES BUT THE FOOD AS
WELL.
AND SO BRINGING THIS INTO THE
PUBLIC DINING SPACE INTO THE
DINING ROOMS -- IS AN AREA OF A
LITTLE BIT OF CONCERN BUT SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
REGULATIONS ARE UNDER WAY NOW
THEY'RE IN THE FORMAL RULE
MAKING PROCESS WERE AN ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT IN THAT.
AND SO I THINK WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR -- AND
OTHERS ON THE IS GETTING SOME
ALIGNMENTS WITH THIS LEGISLATION
AND THE REGULATIONS THAT AGAIN --
IN THE FORMAL RULEMAKING PROCESS
RIGHT NOW ALIGNMENT AND POLICY
AND ALIGNMENT IN IMPLEMENTATION
DATES IS IS WHAT WOULD BE
SEEKING SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO VOICE
THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE -- OTHER ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF COMMON TO
QUESTIONS THE SEGMENT -- THANK
YOU FOR BRING THIS FOR MISTER
MCCARTY.
HOW YOU DO EDUCATION AROUND THIS
IS YOU KNOW WE'VE MOVED TO THIS
MODEL IN OUR LOUNGE WHICH IS A
SMALL SAMPLE OF PEOPLE SORE
SUBJECT AS?
PEOPLE WHO SEEMINGLY WOULD KNOW
THE LAWS THAT WE PASS IN THIS
BUILDING.
AND EVERY TIME I LOOK IN THERE
AND I LOOK -- THERE'S ALL KINDS
OF THINGS AND IT SHOULD BE THERE
PEOPLE THROW THINGS IN ANY BAND
THAT.
EVEN ANY BUILDER SO WHAT'S THE
PLAN TO ACTUALLY MAKE THESE BE
FUNCTIONAL FOR THE GOAL THAT
WE'RE ALL TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
WELL I I TRUST OUR YOUTH AND I
TRUST LITTLE EMI AND BARBARA
VICTORIAN KIDS WHEN THEY SEE MY
RECYCLING BIN EITHER BROTHER YES.
YES.
IF YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THERE WILL
BE SOME -- EDUCATION ISSUES BUT
I THINK RIGHT NOW WE'RE SENDING
A TERRIBLE MESSAGE WHEN YOU GO
TO THESE.
ARE RESTAURANTS SUPER FOR FOOD
SERVICE ENTITIES AND YOU ONLY
HAVE ONE CHOICE.
THE TRASH CAN IF YOU HAPPEN TO
HAVE A BALLER ALUMINUM CAN.
YOU KNOW AT HOME YOU RECYCLE
THEIR THROW IT AWAY.
YOU HAVE A BANANA PEEL OR WHAT
HAVE YOU HALF EATEN HAMBURGER.
THROWING THE TRASH WHEN
EVERYWHERE ELSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A DIVERSION AND ORGANICS
AND COMPOSTING SO IT'S IT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO OUT -- SORT OUT -- LE PEN
INTENDED THERE AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION OTHERS TO TO DEAL
WITH THIS ISSUE GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
DO YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
HOW DID YOU LIKE TO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU ASK THE
RIGHT?
THANK YOU ROLL CALL PLEASE I
DON'T TWENTY ONE AB EIGHT TWENTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING [inaudible]
CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA I
LIMóN.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
THE I. MELINDA'S.
WHEN DOES NOT VOTING MURATSUCHI?
NOT TWO G. AYE STONE
[inaudible]
STONE AYE. SEVEN ZERO YOU WILL
HOLD ROLE IN.
THE ONE YEAH [inaudible]
WHAT?
YEAH.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MOVE THE BILLS.
SINCE WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND -- I AM ACTUALLY JUST
GOING TO HAVE OUR SUPPORTERS
QUICKLY AS SPEAK BECAUSE WE HAVE
THE MOTION A SECOND AND I KNOW
THAT THIS IS THE END OF THE
NIGHT -- YES LET'S REMEMBER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
STAMINA -- AND THANKS TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR ANALYSIS AND
WELCOME YOUR AMENDMENTS I'LL
JUST SAY BRIEFLY THIS BILL IS
INSPIRED BY TWELVE ADAPTATION
FOCUS GROUPS WE HELD WITH
FARMERS RANCHERS AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
STATE.
LAST FALL.
THE STORIES WE HEARD IN THOSE
FOCUS GROUPS -- INCLUDING THOSE
OF YOUNG FARMERS HAVE
EXPERIENCED COP FAILURES -- AND
SIGNIFICANT LOSSES IN THEIR
PRODUCTION.
AS WELL AS FROM FARMERS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY STRUGGLING TO
DECIDE WHAT TO PLANT IN THE
DECADES TO COME.
UNDERSCORES THAT FARMERS
RANCHERS ARE ALREADY
EXPERIENCING AND HAVING TO
MANAGE THE RISKS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THE STATE IS INVESTED A LOT OF
MONEY AND RESEARCH TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND AG'S VULNERABILITIES
AND SOLUTIONS -- BUT OUR FOCUS
GROUPS REVEALED THAT NOT ENOUGH
HAS BEEN DONE TO TRANSLATE AND
PACKAGE THAT INFORMATION.
INTO -- ACCESSIBLE PRACTICAL
TOOLS AND TRAINING FOR PRODUCERS.
SUCH ELABORATE ON THAT NEED HAVE
INVITED OUT DOCTORED TOUGH ON
POLITICS -- UC COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION SPECIALIST BASED EASY
MERCED.
AND AN EXPERT IN APPLIED CLIMATE
SCIENCE AND AGRICULTURE TO
ELABORATE ON THE NEED THANK YOU.
GET YOUR AND A MEMBER OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY THE
IMPORTANCE OFTEN DEVELOPMENT UP
ADAPTATION DECISION SUPPORT
TOOLS. TO MAKE CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURE MORE RESILIENT TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AND CLIMATE
RELATED RISKS FROM NEAR NUMEROUS --
CREDIBLE REPORTS RESEARCH AND
PUBLICATION INCLUDING THE ONE
THAT WE PUBLISHED RECENTLY IN
DURING THE GROUND ME.
AT TITLE CLIMATE CHANGE TRYING
TO IMPACTS ON CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE DETAILED REVIEW.
IT IS EVIDENT THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE POSES SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES TO CALIFORNIA'S
HIGHLY PRODUCTIVE ACCEPTOR.
DESPITE RESEARCH EFFORTS WE ARE
OFTEN CHALLENGED WITH
TRANSLATING RESEARCH INTO
ACTIONABLE INFORMATION RESOURCES
AND TOOLS. TO ASSIST GROWERS TO
MAKE STRATEGIC DECISIONS FOR
EXAMPLE US GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABILITY OFFICE REPORT.
ON CLIMATE CHANGE IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN MENTIONED THAT USDA
PIECES CHALLENGES.
OF TURNING THE LARGE AMOUNT OF
OFTEN TECHNICAL CLIMATE RESEARCH
INTO READY UNDERSTANDABLE
INFORMATION. ONE OF THE LEADING
RECOMMENDATIONS AND CDFA IS
CLIMATE CAN CONSORTIUM FOR
SPECIALTY CROPS REPORT WAS TO
COMPILE GROWERS NEEDS ARE
PROVIDE THE DATA AND FORECASTS
PRODUCTS TO ASSIST WITH DECISION
MAKING.
THERE'S A CLEAR AN IMMEDIATE
NEED FOR DEVELOPING LOCAL
DEVELOPMENT -- CROP SPECIFIC
AGRA CLIMATE DECISION SUPPORT
TOOLS AND DISSEMINATION PROCESS
DESIGNED TO GIVE A COMPETITIVE
EDGE TO INCREASE PRODUCTIVITY
REDUCING RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH
BOTH VERY ABILITY AND CHANGE OUR
CLIMATE RUDY AND CHANGE.
THIS TYPE OF EFFORT HAS BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL IN SOUTHEASTERN
UNITED STATES AS WELL AS IN THE
CENTRAL U. S. -- THOSE THOSE --
DECISION SUPPORT -- TOOLS ARE
CALL AGRO CLIMATE DOT ORG AND AT
CLIMATE FOR YOU DOT ORG.
AND TO THE BEST OF MY KNOWLEDGE
AND KNOWLEDGE OF SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES THERE IS NOTHING
SIMILAR TO THAT EXISTING
CALIFORNIA AND SO SIMPLY
DEVELOPING THIS TOOL IS NOT
ENOUGH.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO INVOLVED --
AGRICULTURAL CLIENTELE FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THE PROCESS UP TO
DEVELOPMENT ENSURE WILD WOOD BY
ABILITY AND INCREASED USABILITY
OF THE STALLS.
AND AND WE NEED TO PROVIDE
TRAINING ON THOSE TOOLS AS WELL.
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY AND AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
AND I DO WANT TO SAY THAT THEY
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES --
AMENDMENTS AND CHANGES THANK YOU
OTHER ANY JUST.
OTHER ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO WANT TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL.
ABOUT ANYBODY ALL OF A
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE IN THE CALIFORNIA
FOOD AND FARM NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
THERESA BURKE VERGE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMPOST COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
JUST MILAN FOR THE CALIFORNIA.
COMMUTER LINE TO FAMILY PHONE
THIS BUT IT IS IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ANY MEMBER ANY CLOUT
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THE SEGMENT.
YEAH I JUST LIKE TO SAY THANK
YOU MISTER MOAN AND IT ALWAYS BE
EVEN BETTER TO SEE MORE AG
SUPPORT YOU'VE GOT YOU'VE GOT
SOME OF THE OF THE NEW SHOULD
FOLKS BUT I SPENT THE FRIDAY ON
SUTTER COUNTY TALKING WITH.
A LOT OF FARMERS ABOUT YOU KNOW
AND EVERYONE WANTS TALK ABOUT
HOW DO WE KEEP UP WITH THE
REGULATIONS LIKE WE'RE DOING
WELL.
AND THEN YOU CUT OFF ONE OF OUR
ARMS AND THEN YOUR BRING PRESS
THAT WE KEEP ON DOING WELL THEN
YOU COULD OFFER OTHER ARM.
AND THEN DAR LEGS AND AND TRYING
TO KEEP FOREMAN.
SO.
I THINK WE NEEDED THIS IS AN
AREA THAT WE NEED TO REALLY PAY
ATTENTION TO AND I'M EXCITED TO
SEE YOU'RE DOING IT AND I JUST
HOPE IT DOESN'T THROW MORE
ROADBLOCKS BUT ACTUALLY PROVIDE
SOME PATHWAYS. FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE.
TO FOLLOW OUR REGULATIONS AND
CONTINUE TO STAY IN BUSINESS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND QUIVER ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM FIFTEEN A. B. FOUR OH NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMóN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA FLORA AYE CHAU CHAU
AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LIMóN HI LIMON AYE MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
AYE MURATSUCHI.
STONE.
STONE I TEN ZERO THANK YOU THE
BILL ITSELF I THINK THE LAST
BILL OF THE EVENING.
IT'S A MOVE BILLS.
IT IS A MOVE THE BILLS.
YOUR MOTION AND A SECOND SO I
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND -- TO I
DO HAVE MATT ROBINSON HERE I
THINK HI MATT.
IS.
HE IS GOING TO AS SAY IF YOU A
QUICK WORDS ABOUT BILL SHERMAN
ROBINSON THE CALIFORNIA GREEN
BUSINESS NETWORK.
AS THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT YOU
HEARD A VERY SIMILAR VERSION OF
THIS BILL LAST YEAR SO I'LL STOP
THERE AND JUST ASK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU HI THERE ANY ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK BE SURE YOU
COME UP QUICKLY.
ANYONE SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU ANY MEMBER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE ANY COMMENTS.
YOUR BUT I THINGS BRING HOME THE
ASPIRIN AYE.
THANK YOU WITH MOTION A SECOND
WAIVER ROLL CALL PLEASE I DON'T
SIXTEEN AB FOR SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THEM ON THE
MOTION IS TO PASS A REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I'VE
FLORA FLORA AYE CHAU CHAU AYE
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I LIMON.
AYE LOW MOAN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S MELENDEZ
AYE MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
STONE I TEN ZERO THANK YOU THE
BILLS OUT.
OKAY NOW WILL RETURN TO BILLS --
TEND TO VOTES ON PREVIOUS BILLS.
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH.
WE'LL GIVE MISTER MERRETT TO
CHIEF. FIVE MINUTES OR SHOULD WE
JUST WE A ROGUE ROAD AND THEN.
YEAH WHY DON'T WE LIST THE CALL
AND AND GO THROUGH THE BILLS
THEN I CAN ALWAYS.
HOLD THEM OPEN FOR HIM.
OKAY YEAH.
OKAY ON THE COMMITTEE RULES.
ADOPTION OF COMMITTEE RULES TO
ADOPT.
THE NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
ROLES FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY LEGISLATIVE
SESSION HER VOTE SIX TO TWO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS LIMóN.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY AYE AYE
MCCARTY AYE STONE.
STONE I NINE TWO ON THE CONSENT
ITEMS.
THE CURRENT GOAL IS EIGHT TWO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS LOW MOAN.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STONE.
SO.
NINE TEN ZERO ITEM ONE AB.
SIXTY FIVE DO PASSED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE FIVE ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE LIMóN.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I MELENDEZ MULLIN DESIRE
MURATSUCHI.
ROUTE TO GI.
TEN ZERO ITEM TO AB ONE SIXTY
ONE TING THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED REFER TO PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE
COMBO IS THREE TO THREE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAU.
FOUND NOT VOTING.
LIMóN.
LIMóN AYE.
MCCARTY BY MCCARTY AYE.
STONE.
STONE I SIX THREE ITEM THREE AB
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT BY DOLLY DO
PASS AS AMENDED CURRENT BEAU
EIGHT ZERO WITH THE TERM VOTING
I ABSENT MEMBERS LIMóN.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STONE.
STONE I TEN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO
MEMBERS WE HAVE NOW.
ITEM FOR AB ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
CRISTINA GARCIA DO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS.
CHAU.
CHAU I ELEVEN ZERO ITEM FIVE AB
TWO THIRTY ONE MATHIS TO PASS
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE.
THREE TO SEVEN WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING NO ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU NO. EIGHT TO THREE I'M
SORRY.
THREE TO EIGHT I DON'T SEVEN AB
TWO FIFTY SEVEN MATHIS TWO
PASSES AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE NINE TO ONE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAU [inaudible]
CHAO I GEN.
ONE ITEM A AB TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
MCCARTY TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CAR
VOTE TEND.
TO ZERO AS A MEMBER CHILD.
WELL I ELEVEN ZERO ITEM TEN AB
THREE FORTY THREE PATTERSON TO
PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE.
NINE TO ZERO ABSENT MEMBER
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STONE.
STONE I ELEVEN ZERO ITEM ELEVEN
AB THREE FIFTY TWO EDUARDO
GARCIA DO PASSED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE SIX TO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING CHAU.
CHAU I THE MOON.
THE MOON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING [inaudible]
EIGHT ZERO ITEM TWELVE A. B.
THREE EIGHTY THREE MASON
FRIEDMAN TWO PASSES AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CAR ABOUT SEVEN ZERO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS TRIAL.
TRIAL II Là MON.
Là MON I MATHIS.
MATHIS I CHEN [inaudible] ZERO
ITEM THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY SIX EDUARDO GARCIA TO
PASS REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE KERR ABOUT SEVEN ZERO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE LIMóN.
LOW MOAN AYE MATHIS MATHIS I
ELEVEN ZERO ITEM THIRTEEN AB
THREE NINETY FOUR OVER NO CHIEF
DO PASS AS AMENDED A REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE.
FIVE TO ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN.
HI FRIEDMAN I CHAU.
CHAU AYE GARCIA GARCIA I MON.
Là MON I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STONE.
STONE NO. TEN ONE ITEM FIFTEEN
A. B. FOUR OH NINE OF THE MON.
TO PASS AS A MENTOR REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT --
IS TEN TO ZERO AFTER A MEMBER
MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I ELEVEN ZERO ITEM
SIXTEEN A BEFORE SEVENTY LEMOND
TO PASS REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE. TEN ZERO
ABSENT MEMBER MURATSUCHI. TWO G.
I ELEVEN ZERO I AM SEVENTEEN A.
B. SIX SIXTEEN PATTERSON DO PASS
AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE. EIGHT TO ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELINDA'S
EYES SHONE.
STONE I ELEVEN ZERO ITEM
EIGHTEEN A. B. SEVEN FIFTY FIVE
BY HOLDEN TO PASS REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS.
CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO ONE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA NO [inaudible]
LIMóN.
LIMóN I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO
STONE [inaudible]
STONE I EIGHT ZERO I MEAN. EIGHT
THREE ITEM NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO BERMAN TO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE.
SEVEN TO ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
FLORA -- FLORA AYE GARCIA
[inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STONE [inaudible]
STONE I GEN.
ZERO ITEM TWENTY ONE AB EIGHT
TWENTY SEVEN MCCARTY DO PASS AS
AMENDED CURRENT VOTE.
SEVEN TO ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
CHILD.
TROUT I EIGHT ZERO ITEM TWENTY
THREE A. B..
TEN ELEVEN BY PATRICK NORRIS THE
MOTION TO PASS REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE IS FIVE TO ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA AYE EGGMAN [inaudible]
LIMóN.
LIMóN AYE MCCARTY. THIRTY AYE
MELENDEZ LANDIS I'M OUT TO G..
MURATSUCHI I GEN.
ZERO ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB.
TEN EIGHTY I GONZALEZ TO PASS
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT -- IS SIX TO
ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA NO [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELINDA'S
NO MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I EIGHT ZERO THANK
YOU OFFER